scp-1730 is one of the biggest threats
the foundation has ever faced
scp-1730 does not exist it was June 5th
when the compound was first discovered a
large complex of structures in rural
Texas about 15 kilometers Northwest of
the Mexican border located in Big Bend
Ranch state park it was easily the
biggest structure in the area but there
was no record of any such structure ever
being built a massive network of power
stations containment facilities and
research buildings scp-1730 looked like
it had been abandoned for a long time
the exterior was degraded but the
building was still operating a power
generator had been running for an
indeterminate amount of time even as the
infrastructure degraded power flickered
through the site and fuel leaked
frequently but there was one detail that
attracted the attention of SCP brass
scp-1730 for identifying markings
linking it to Foundation site 13 a
research facility that was marked for
construction near gnome Alaska but sites
teen had never been built having been
abandoned in the planning stages so why
is it in the middle of Texas fully
constructed and long abandoned the
foundation needed to know more and they
needed their best to investigate it was
time to call in the game wardens Apollo
3 the mobile task force used to
investigate dangerous sites was brought
in and five Elite agents were briefed
and sent in Ross Houston Noah ohalo and
Vigo it didn't take long for them to
discover that something was very wrong
with the site of scp-1730 the facility
was located in the middle of South Texas
but the local Flora surrounding it was
native to Nome Alaska something had
transported a building that shouldn't
exist to another place and time
Commander Ross ordered his men to enter
with Houston taking the lead they
discovered that the entry LED down a
long staircase they descended slowly
following a strange light that no one
could identify but had a sudden shock
when they discovered that the basement
of the staircase was missing the light
suddenly stopped and it became so dark
that it was in possible to see what lay
beyond the staircase upon probing the
inky black void at the base of the
staircase they determined it wasn't a
fog or Shadow it was a liquid and it was
Rising Ross ordered the men to pull back
but Houston was in 2D he couldn't break
three from the inky black liquid the
band pulled him away and got him free
but his legs were gone not ripped off
because there was no blood anywhere
smoothly cut off as if they were never
there and as they put Houston down he
stood up on Phantom legs he didn't feel
any pain but everyone could tell
something was very wrong with this place
and the messages they started seeing on
the wall made clear they weren't the
only ones who knew it what happened to
site 13 death here not my body bleed
there had been other people or things
inside scp-1730 and they wanted anyone
who entered to know that this was a very
dangerous place to be as they Advanced
down the hall back toward the entrance
they saw what looked like a person in
the distance but as they approached it
became clear it wasn't another Explorer
it was an old horribly disfigured corpse
seemingly attached to the wall not by
chains but views to the wall in
unnatural ways at first the team seemed
unconcerned recognizing the corpse as
someone named Zachary fortunately
command back at the base realized this
as the effects of some sort of Cognito
Hazard a mental infection in the base
they uploaded a filter to their helmets
and the team recoiled in horror at the
site in front of them but the horrors
were just beginning they turned around
to see a shimmering humanoid entity in
the hallway behind him as it approached
its footsteps distorted the hallway
around it pulled ap3 NOAA toward it
without touching him and as the soldier
was pulled into its clutches his body
started to distort Vigo was next being
grabbed by the arm by a long appendage
and his arm started to change color in
the store but the foundation sent Apollo
3 in prepared Houston produced a
portable reality anchor designed to
handle reality warping entities and with
a flash of red light the creature was
revealed it was a a horribly elongated
humanoid that only existed for a second
before the reality anchor erased it and
restored the hallway to its normal State
Vigo would recover with the strange red
color in his arm fading eventually Noah
wasn't so lucky he was already dead and
had been fused into the wall just like
the unfortunate corpse these Horrors had
been encountered just by trying to
return to the entrance so it was clear
the only smart thing to do was to
descend further into the facilities and
get some answers as they Advance not
encountering any other Supernatural
entities they saw more evidence of the
dark things that had occurred inside
their team the infirmary had been torn
apart a cafeteria had been melted into
slag and a large group of containment
cells ended with a section called
Olympia class but while most of the
other cells were standard sized these
were over 100 meters high what had the
foundation or whoever ran this place
been keeping in these cells they would
get more answers as they made their way
down the hall where they saw a single
television still working and
Illuminating the hallway at first the
television flickered but the image soon
cleared and the Agents were able to see
what it was broadcasting it was the
interior of a containment cell and there
was someone in it and they recognized
them as one of the most dangerous beings
contained by the SCP Foundation Bobble
the clown a predatory Supernatural clown
that inhabits a children's TV show
Bobble the clown was broadcast by an
unknown source and could only be seen by
children under 10 originally seeming to
be a normal kid show about a clown every
episode eventually devolved into the
murderous Bobble teaching kids how to do
horrible things like arson and torture
the foundation eventually captured an
isolated bobbles broadcast but the clown
remained hostile and vicious but not
here as the team talked to the Bobble
trapped in the mysterious site 13 it
became clear that this clown was broken
by whatever it had experienced it
rambled it hid from the camera and it
was clearly terrified as it told the
team about the horrors of the site and
it seemed to recognize the agents as
something familiar familiar but not
completely familiar he claimed to be
able to smell them and it said they
smelled different as Babel rambled on
the agents learned about a man named
Emerson who ran the sight like the
foundation he was obsessed with
containing the strange and dangerous
entities in the world but unlike the
foundation he didn't just want to
protect the world from them he hated
them the entities inside 13 didn't even
have numbers Emerson wanted to use them
up however he wanted him to dispose of
them and something Bobble called the
meat grinder entities that outlived
their usefulness were taken down below
and none were ever heard from again it
was directly counter to every SCP
Foundation policy but this site had
clearly been performing these horrible
experiments for years how and why hadn't
anyone heard of it the team continued to
make their way into the facility but
their signals were lost as they entered
the cryogenics unit by the time contact
had been restored they were no longer
alone there were survivors both agents
of the foundation and survivors of the
facility and they were angry with no way
out massively outnumbered they called
for backup mobile task force T5 also
known as samsara was reserved for the
heavy duty missions they're an elite
group of practically Immortal cyborgs
fashioned from the Flesh of a God and
equipped with further cybernetic
enhancements to eliminate keter Level
Threats and to protect themselves from
Cognito hazards they were sent in
through a drainage gate to look for
survivors and neutralize whatever lay
within they didn't know what to expect
but they knew one thing no one who had
been sent in had come out it wasn't long
before they realized how dangerous this
Mission would be as they came across
some large gated drainage pipes they
could see at least 20 charred bodies of
humanoids pushed up against the gate
some reaching their hands through
whatever had happened in site 13 these
unfortunate beings had been desperate to
escape as they made their way down the
drainage pipe they could feel it getting
hotter as if they were nearing an energy
source there was one other odd thing
about the pipe it was draining inward
not out they made their way into a
control room where men any of the
consoles had been destroyed looking
through a window their view was obscured
by a mysterious black mass on the
control panels they could read terms
like incinerator and body pit access
they split up trying to find answers but
found many of their accesses blocked by
the black mass as the T5 task force
argued over their next move they were
startled by a sudden jolt the giant mass
had started moving the team watched as
the mess spun revealing a giant turbine
which turned the inky substance into a
fine slurry That Was Then scorched by
giant streaks of fire one of the T5 shot
open the glass chamber allowing the team
to get closer and Blasting them with a
wave of heat as they descended into the
chamber they could see a massive
plant-like structure overhead which
started to shake suddenly thousands of
glowing pods were released from the
massive plant and each one lit up and
let the team view the chamber more
clearly but it was what was inside the
pods that was more disturbing each pod
had a humanoid shape inside seemingly
reaching toward the team until they hit
the slurry below and the shadow went
dark the team decided to investigate the
slurry when something started to leak
out of the walls looking at it they
could see something moving within one of
the team members picked up the wriggling
object out of the black liquid and it
took a bite of his hand it was a leech
and there were thousands more of them
moving toward the slurry consuming it
and as the leeches ate they started
growing they seemed to be moving in
unison communicating with a larger being
lurking at the base of the slurry a
larger leech a queen or something else
the team wasn't sticking around to find
out they beat A hurried escape from the
leech room finding themselves in another
hallway whatever the black substance was
the entities who had been here had used
it scrawling Blood on the walls over and
over again occasionally they would come
across a drained corpse covered in the
black fluid and the leeches bled them
dry the facility was so sprawling that
the team knew if they wanted any chance
of navigating it safely they needed to
get the lay of the land they needed to
find the control center the door red
stares to cryonics and the leeches were
nowhere to be found it seemed like a
but as soon as the team entered the
temperature dropped drastically to well
below where it would be safe for a human
to survive the team's internal heating
system kicked in to save their lives but
it wasn't the only threat the team was
about to encounter exactly what site 13
was keeping locked up as soon as they
entered the room sound ceased to work
the filters in their gear were
overloaded and the team saw warnings
around the room silence don't look a
massive multi-lim figure emerged with
each of its 60 arms moving independently
the creature had no head but a large
circular structure covered with ancient
glowing symbols whatever it was it was
ancient all-powerful and deadly the team
scrambled to get away as the glyphs on
the creature burned white hot anyone who
touched it was burned anyone who looked
too long at it felt their Optical
implants burn out the symbols on the
creature were indecipherable but one
word was clear and printed in English
Emerson site 13 was from another world
another timeline where the SCP
Foundation evolved into something
horrible ruled over by Elliot and it
tortured and captured its beings and
eventually killed most of them in the
horrors of the incinerators when an
escape threatened to destroy the
facility Emerson successfully activated
the device that removed the facility
from their world into hours of course as
any Avid follower of the SCP Foundation
will know there's far more to the story
than this Emerson may have been the
start of sight 13's problems but he was
far from the end it's the mission of the
century a daring rescue into the depths
of one of the most dangerous locations
in the Multiverse site 13 otherwise
known as scp-1730 when the impossible
site-13 was first discovered multiple
mobile task forces were sent to
plummet's Deaths and none returned they
were greeted to a labyrinth and
Nightmare littered with deadly Cognito
hazards escaped scps and mysterious
murderous leeches some were trapped
along with the civilians that were sent
to rescue others were killed or changed
in unimaginable ways mobile task force
Apollo 3 also known as the game wardens
had been sent in on a rescue mission
when they encountered a horrifying sight
the captured broadcast of Bobble the
clown a dangerous SCP known for
corrupting and destroying children
through its deadly messages but this
Bobble was different much like
everything from site 13 this bottle came
from an entirely different dimension and
he had terrifying information to relay
and the universe where scite 13
originated besides Psychopathic director
one Elliot Emerson had struck a deal
with the global Coalition a
controversial government group who
intends to protect Humanity by killing
anomalies rather than containing them
Emerson had converted his sight into an
unethical unrestrained slaughterhouse
and was incinerating scps by the hundred
in the so-called body pit but Emerson's
Game of Death came back and bit him
snapping the threads of reality and
turning the entire site into a
dimensionally displaced super anomaly
the game wardens realized they were in
way over their heads their chances of
surviving this place were dropping by
the second and if they wanted any chance
of succeeding in their mission they
needed backup so sight command called in
mtft AKA samsara calling in samsara for
a run-of-the-mill collection mission is
like using a bazooka to kill a housefly
but for a case as severe 1730 their
skills were not only nice to have but
vital samsara are among the best of the
best Immortal cybernetic clones forged
from the Flesh of a god equipped with
weaponry and technology that could
surpass even that of other Elite Mobile
task force units the four members of
samsara are so Adept at what they do
they earned the nickname Power Rangers
among their peers the remaining game
wardens knew that with samsara on the
case they may actually survive this
thing after all and they just needed to
hold out samsara arrived on site not
long after packing some serious
technological heat including arm mounted
incendiary cannons shock absorbing leg
extensions heat resistant plating and
built-in Scrabble adaptations within
their eyes to ward off the deadly
Cognito hazards everyone involved was in
for the fight of their lives the four
samsara agents Iran to nanku munru and
onru entered via a drainage gate in one
of The Office Buildings above ground and
began their descent inside after
observing numerous chart bodies they
deduced that there must have been a
massive incinerator somewhere on site
Emerson's incinerator theorizing that
this was connected to the body pit they
kept hearing about they descended
further feeling the temperature rise as
they did so due to the anomalous nature
of 1730 nothing inside made any kind of
logical sense cause caused by a reality
warping machine known as thresher the
internal geography of site 13 was
subject to constant shifts the team then
split up to cover more ground Monroe and
nanku continued to follow the pipes and
the heat toward the furnace while Iran
to an onru broke away to explore what
lay Beyond a weak wall after busting
through the wall iranu and onru explored
several empty office blocks before
finding their way into a control room
with a glass observation deck while the
window was obscured by garbage and human
corpses signage indicated that the
incinerator and the body pit were
directly below them the team once again
reconvened and managed to activate the
incinerator which shredded the mass
stuck inside with several large turbines
before burning the resulting slurry the
same process that had happened to so
many anomalies under Emerson's watch
with the path cleared samsara decided to
descend via the incinerator using the
drainage pipe as a kind of makeshift
tunnel eventually they happened upon the
leeches large black and hungry these
creatures seem to infest 1730 by the
Thousand anywhere that blood or drainage
runoff could be found the leeches could
be found too they didn't appear to have
any connection to an anomaly previously
secured and contained by the foundation
they squeezed and wriggled through the
cracks in the walls searching for fresh
blood on Route detected that the leech
is all moved with a kind of collective
purpose suggesting a telepathic hive
mind onru was able to tap into this Hive
mine using her cybernetic enhancements
and map the chaotic geography of 1730
through the leech colony's Collective
knowledge with this new Advantage they
could add a second goal to this Rescue
Mission find the thresher device causing
all the instability and potentially
reduce power to it if possible but they
were on the clock to save the other
survivors as those leeches were sure to
get hungry for warm blood soon they
followed the leeches down the most
direct path toward the survivors on the
way they encountered a horrifying
creature the many limbed humanoid
nightmare that functions as Emerson's
Eternal punishment his charred body tied
screaming and alive to the platform
where the monster's head should be they
managed to make it past the monster
before finally rendezvousing with
Captain Hollis of mobile task forces 8-9
otherwise known as the mole rats as well
as the game wardens and the other
survivors there were 27 surviving
members of site 13 staff many of which
had severe injuries making it even
harder to transport them back to safety
through the Hazardous terrain and to
make matters worse the leeches were back
the team quickly decided that the best
route out of here was directly past the
thresher where they could reduce power
to the machine for just long enough to
create a stable path of Escape nanku
opened fire on a horde of approaching
leeches with a flamethrower and everyone
began running for their lives it was a
final make or break Dash to safety
however their Advance was soon stopped
by a strange roped creature drawing a
Cognito hazardous meme on the wall with
its claws where the team attempted to
engage it attacked exposing additional
deadly memes and the dangerous effects
of its single white eye and we're not
talking about internet memes here these
are symbols and information that are
often deadly to even bear witness to and
for you or I this would be a real threat
but not to a team equipped with goggles
containing Cognito Hazard filter
technology the battle was cut short when
the floor collapsed underneath them and
the creature was devoured by something
even larger and more monstrous a
gigantic black leech covered in huge red
eyes its entrance caused thousands of
leeches to spill out into the Hall as
the monster screeched and slithered its
tentacles after them allow us to
introduce you to Elijah also known as
the leech boy and a pivotal component of
the very existence of scp-1730 he was a
boy with the mind of a toddler but he
had the strange ability to absorb blood
through people's skin hence his nickname
bleach boy one of the doctors in site 13
Dr Hadley took pity on Elijah after all
he didn't choose to be the way he was
director Emerson didn't share Hadley's
sympathy his orders to exterminate all
anomalies included humanoids like Elijah
when Hadley protested Emerson had her
beaten within an inch of her life while
other dissenters were shot Dr Hadley
disgusted by the inhumanity over
superiors devise the perfect Revenge she
sabotaged the incinerator and the body
pit allowing a mass Containment Breach
that flooded the site with deadly
anomalies young Elijah ended up
consuming the slurry of the other
shredded anomalies causing him to mutate
into a powerful monster a behemoth of a
leech who gave birth to and controlled
all the others it was Hadley's Revenge
that caused Emerson to panic and
activate thresher leading to a rift in
reality and the creation of 1730 and by
extension all the problems faced by Our
Heroes today samsara and the others fled
leech boy began taking a different
Escape round however while on Route they
encountered the dreaded Crystal
butterflies a dangerous SCP capable of
destroying organic matter with a mere
touch iranu stepped up to bat roasting
the creatures with his arm mounted
incinerator and taking extreme damage to
his body in the process but they didn't
have time to rest with the butterflies
disposed of they kept moving heading
toward the thresher but not all the scps
were necessarily working against them
Bobble the clown came in handy at the
next checkpoint manifesting in the
monitor of an electronic door and
opening the way through as they
continued on their Journey they had to
fight off frequent attacks from leeches
losing some of the task force members in
the process they were also forced to
face off against a number of other
anomalies in order to survive such as
scp-2316 manifesting his floating bodies
beneath them and scp-1370 which used a
huge mechanized body to attack the team
of survivors that was all just a warm-up
for the true final battle though the
floor shatters beneath them and out of
an impossibly huge chamber the monster
that had once been Elijah wriggled free
reaching for them with huge tentacles
and shrieking from its thousand-tooth ma
it was at least 200 meters tall and
barely reacted to any amount of
Firepower it seemed like they were all
doomed until Captain Hollis had a truly
crazy idea with the help of samsara she
led the bloodthirsty Abomination down
through the cryonic center and into an
olympia-class testing chamber there as
the leech boy was bearing down on them
Hollis opened the gates to two adjacent
containment cells and something Beyond
incredible habit two of the most
powerful scps ever known a giant sword
wielding gate guardian and the reality
bending Cosmic deer scp-2845 entered the
arena What followed was one of the most
epic showdowns in the history of the SCP
Foundation As the deer and the gate
Guardian went to battle against the all
devouring leech while the monsters
fought Hollis ordered her team to get
the rest of the survivors to safety she
and moon roof the samsara team remained
behind to prevent any of the anomalies
from escaping as the entire base began
sinking into the ground from the
combined forces of the battle raging
around them and the Threshers continued
Onslaught on reality even if the
survivors escaped with the anomalous
developments inside site-13 escape and
wreak havoc on the World At Large that's
when Hollis received a vision a horrific
charred post-apocalyptic World roamed by
inconceivably powerful entities and
Nightmare Gods it was a vision so
horrific that just seeing it nearly
broke her mind she knew what she had to
do the only way she could truly defeat
this terrible place and ensure safety
for mankind while leech boy the gate
guardian and the deer continued their
battle for the ages paulus ran to
thresher and forced the machine into
overdrive up above the remaining members
of samsara the mole rats and the game
wardens escorted the survivors to safety
downstairs thresher emitted a blinding
white light as the system began overload
in her final moments all Hollis could do
was a laugh perhaps it was a laugh of
pure Insanity of a mind broken by the
horror she witnessed or perhaps it was a
laugh of Victory knowing that in spite
of the immense Powers all around her she
had won the day she had saved not only
the survivors and her teammates but
possibly all of humanity and all it cost
her was everything outside the survivors
had reached a safe distance away when
the entirety of sight 13 imploded in a
final brilliant flash when the dust
cleared scp-1730 was gone all that was
left was an immense Crater where the
impossible base should have once been
Captain Hollis had done it through
overloading the thresher machine she'd
taken this anomaly out of the world the
exact same way it entered it was torn
from its Moorings on our Earth and
kicked into the Infinity of space-time
perhaps never to be seen again along
with everything it contained scp-1730
was reclassified to neutralized of
course the foundation would have plenty
of other anomalies to pursue soon after
but the nightmare of Emerson's sight 13
was over once and for all
a light shines above a metal table with
a chair positioned on either side this
is the isolated hermetically sealed
interview chamber of provisional site-23
outside the room Waits two shell-shocked
human mobile task force members another
with invisible ghost legs three powerful
cyborgs and a scientist From Another
Dimension they're all here to talk about
one thing the nightmare that unfolded at
site 13 also known as
scp-1730 everyone thinks they know the
story a mysterious sight suddenly
appears in Texas seeming to exactly
match the blueprint for an abandoned
site that's supposed to be in Nome
Alaska what started as a simple
anomalous location turned out to be an
epic horror From Another Dimension the
task force is sent in by the foundation
were either massacred or trapped inside
and those who survived reported seeing
unspeakable Carnage inside the base
including a death machine designed to
destroy anomalies and that's not all as
a result of the mysterious thresher
machine the entire location had been
transformed into a shifting space
anomaly filled with creatures straight
out of a nightmare from giant telepathic
leech monsters to huge multi-limbed
demigods that would eternally punish the
site's murderous director Elliot Emerson
it was only through the combined might
of three different mobile task forces
including the legendary samsara and the
sacrifice of Brave Captain Hollis that
the cursed location was finally flung
into a different dimension neutralizing
the thread it posed to our reality but
for the SCP Foundation the story doesn't
end with neutralization there's still
plenty more questions that need
answering and that's why today we're
going to tell you what they found out
after the neutralization of scp-1730 not
only will we discover what's become of
the many people involved we'll learn
about what happened in the last moments
before the neutralization took place and
perhaps most importantly of all for the
sake of our universe we'll find out how
sight 13 came into existence and how
site director Emerson went down such a
dark path it's time to get some answers
welcome to the final part of the scpc
1730 Saga as we closed the book on one
of the most deadly locations in the
foundation Multiverse first to sit down
in the interview chair was Captain
Ephraim Ross leader of the mobile task
force Apollo 3 also known as the game
wardens he was a shaken man looking far
older than his 35 years his eyes heavy
with the weight of the horrors he'd seen
and he and his team were among the first
to venture into the bowels of sight 13
and witnessed the atrocities that had
gone down there like the body pit full
of fleshy slurry or the countless
containment chambers that Mark their
occupants for vivisection and
termination Captain Ross was haunted by
the things that happened to his team
under his watch as the anomalous
transformation of Houston's legs and the
nightmarish warping death of Noah at the
hands of a stretchy reality-bending
anomaly he compared the state of chaos
going on down there to something like
Jurassic Park where all hell had broken
loose and the Monsters ruled he also
remarked on the Olympia containment
cells each the size of a football
stadium capable of containing things far
beyond the scope of this universes as CP
Foundation his interviewer was the
hard-nosed Dr Peter Vinson who thanks
Captain Ross for his contributions and
called in the next interview subject
agent Leah Mahalo a game wardens Task
Force member working under Captain Ross
he had a thousand yard stare and even
the untrained Observer could see that
agent a hollow had left some parts of
himself back in site 13 when Dr Benson
attempted to interview him he mostly
remained silent only volunteering one
Grim statement we should have died in
there this isn't real this isn't real we
were supposed to die in there next to be
interviewed was Captain Iran to of
mobile task force tau5 AKA samsara his
interviewer Dr Isha Saint Claire
questioned him about the nature of the
mission and the cybernetic Soldier was
even keeled about the matter he said
that in spite of regrettable losses of
life he was still satisfied with the
outcome of the mission overall the
high-value targets were rescued the
anomaly was for all intents and purposes
neutralized and the degree of loss was
actually better than their pre-mission
predictions it seems that the weight of
death doesn't weigh quite as heavily on
those who will probably never have to
experience it as the samsara team are
capable of Simply being rebooted into
new bodies if terminated in the field
people like Captain Hollis weren't as
lucky next agent Cotter Houston of the
game wardens was both interviewed and
medically evaluated by Dr Ian Harris
agent Houston had his legs
dematerialized after he tripped into a
rising tide of anomalous liquid which he
described as looking like a moving
physical computer glitch however in
spite of this agent Houston is still
able to stand and move of his own free
will it seemed to Dr Harris that
Houston's legs Were Somehow trapped
between Dimensions Houston told Dr
Harris that he didn't experience any
kind of pain when his legs were removed
but to this day he occasionally feels
something furry brushing up against them
perhaps wherever his legs are they
aren't alone next the stoic agent
moonroo of samsara was interviewed by
Captain Elliott O'Neill of mobile task
force d26 also known as time cops
Captain O'Neill had a bone to pick with
Munro namely that he'd allow Captain
Hollis to run off and sacrifice her own
life despite having a clear directive to
prevent the human task force members
from endangering themselves at any cost
moonroot deflected claiming that when
Hall is separated from the group he
assumed that she ran off with intentions
that never included her own demise
O'Neill and the foundation found this
answer unsatisfying and decided to move
on to their next interview with onru the
last person with Captain Hollis before
her death the interviewer Dr Darian
Arnold probed the elite samsar operative
on why she turned off her camera before
she and Hollis reached the thresher the
machine that Hollis overloaded to
annihilate site 13 from our Dimension
she gave a more compelling answer than
Munro when she and Hollis entered the
server room on the way to the thresher
they encountered what might have been
the ultimate Cognito Hazard it was a
vision of a terrifying alternate
Dimension with billions dead a poisoned
star like the biblical wormwood fell
from the burning Sky a nightmare God
like the one torturing Elliot Emerson
wandered along the fields of crucified
people covered in deadly Cognito
hazardous runes just looking at it
burned the scramble technology out of
moonroo's eyes and she quickly turned
off offer cameras to avoid potentially
frying the brains of Mission Control
Hollis wasn't so lucky the things she
witnessed broke her sanity in which she
finally overloaded the thresher machine
she was laughing and crying finally and
perhaps the most enlightening debriefing
interview of them all site director
William vesterland interviewed Dr
Muhammad Scott the highest ranking
researcher of site-13 and confidante of
the now Infamous director Elliot Emerson
the question was simple just what had
happened for site 13 to become so messed
up and Dr Scott answered in detail with
the tale of corruption alternate
realities and The Perils of unchecked
power in his home Dimension site 13 was
originally created in Nome Alaska to
house the corpse of a giant sea creature
that beached itself on the border of
India and Bangladesh in 1964. it became
the largest and most secretive
Foundation containment facility in the
latter half of the 20th century however
disaster struck in 1994 when a Marxist
extremist used an anomaly to level the
Willis Tower in Chicago as a result the
foundation lost a lot of its funding and
international support leaving it in dire
Financial Straits enter the True Villain
of the site 13 story Paul manafort if
that name sounds familiar to you it's
because he was an associate of President
Trump in our universe who got into legal
trouble for shady International dealings
however in Dr Scott's Universe he was a
powerful staffer for president Bob Dole
who in that reality had beaten Bill
Clinton in the 1996 presidential
election manafort was made the new
Secretary General of the global occult
Coalition the un's answer to the SCP
Foundation and one of their leading
competitors with an ethos geared toward
killing rather than containing anomalies
manafort into GOC co-opted the
struggling Foundation providing them
with money in exchange for control the
foundation had no choice but to accept
the deal with the devil slowly manafort
replaced the foundation Old Guard with
Toadies and Loyalists the Ethics
Committee in the o5 command were
dismantled dissenters were dragged out
of their offices and shot point blank in
the head execution style site 13 had
originally been directed by Dr right but
bright was arrested and contained under
false pretenses so manafort could
install a new director a mid-level
researcher by the name of Elliot Emerson
Emerson is often painted as a sadistic
monster who took pleasure in torturing
anomalies to death and flushing them
down the body bit the reality is both
simpler and more Grim Emerson it turns
out was just an eager yes man he was put
into his position to follow manafort's
orders to a T and those orders were
simple kill in a perfect example of the
banality of evil Dr Emerson converted
site 13 into a brutal slaughterhouse
just as his overlords at the GOC had
ordered him but things were quickly
getting out of hand and one of the most
vocal critics of the new regime was one
of Emerson's old lovers one Dr Vera
Hadley assistant director of anomalous
biology Dr Hadley was disgusted by the
inhuman ax Emerson was carrying out and
couldn't stay silent and for this she
faced horrific consequences corrupt
guard stripped her and beat her to
within an inch of her life in front of
her co-workers in that moment she swore
her revenge she sabotaged the
containment procedures and had the
engineers rig the already unstable
thresher device to overload as Emerson
watched the anomaly's great containment
he began to fear for his life both from
the anomalies themselves and from the
punishments of his superiors at the GOC
Dr Scott revealed that Emerson was no
evil mastermind he was a lap dog for the
GOC a dirty coward all the way to the
very end and he was desperate he held Dr
Scott at gunpoint and ordered him to
activate the thresher or die and the
rest is history there would be no
Redemption for Dr Scott's former friend
as Emerson ended up chained to the Rune
covered platform ahead of a nightmare
God for all eternity so ends the
debriefing of the site-13 survivors and
closes the book on that terrible place
for now anyway the story of scp-1730 is
anything but simple and there are so
many angles from which this dark tragedy
of Cruelty and Corruption can be
approached and ultimately it was all for
the same two things at the root of every
evil the desire for money and power but
the pursuit of these base desires can
lead to some truly nightmarish
consequences and nobody knows this
better than former director Elliot
Emerson who will be paying for these
sins until the end of time a swarm of
bloodthirsty entities Waits outside the
protective boundary that surrounds the
solar system they surge through the
vacuum of space looking for
vulnerabilities in the force field that
protects us from their destructive
Powers the creatures ran themselves
against the barrier again and again
trying to break through upon impact the
force field shimmers a golden color and
displays a series of thematurgical
symbols but it holds suddenly something
flies through the protective shield from
inside the solar system it leaves a hole
two creatures enter our solar system
before the shield closes this may be the
end for Humanity the sixth overseer sits
at a computer terminal massaging the
bridge of his nose he is just logged
into the foundation database to gather
information on anomaly whose intentions
are still unknown the o5 council wants
him to vote on an extreme measure but he
requires more information first there is
something coming he can feel it and he
thinks it has something to do with
scp-1548.05-6 straightens his back and
sits up in his chair he logs back into
the foundation database and brings up
the entry for
scp-1548 he knows that this SCP has been
connected to some odd occurrences
recently but what are its true
intentions is scp-1548 trying to help
save the universe or is it a malicious
entity hell-bent on destroying it 05-6
must find out he Scrolls through the
first few entries
scp-1548 itself is a series of solar
phenomena that occur at the South Pole
of the Sun during these events the sun's
plasma morphs into different
pharmaturgical symbols each symbol is
tens of thousands of miles across the
symbols themselves have not all been
classified by the foundation yet but
there are three that have been observed
multiple times the first is an unnamed
symbol that when inscribed on a
telescopic device by a person with
thamaturgical abilities can identify
psionic entities with malicious intents
the second symbol is known as the
calfastian aisle which when displayed on
a material strengthens it immensely and
gives it the ability to absorb kinetic
and electromagnetic energy the final
symbol is the 12 holy owls of cyrinthium
when this symbol is affixed to an object
any entity that is killed by it will
immediately annihilate and take
everything in its radius with it 05-6
jots a note on the pad of paper sitting
on his desk he has seen some of these
symbols before they are connected to the
ortafen mythology the practitioners of
this religion are known as the Church of
the second high top and are a mix of
human and alien entities whose main
purpose is to Aid the guardian deity of
the universe
in combating any threat that may try to
wipe out this existence there must be a
connection between the Church of the
second high top and
scp-1548-05-6 thinks he Scrolls back
through the scp-1548 file to the entry
logged on May 17 1983. the first time an
event connected to
scp-1548 was recorded a pro picked up
the manifestation of thematurgic symbols
on the South Pole of the sun it was odd
but nothing other than the manifestation
of the symbols seemed to occur this
event was recorded as extra normal
events 9008 and logged into the SCP
database the event was all but forgotten
until December 23 2016 when the activity
of
scp-1548 really began to pick up on that
day
scp-1548 began manifesting protection
symbols in Rapid succession over the
next few months a dense cloud of ionized
gas formed around the solar system this
iron wall of radiation surrounded the
heliopause the boundary where the sun's
radiation gives way to the vacuum of
space over time this Cloud became
thicker until no light from outside of
the solar system could enter Foundation
censorship protocols were quickly used
to disseminate false data suggesting
that the solar system was passing
through a dense cloud of cosmic dust and
that was what was altering the night sky
and causing the Stars to disappear but
as o5-6 continues to scan the files he
knows what the true cause of this
phenomenon is it must be scp-1548 but
why is the anomaly trying to protect us
from something outside of our solar
system or is it trying to trap Humanity
within with no means of Escape 05-6
stands up in stretches Ah that's enough
for today he says out loud to the empty
room he walks towards the door and
reaches for the handle all of a sudden
Sirens start going off and red lights
begin to flash 05-6 spins around and
runs back back to the computer terminal
an emergency alert begins coming through
the Falcon Lite 5 rocket that launched
earlier in the day to bring supplies to
the International Space Station has
spontaneously lost 50 percent of its
mass mid-flight 05-6 frantically begins
typing he brings up videos from
surveillance satellites the overseer
watches in horror as pieces of debris
and bodies of the crew flow through the
Silence of space the rocket looks like
it has been cut directly down the middle
and half of the structure has vanished
from existence what is happening
suddenly another alert comes in all
communication has been lost with the
International Space Station without
warning the space station begins
broadcasting a series of Cognito hazards
05-6 quickly changes the channel to stop
the signal from transmitting through his
computer reports start coming in from
around the world that anyone who
continued listening to the Cognito
Hazard signals began entering trances
then their brain completely evaporated
from their skulls there is a surge of
thymaturgic particles in orbit around
the Earth 05-6 traces the particles back
to their Source they came from
scp-1548 the signal from the ISS stops
abruptly the entire space station
changes course it is on a trajectory to
re-enter the Earth's atmosphere the
friction and heat will rip the space
station apart 05-6 can't believe what is
happening it seems as if scp-1548 helped
Humanity in a way by stopping the
signals from the ISS but how can he be
sure that scp-1548 wasn't responsible
for the Cognito hazards in the first
place he needs more information
05-6 searches for answers as more
anomalies connected to scp-1548 start
occurring around the world during a
political demonstration in Berlin a
thermaturgic way opens up that leads to
a pocket Dimension soon after the
appearance of the portal koru Arch
priest pharah attenus the leader of the
Church of the second high top makes an
announcement he claims that the way
leads to a shelter which will protect
people from the coming Doom of the
universe the people in the area along
with the members of the Church of the
second high top make their way into the
portal two undercover Foundation agents
follow the group after everyone has
entered the way immediately closes and
there is no further contact what does
the church of the second high top know
that we don't 05-6 wonders he continues
monitoring the situation and looking for
answers suddenly a message comes through
all Foundation channels it is coming
from the Sun it is not as
cp1548 instead it is
scp-179 the humanoid permanently in
space near the sun 179 sends out one
clear word in its signal defend who is
scp-179 talking to 05-6 thinks what
needs to be defended is it Humanity our
solar system the universe another alarm
begins to go off what now 05-6 screens
he brings up the alert the screenplay
flashes to the Moon 05-6 focuses in on
where the alert is coming from it is a
foundation Base called area 32 what
remains left of the base is reporting
that
scp-2821 suddenly expanded in size
formed a wormhole that led to another
region of the universe and then vanished
through it taking 38 Foundation members
and 10 anomalies with it Sirens continue
to go off distress signals are being
picked up on every channel it seems as
if the world is coming to an end and
everything that is happening is somehow
connected to
scp-1548 a static field transmission
begins coming in from scp-3417 the words
are Urgent all are toughens here all our
tousins must listen now the stars are
lost static breaks up the transmission
for a few moments before it resumes ago
the first Invasion occurred the gods
were unprepared never comprehending the
fragility of the universe after its
creation the worlds must fight the
transmission cuts off everything goes
silent a pulsating SCP icon appears on
the screen of 05-6's computer it is the
part of the puzzle he has been waiting
for in 1999 the o5 council unanimously
voted to launch a mission called serif 1
to explore beyond the heliosphere and
the mission's true purpose was to
explore the plausibility of
extraterrestrial SCP objects in Space
the message that 05-6 just received is
from serif 1. it is relaying information
back to Earth the video shows the
barrier of ionized radiation that
scp-1548 had created glowing orange at
the border of the heliopause the
radioactive wall seems to be made up of
complex geometric patterns around 6 000
miles across serif1 accelerates towards
the barrier it smashes through the
protective shell the probe has entered
Interstellar space 05-6 knows that
everything he is seeing is on a delay as
the information being sent back by
serif1 needs to travel vast distances
and it takes significant time for
signals to reach Earth after passing
through the ionized barrier the
connection to serif 1 is lost over the
next few days 05-6 tries to link the
anomalies happening in the solar system
to scp-1548 the foundation still hasn't
concluded that 1548 is harmful or trying
to protect the solar system in some way
then a message comes in from serif1 it
is briefly regained communication with
the foundation most of the probe's
instruments have been destroyed but its
rear-facing camera is still broadcasting
05-6 pulls up the feed he stares at the
screen in horror as the images unfold
before him the camera captures swarms of
unknown entities surrounding the
heliopause the bodies of the entities
are asymmetrical with countless
appendages and unknown structures
jutting out from their cores they seem
to range in size from 10 kilometers to
10 000 kilometers across although some
seem so large that their size can only
be hypothesized the Swarms crash into
the protective barrier that scp-1548 has
created around the solar system each
time part of the swarm Rams the barrier
thousands of thamaturgic symbols and
solar flares appear at the point of
impact two entities that are later
classified as 1548 Omega 1 and 1548
omega-2 are captured entering the solar
system by serif ones camera video from
serif 1 shows that as the probe exited
through the protective barrier it
created a hole that remained open for a
few moments during the time that the
shield of ionized radiation was
vulnerable
1548-omega-1 and
1548-omega-2 entered through it they are
now inside the solar system
scp-1548 launches countermeasures in the
form of glowing red sigils that create
shock waves to slow down
omega-1 and omega-2
omega-1 is shaped like an EO with five
contorted arms radiating from its body
and a mouth made of impossible geometric
shapes omega-2 has a tetrahedral
structure that leaves a trail of black
rocks in its wake as the two entities
move towards the sun
scp-1548 becomes more active it closes
the hole in the barrier before any other
creatures of the Swarm can enter and
then launches hundreds of concentrated
blasts of thumbic energy at omega-2 the
flares vaporize the entity in seconds
the last thing the video feed of serif-1
captures before it cuts out is omega-1
disappearing from view as it creeps
towards the center of the solar system
it has escaped the protective measures
of
scp-1548 after the o5 council reviews
the footage they decide to deploy the
scps Cortana to intercept omega-1 the
orbital vessel is fully equipped with
experimental anomal Us weapons and
propulsion systems the council is sure
that the Cortana will be able to destroy
omega-1 data coming in from other
satellites indicate that omega-1 has
destroyed Pluto another Kuiper Belt
objects it is slowly making its way to
the center of the solar system
annihilating everything in its path the
Cortana intercepts omega-1 near Jupiter
and engages the creature after 10
minutes of battling communication with
the ship is lost probes in the area
capture footage of the Cortana and
omega-1 in mid-battle when they are
suddenly surrounded by a black substance
and both vanish from sight 05-6 and the
other council members watch in
anticipation unsure of what has just
happened then the black substance
dissipates the scps Cortana sits
Motionless In Space the entity is
nowhere to be seen a cheer erupts from
the overseers and Foundation members in
the room it seems the entity has been
defeated then without warning the Quran
Anna accelerates rapidly it is on a
collision course with Mars as the ship
hurdles past one of the probes in the
asteroid belt the foundation members see
an organic Mass resembling that of
omega-1 attached to the hull of the Shem
the overseer Council watches in horror
as the scps Cortana smashes into the red
planet leaving a crater 215 miles wide
the energy released from the impact
instantly ionizes the thin atmosphere of
Mars causing the surface to turn into
molten rock from the epicenter of the
impact crater a black organic Mass
begins to crawl across the planet the
overseers are frozen in fear but
scp-1548 immediately deals with the
entity that is devouring the surface of
Mars from the Sun comes the largest
scp-1548 instance ever recorded a solar
flare is jettisoned towards Mars the
impact causes of fusion reaction so
intense that for a moment Mars shines as
brightly as the sun the planet explodes
its debris is cast across the solar
system over time it will create a second
asteroid belt in the orbit that Mars
once inhabited the overseer council is
now convinced that the threat has been
dealt with
scp-1548 is holding the Swarm at Bay
outside of the solar system at least for
the moment 05-6 returns to his office he
brings up the file on scp-1548 he is
still unsure of this scp's true
intentions it seems to be protecting
Humanity but why 05-6 sits back in his
chair and Scrolls to the end of the file
there is an update to the file by 05-3
something that wasn't there before
05-6 opens the new entry and reads the
caption all that's left of our infinite
ever expanding Universe 05-6 Scrolls
down the images a picture taken by
serif1 before contact was lost forever
it is a picture of All That Remains of
the Universe there are two dots of light
and nothing else but Blackness the Swarm
has destroyed everything in the universe
except for those two far away stars and
our own solar system which was protected
by
scp-1548 but how long can it hold out
against a universe destroying Force only
time will tell Dr Dan anxiously paced in
his cell it was the only way he'd been
able to occupy himself for the past six
months save for pouring through files
and when he was lucky being able to
oversee another failed termination
attempt he only stopped pacing when for
a brief and horrible moment he realized
that monster was probably doing the
exact same thing in its big metal cube
at this very moment that horrible
creature that he'd thrown away his life
for a feudal shot at killing perhaps the
whole thing had been a Fool's errand
after all he was formerly a researcher
under the employee of the SCP Foundation
secure contain protect they had truly
sadistic beasts like scp-106 the
nightmarish old man and scp-352 Baba
Yaga in containment cells and there was
no plans to terminate either of them
they weren't the global occult Coalition
for 343's sake why did Dr Dan even want
to terminate
scp-096 in the first place he tried to
explain it to them again and again but
his pleas had fallen on deaf ears in his
mind the impetus for destroying the shy
guy was terrifyingly clear it was a
monster that killed anyone or anything
that looked at its face even a
photograph of it even a tiny collection
of pixels when its rage state was
induced it seemed that nothing would
stop it it would have an intuitive
psychic link to its victim charge at
them at Breakneck speed and only find it
Zen again once all of them were dead
and if a picture of scp-096 was leaked
onto the internet it would cause a chain
reaction that triggered an XK class and
the world scenario there were plenty of
creatures and entities that the
foundation knew about that could
theoretically bring about the apocalypse
but to him 096 was the most realistic he
preyed upon the inherent curiosity and
thirst for knowledge seeded in every
human heart the same drive to Simply
know that led to the creation of the SCP
Foundation would be Humanity's Doom in
the face of an scp-096 outbreak and if
such a thing happened the foundation
would need to break the Masquerade of
secrecy to have any hope of saving
Humanity in his many feverish nightmares
Dr Dan had seen it all so clearly the
first photographs of scp-096's face
would be leaked online perhaps a few
hundred people across the globe would
look in disparate enough locations that
it would be almost impossible for the
foundation to detect and save all of
them as
scp-096 went on its bloody Rampage of
course as the image proliferated as
images on the internet often do the
purview of 096's violence would only
grow people across the nation would
start to take notice and soon after that
across the world mysterious creature
causing Mass casualties would be the
headline on every news desk because why
would anybody want to talk about
anything else perhaps some foolish
reporters would take video footage of
the creature everyone has a phone these
days with high definition cameras
pictures would be taken and posted more
and more of it would flood the internet
too many simultaneous moles for even the
SCP Foundation to whack the news would
spread panic and hysteria would spread
people wouldn't even know what's
triggering all this horror if the
foundation didn't go public and tell
them that it was the pictures that was
killing everyone and by then wouldn't it
already be too late the antidote to fear
is knowledge it's why when anything goes
wrong where refreshing timelines and
feeds and news websites for any kind of
information and if you were told an
Unstoppable monster was killing scores
of people and might be coming to a
neighborhood near you sometime soon
wouldn't you want a good look at it
wouldn't you want to know your enemy
having no idea that the mere Act of
knowing was what sealed your horrible
Fate by Dr Dan's Bleak estimations if
only several million people died as a
result of this kind of scenario it could
be considered a positive outcome he'd
seen it all but no matter how many times
he tried to articulate this to his
superiors he wasn't listened to they
didn't take him or the threat that
scp-096 posed seriously every time he
warned of the apocalyptic potential of
scp-096 he was simply told to get back
to working on those
it was why he needed to give those
naysayers a demonstration it was why a
certain photograph needed to show up in
the home of a certain Mountaineer it's
why all those people had to die there
was no other way the deaths of the
civilians and the researchers and the
mobile task force members were of course
regrettable but it was the only way to
prevent the deaths of so many more they
gave him what he wanted permission to
put this gangly time bomb in the ground
even if the beast's death was
inextricably tied to his own execution
at the hands of the very employers who
authorized him the world was full of
funny little ironies like that another
one is that even though Dr Dan now had
the authorization and funding to
terminate
scp-096 he was discovering that he
lacked another important factor the
capability they tried incinerating it
exposing it to massive amounts of
radiation Expo closing it to an insane
degree of kinetic trauma the equivalent
of being hit by an out-of-control bullet
train they tested every kind of
experimental off the books Weaponry that
they had access to through various
research projects proton blasts lasers
high intensity energy beams nothing even
when they fried off every scrap of flesh
on the monster's body its unbreakable
skeletons still remained and in what
seemed like no time at all it'd be back
in Action its very existence seemed to
mock him a guard opened his cell door
staring disdainfully at the disgraced
researcher that same guard had slammed
his head against a wall a month earlier
one of his friends had apparently been
killed in the legendary 096 Containment
Breach that set this whole sword thing
in motion up an atom scumbag he sat in
the gruff's early voice training a
handgun on the doctor he knew wouldn't
fight back they need you in test chamber
6. Dr Jan allowed himself a small grin
imperceptible to the guard who clearly
hated his guts they'd approved his 096
vs 682 cross test marvelous how
marvelous to all the others it would
seem like just one more entry in a long
line of 682 cross tests he thought it
Darkly funny in his eyes the foundation
had no hope of ever killing
scp-682 its defining quality was being
impossible to kill and it didn't present
nearly the threat to the entire world
that 096 posed their futile attempts to
murder the lizard were little more than
a money sink to justify the site's
exorbitant funding but perhaps he could
turn this to his benefit maybe scp-682
would hold the secret to actually
killing off his Nemesis within 30 hours
Dr Dan had his disappointing answer both
anomalies had undeniably done a real
number on each other and Dr Dan did take
a kind of sick Amusement in the mental
trauma that scp-682 had induced in 096
But ultimately it was all for nothing
682 had skin 096 alive and melted off
its flesh with acid but once again that
indestructible skeleton stood firm this
had been the 27th termination attempt
since the incident the 27th failed
termination attempt Dr Dan mentally
corrected himself
096's skeleton kept defeating them even
their most Ardent attempts to penetrate
the bones and destroy the creature
within had failed during a previous
attempt they tried to access the brain
by putting a diamond hard drill into its
eye sockets of course it was the drill
that actually broke much to Dr Dan's
seemingly tireless frustration needless
to say in the debriefing interview with
Dr Carver a researcher who once would
have considered him a colleague he
wasn't in High Spirits if he managed to
kill this thing then he would always be
the hero who made a terrible sacrifice
in order to save many more lives if he
didn't kill 096 he was little more than
the monster who murdered all those
innocent people for nothing though you'd
never hear him say it out loud if it
wasn't for that damnable indestructible
skeleton this monster would be long dead
already if only there was some way to
break the creature's bones that's when
it hit him
SCP-173 the sculpture a site 19 icon
often overlooked because of its more
silent but deadly style but undeniably
one of the most frightening and
dangerous anomalies out there it had
racked up a truly shocking body count
since it was first interred at site 19
in 1993 one broken neck at a time and
it's one of the few creatures out there
that even the hard to destroy reptile
himself is utterly terrified of perhaps
a monster that practically has a PHD in
breaking bones would be the ideal
candidate to vandalize the Shy Guy's
vertebrae once his proposed proposal was
greenlit for initial testing Dr Dan
arranged for the shy guy with a bag over
his head of course to be brought into a
testing chamber with the ever stoic
SCP-173 when all the researchers and
guards were safely outside all it took
was a single blink to make all of Dr
Dan's darkest dreams come true in the
nanoseconds his eyes were closed he
heard the most beautiful sounds in the
world a loud fleshy Crunch and a pained
howl from 096 he opened his eyes to an
equally wondrous sight 096 doubled over
at an unnatural angle its spine snapped
between the fourth and fifth vertebrae
spinal fluid leaking down the creature's
flank that freaky little sculpture had
done it it had actually damaged the
Integrity of the Shy Guy's skeleton it
was at that moment that Dr Dan knew he
could kill this thing admittedly there
was a Containment Breach shortly after
that when the bag slipped off of of
096's head can it charge through the
nearby steel wall killing multiple
people before being subdued and
recontained but when it comes to
projects involving Dr Dan a mere handful
of innocent people being killed sits
comfortably within the acceptable margin
of error a day later Dr Dan was standing
before a crowded boardroom with agents
researchers and even a few members of
the o5 council in attendance he
explained his findings to them and the
fact that even more importantly they may
have a way to bring The Wretched
existence of 096 to an absolute halt his
plans were approved not long after he
was putting them into motion Dr Dan was
surrounded by researchers and heavily
armed guards as 173 was escorted into
the test chamber with a forklift 096 was
there still bagged off to the side was a
giant tub of hydrofluoric acid connected
to a hose and injector attachment if
this didn't work nothing would everyone
stood back in a safe Zone as 173 was
released to do its thing crunch just
like the previous time 096's spine had
been successfully snapped spinal fluid
dribbled down its skin everyone had
rushed into the chamber one grouped kept
173 isolated with their stairs the other
headed by Dr Dan prepared the acid
injector and shoved it into the breach
in 096's spine as the acid was pumped by
the gallon into 096's Bones the creature
let out the most horrifying whale it
kicked and bucked as more acid was
pumped in melting those indestructible
Bones from within the creature even
began to vomit acid as it panicked
melting the bag off of its own head some
panicked and averted their gaze Dr Dan
didn't he stared directly at the
creature's face for the first time as it
melted in front of him with nothing
short of pure relation heading one had
he actually won the creature let out a
gurgling shriek and the guards opened
fire their bullets splattered into the
monster's melting Flesh and Bones as it
hollered and treat they didn't let up
firing up and down its body spraying it
with white hot lead it began to melt and
bubble away expanding into a great
gruesome puddle on the floor beneath
them Dr Dan laughed like a madman even
as the guards grabbed him and dragged
him away from the foul-smelling greasy
mess bubbling with chemical life he just
kept laughing even though he knew the
death of 096 meant an equally Swift
death of his own it didn't matter it had
all been for something the world was
saved it was over he'd finally won on an
ordinary day in 1991 a Young Man known
by the initials JS went on a hike with
four of his friends on the wooded
outskirts of their small town everything
seemed perfectly normal until JS began
to feel a strange sense of familiarity
like he had been in this spot before he
couldn't shake this weird feeling but
thought nothing more of it little did he
know that this was a sign of deadly
things to come several hours after first
experiencing that sense of deja vu JS
was found by the side of the road
covered in cuts and scratches with his
friends nowhere to be found this is the
story of scp-939 an unforgettable
monster that you'll never remember
there was no way for JS to know that the
unsettling feeling he felt and the
horrors that followed it were the result
of an experiment conducted by the SCP
Foundation an experiment with deadly
unforeseen consequences
JS and his friends were exposed to a
substance known only as amn c227 as part
of a series of tests performed by the
SCP Foundation intended to determine the
effectiveness of this substance as a
deliberate and knee stick
dealing with as many mysterious secret
creatures and objects as they do
the SCP Foundation has long needed a way
to tamper with the memories of those
exposed to the foundation's various
prisoners and test subjects and when the
foundation discovered amnc227 it seemed
like it might be perfect for this
purpose so where did amnc227 come from
over a year before the incident with JS
and his friends the SCP Foundation
captured
scp-939 scp-939 is a species of
endothermic predators that live and hunt
in packs
their designated ketter class and
regarded as highly dangerous and hostile
to human life native to caves they have
no eyes translucent red skin and stand
at an average of 2.2 meters tall with an
average weight of 250 kilograms they
have four limbs each ending in three
fingered Claws and a fourth opposable
digit resembling a thumb
in addition to their sharp claws their
mouths are filled with red fang-like
teeth that reach up to six centimeters
in length
in place of their absent eyes they have
light sensitive spots running along
their backs
which are covered in spines believed to
detect changes in air pressure and flow
in addition to their many other
terrifying attributes the internal
anatomy of scp-939 poses a biological
mystery these creatures have no
circulatory system and no digestive
tract that's right in spite of being
Predators seemingly acting on a need to
feed they have no stomach instead when
they eat their food builds up in their
respiratory system until its presence
inhibits function and then it is
regurgitated in spite of being a
creature that should not under any
logical conditions be able to live
scp-939 continues to persist and is even
capable of giving birth to live young
after a gestation period of 12 months
the SCP Foundation was able to study a
litter of these young that were born in
captivity in September of 1992 though
the creatures remained just as much of a
scientific mystery as they were upon
first discovery
everything about them seems to defy the
logic of the natural world which to be
fair is really nothing new for the
foundation the respiratory system of
scp-939 was found to Exhale small traces
of an airborne amnestic substance given
the name amn c227 this compound blocks
the formation of memories for the
duration of exposure to it plus a
30-minute period following the exposure
give or take a few minutes it is
colorless odorless tasteless and
completely undetectable in the
bloodstream after only 60 Minutes amn
c227 was approved for use as a Class C
amnestic by the SCP Foundation in 1990
following some initial tests however
after one particular incident involving
a young man and his friends the official
use of amn c227 was suspended JS and
three of his four friends were
previously given a dose of amn c227
though the details of why they were
given the amnestic has since been
stricken from the record
several months after being exposed to
amnc227 JS and his friends went out on
their ill-fated hiking trip while hiking
JS was suddenly overcome with the sense
of deja vu when he mentioned it to his
friends three of them agreed that they
had felt it too one of the group another
young man who had not been exposed to
amnc227 was uncomfortable and decided to
go home
JS and the remaining three members of
the group made the choice to stay in the
woods and try to determine what was
triggering the unusual feeling of
familiarity as they got closer and
closer to a large cave near the hiking
trail the sense of having been there
before grew stronger and stronger
armed with only one flashlight and a
foolish curiosity the four went inside
the cave they made their way deeper and
deeper and deeper into the darkness not
knowing why they felt this way or what
they might find inside none of the group
could explain just what felt so familiar
only that the further they made their
way into the cave the more pronounced
the feeling became it was getting late
and they knew they should have been
afraid to venture so deep into a cave
with only one light source and no
knowledge of what lay inside but still
they pressed on one of the group
remarked that they should turn back but
the others refused to listen they wanted
to know what they were getting close to
what was drawing them deeper and deeper
into the cave unfortunately for them
they would get their answer in the heart
of the cave was a pack of scp-939
waiting patiently for their prey to
wander into their domain there are no
witnesses to account for what exactly
happened to JS and his companions but we
can reasonably piece the events together
from what happened after once the
friends reached the heart of the Cave
the creatures were on them in seconds
raking them with their sharp claws and
biting with their
scp-939 are larger and stronger than
most people so it was probably not much
of a fight however while his friends
were being devoured JS was somehow able
to scramble out of the cave and make his
way into the woods in search of help
under the influence of the AMC 227 that
had built up in the cave from the
presence of the pack of scp-939 JS lost
a large portion of his memory of the
event he found himself on the side of
the highway late at night seriously
injured and his clothes ripped an
officer found him there and asked him to
stay still and remain calm until an
ambulance could arrive JS was still in a
panic and attempted to run away from the
officer begging to be released so that
he could get away he babbled
incoherently about the color red
screaming over and over again about the
red though when prompted he could not
explain what the red he was screaming
about referred to his friends were not
with him just as the officer managed to
calm JS the ambulance arrived its
flashing red lights sent him into
another frenzy and he attempted to
escape custody claiming that the red
lights were going to get him the
official police report described JS as
perhaps being under the influence of a
powerful hallucinogen that he was just
having a bad trip but the SCP Foundation
knew better
the foundation conducted an interview
with JS about his experience and
determined that scp-939 was certainly
involved as part of their cover-up
effort they strongly implicated JS in
The Disappearance and the death of his
friends he was convicted of manslaughter
though the bodies of his friends were
never found it is rumored that the SCP
Foundation hired him on a prison work
release program
and that he now works as a member of the
janitorial staff at one of the
foundations facilities
this incident led to the suspension of
the use of amn c227 as it revealed some
vital and disturbing information about
the compound side effects after the
exposure to amn c227 a person who found
themselves exposed to it again would
experience a sense of familiarity and
felt compelled to investigate the source
of this feeling essentially anyone
treated with amn c227 are not made aware
of the existence and danger of scp-939
would become a perfect victim primed to
be attracted to dens of scp-939 it is
likely that this side effect is not a
coincidence but rather a deliberate
hunting tactic designed to attract prey
that had somehow managed to escape with
no memory of their attack at the hands
of scp-939 this previous intended prey
would find themselves drawn to the same
Den or even a new one not knowing that
they were walking back into near certain
death while the SCP Foundation suspended
the use of amn c227 as a Class C
amnestic they did recruit a team of s CP
field operatives to take advantage of
this side effect this team of operatives
were deliberately administered a dose of
amnc227 and briefed on its effects as
well as the dangers of following the
feeling of deja vu should its surface in
the field these infected officers were
essentially used as Bloodhounds relying
on any sense of unusual familiarity to
sniff out new dens of scp-939 so they
could be captured and contained by the
foundation
as far as we know this operation is
still ongoing today however now that the
foundation has a sufficient number of
specimens to study additional dens of
scp-939 that are discovered are ordered
to be immediately destroyed as for the
scp-939 still in captivity they are
contained in environmentally regulated
and negatively pressured cells with
walls of reinforced concrete the doors
to the cells are airtight to prevent the
leakage of any amn c227 and any
Personnel that interact with one of the
creatures is required to wear level C
Hazmat gear to avoid exposure and follow
decontamination procedures upon exiting
the cell all scp-939 have subdermal
tracking devices implanted to find them
in the event of Escape
only one scp-939 has given birth in the
time that the creatures have been in
captivity strangely scp-939 young look
indistinguishable from Human infants and
change their physical appearance at some
yet unknown Point as they age if any
more offspring are produced they will
immediately be separated from the parent
and studied all that we know is that
they are found in caves in the woods
outside of a small town it could be any
town even yours so if you're ever out
hiking and struck with a sudden feeling
of deja vu
don't investigate don't get curious
just go home
it might just save your life the SCP
Foundation has faced a number of wide
potentially apocalyptic threats in its
mission to uphold normalcy and save
Humanity we know the SCP Foundation
could be ruthless in this Mission the
events of scp-5000 before agent Pietro
restarted the Universe show what happens
when the foundation is pushed to its
final decisions regarding normalcy being
upheld in scp-5000 it seemed that the
SCP Foundation decided to seize research
further into the anomaly they needed to
neutralize but what would have happened
if they didn't in any case we know the
SCP Foundation is dedicated to normalcy
and the containment of the anomalous but
what happens when the SCP Foundation is
faced with a dire decision uphold
normalcy or destroy their Universe the
Multiverse is a concept in science
fiction that has gained Mass amounts of
popularity over recent years especially
recently thanks to a certain wall
crawlers movie multiverses are parallel
universes that are similar or extremely
different from the main ones scientists
have pondered over the existence of a
Multiverse for hundreds of years but the
most popular being the many worlds
interpretation a theory of quantum
mechanics that states there are many
worlds that exist in parallel at the
same space and time as our own some
interpretations even state that every
decision a person makes causes a branch
in reality where the person made the
other decision we're familiar with the
SCP foundation's run-ins with the
Multiverse from
scp-2935 O Death a cave that allows The
Wanderer to enter a parallel Dimension
that's fully and completely dead only
for the same thing to happen to their
own world once they return through the
cave or
scp-1437 a hole that allows the
foundation to send receive and read
parallel dimensional documentation from
other multiversal SCP foundations
combine those two concepts with an
scp-001 proposal the importance of an
scp-001 proposal is not lost on the
foundation researchers of the SCP
Foundation saved the scp-001 slot for
only the most dangerous apocalyptic or
widespread anomalies that could affect
the foundation itself humanity and
normalcy arbelix scp-001 proposal and
the research within its file found the
answer to the question we posed above
when the SCP Foundation is faced with a
dire decision do they uphold normalcy or
destroy their universe and all the
people who live in it the file begins
somewhat different from what we're used
to with SCP Foundation files instead of
an item number or containment procedures
we begin with a yellow notice from the
records and information security
administration or racer for short the
notice states that the following file
was received in 2026 from Dimension r42
his Dimension r42 potentially the cause
of scp-001 could they be attacking this
version of the SCP Foundation the notice
continues with the description of the
file that follows it it states the file
below describes an anomaly threatening
all members of humankind in all of the
Multiverse this file had been emitted to
this version of the SCP Foundation for
eight minutes as an extremely dangerous
Cognito Hazard classified as a class 5
Cognito Hazard capable of easily
destabilizing and penetrating this
universe however it was found to not be
dangerous only reading as a danger level
zero while this Foundation was unable to
quickly counteract this Cognito Hazard
it appeared to not pose a threat to the
affected universe's humankind part of
this notice is crossed out indicating
that it is no longer true there is a
high threat of repeated Cognito
hazardous or other forms of attack from
dimension r42 instead this part has been
replaced with the following fact
Dimension r42 no longer exists did this
version's SCP Foundation fall to scp-001
their entire universe no longer exists
so perhaps this file that this
Dimensions SCP Foundation received could
be a potential warning under this race
and notice the reader is not greeted
with the standard foundation
documentation yet again instead it seems
that the original senders of this file
left a note for the readers of this file
it says greetings you are reading this
dossier in a para dimension of The Relic
Dimension r42 due to the Colossal size
of your world's address for your
convenience your dimension will be
Hereafter referred to as PD para
Dimensions it seems as though we're
reading this scp-001 file Through The
Eyes of the SCP Foundation in this
so-called para Dimension so if the
original SCP Foundation and their
universe r-42 is now destroyed what does
this mean for us the note continues the
following message has been constructed
by the SCP Foundation of The Relic
Dimension r42 and is addressed to the
SCP Foundation of paradimension PD
enclosed you will find information about
scp-001 which is a threat to the
Multiverse here we go
scp-001 is definitely the cause of r42's
Destruction but how can we be so sure of
this maybe scp-001 caused the foundation
to destroy their Universe the node also
includes the following statement as you
may have noticed this message was
preceded by a burst signal containing a
non-dangerous Cognito Hazard the best
signal was constructed in such a way
that minimal change to the signal would
have caused indiscriminate and
overwhelming casualties among the Dennis
thousands of PD as you can see r42 is
capable of eliminating the absolute
majority of PD denizens but has not
exercised this capability in the context
above we ask you to consider this action
not as an act of aggression but as a
demonstration of the fact that r42 has
no pre-tension for conquest or other
forms of aggression towards PD take the
following information in Earnest well at
least this version of the SCP Foundation
is being somewhat friendly with the
parent Dimension if r42s as CP
Foundation needs to quell this
multiversal threat though why are they
leaving it up to an SCP Foundation that
may not be so inclined the scp-001 file
begins with the object class this
anomaly is of the joint class of paradox
apollyon we know from scp-001 when day
breaks or scp-3999 that a polyon class
anomalies are extremely dangerous posing
an immediate and almost Unstoppable
threat to normalcy the SCP Foundation
all of humanity or even the universe
itself the Paradox part is interesting
what exactly is paradoxical about an
appallian-class anomaly a footnote
explains this for us this anomalies
distinguishing feature is that in order
to eliminate the anomaly that will
inevitably eliminate mankind it is
imperative to eliminate mankind or
release another k-class event oh boy it
seems that the SCP Foundation of r42 was
not eliminated by scp-001 they
eliminated themselves to contain
scp-001 is this paradimension faced with
this decision now the containment
procedures of the SCP file continue on
this note the only way to contain
scp-001 and prevent a ZK class
cross-reality failure event is the
annihilation of humankind k-class
scenarios are not not a concept used
lightly by the SCP Foundation we're
familiar with the Omega K class scenario
when we are completely rid of death or
XK Class end of the world scenarios so
we know the danger these anomalies hold
to humankind normalcy and the world the
SCP Foundation will do anything to
prevent these scenarios from occurring
apparently even including the
elimination of all humankind or entire
universes the description goes more in
depth on the scp-001 anomaly
scp-001 consists of all living members
of the homo sapiens species living
within Dimension r42 and the para
Dimension or PD for short it seems as
though this anomaly was created out of a
mistake from Dimension r42 and PD as the
description States the anomaly first
came into existence and developed in The
Relic Dimension r42 and later activated
in PD by accident how could this have
happened are these Dimensions linked
much more closely than we first thought
let's continue with the description to
find more information scarily this
portion of the description contains a
note that states that unchecked growth
of scp-001 will cause the annihilation
of the entire Multiverse the SCP
foundations of Dimension r42 and PD are
not met with this decision as now the
entire Multiverse is at risk the r42 SCP
Foundation has done immense research on
the topic of the Multiverse of their
Universe after the big bang a finite
number of universes were created only 57
to be exact however only one dimension
was able to form Humanity Dimension r42
had its unknown why this happened but
all we know is that with the destruction
of r42 and the potential annihilation of
PD Humanity will cease to exist in the
Multiverse the danger of scp-001 is that
it has the anomalous capability for wide
scale replica location of paired
Dimensions we are reading this article
from one of these para Dimensions so
this SCP Foundation is technically an
anomaly that must contain itself a pair
Dimension is defined as a parallel
reality that has an extremely small
deviation from its parent dimension in
this case PD is a para dimension of r42
it seems that these para Dimensions form
as a result of human decision making so
if you've ever been between a type of
shirt to buy or were confused on an exam
and guessed a question a para Dimension
could have formed from this decision
where the pair Dimension has you take
the other choice because of this
Dimensions housing living instances of
scp-001 uncontrollably grow a colossal
number of minimally differing pair
Dimensions every second no sign of pair
Dimensions have been found in the other
56 parent Dimensions the picture on this
file shows how PD has branched from r42
but at this point it seems that Millions
if not billions or trillions of para
Dimensions now exist the real problem of
para Dimensions is that the Multiverse
has a limit on the number of pair
Dimensions that can exist and once that
is crossed the ZK class cross reality
failure event will begin and the
Multiverse will be destroyed the r42
dimensions SCP Foundation has also
discovered that once humankind emerges
in the pair Dimension they can begin to
have para Dimensions themselves the ZK
class cross reality failure event can be
expected to begin between four to two
months from the PD receiving this
message to summarize
scp-001 is humankind specifically it's
decision making when a person makes a
decision a pair of Dimension may be
created the Multiverse has a limit on
the number of pair Dimensions it can
have and since pair Dimensions can have
pair Dimensions they are quickly
approaching the ZK class cross reality
the failure event the SCP Foundation of
r42 is approximately 17 years ahead of
PD which allowed them to research and
develop containment procedures to
contain the anomaly and save the
Multiverse r42's SCP Foundation
discovered scp-001 five years before
writing the file we're reading now aside
from that they developed two operations
castling and minimal gain to slow pair
Dimension creation and prevent the ZK
class cross-reality failure event in
stage 1 of operation minimal gain the
foundation began with neutralizing and
decommissioning all of their contained
anomalies under the classification of
Euclid or ketter specifically those that
were expensive to contain or requiring
high levels of personnel and researchers
stage 2 saw operation castling be
commenced the r42 SCP Foundation
launched Rockets with variance C Global
amnestic dispersing warheads and took
control over all countries in order to
hold power over all humankind in stage 3
the foundation began to move their world
to a more natural state destroying all
hazardous radioactive chemical and
bacteriological objects removing dams
and stopping oil extractions during
stage 3 stage four began the r42 SCP
Foundation began eliminating Humanity in
third world countries by use of viral
and biological attacks Stage 5 was a
wider spread attack on Humanity where
the SCP Foundation added deactivation
resistant viral agents to water
treatment and collection plants food
products medication and household items
of developed countries by stage 6 only
0.1 percent of humanity remained and
they were targeted with drone strikes or
put into concentration camps for
elimination stage 7 of the remaining
survivors the foundation sampled them to
find the fittest of those left to
preserve humankind stage 8 saw 15 000 of
these people put into indefinite
cryosleep and the remaining survivors
were eliminated stage 9 saw the
destruction of the remaining SCP
Foundation Personnel we move on to a
list of proposals that were made before
or during operations castling and
minimal gain proposals rejected include
the use of SCP objects or other
Technologies to eliminate derivative
Dimensions the development of Nanobots
with the capability to control human
decision-making capabilities and
eliminate variability full replacement
of humanity with bionic hybrids acting
explicitly within standard behavioral
models unification of humanity into a
neural network with control given to an
AI Control unit and the destruction of
Earth and or all of its inhabitants
While most of these seem like Clear
Solutions that would prevent the
elimination of humanity at the SCP
foundation's hand these proposals were
all rejected for one reason the SCP
Foundation did not have enough time one
proposal was accepted however the use of
scp-0000
this appears to be the solution the r42
SCP Foundation concocted to fight
scp-001 and potentially save the
Multiverse it poses the question if the
r42 SCP Foundation used this same
anomaly to contain scp-001 as proven by
the fact they no longer exist will PD do
the same the file explains that the r42
SCP Foundation opened a dimensional
Wormhole into PD as they do not know at
the time if para Dimensions could cause
the creation of more pair dimensions in
doing this the SCP Foundation seemingly
infected PD with the ability to create
para Dimensions the author of this file
goes on to explain that the r42scp
foundation had plans to attack PD and
use operations castling and minimal gain
in the dimension however they could not
access the dimension again and they
believe that the foundation Personnel of
P D would have made use of thumbnail
class anomalies to save themselves and
their world a note from r42's overseer
council is left for PD if the apollian
destruction was not enough the overseer
council is involved the importance of
the neutralization of this anomaly
cannot be forgotten so the overseer
Council explained to PD the world has
existed before us and must remain after
us our Multiverse is ill and the name of
the illness is Humanity
scp-001 the only way out is
scp-0000
will cease to become a threat with its
Health it is in our power to leave a
chance for other Sapient species that
perhaps will not be affected by the same
anomaly or will find a way to get rid of
it before it's too late we the o5
council and other survivors from r42
have chosen Our Fate we hope hope you
will do the same what is this scp-0000
how did the SCP Foundation of r42 find
the solution the file for
scp-0000 is placed within this
scp-001 file
scp-0000 is a paradox thumbnail class
anomaly without any containment
procedures
scp-0000 is a device that once activated
will destroy the universe it was
activated in it will also destroy all
para Dimensions that are not creating
other para Dimensions as such PD would
not be destroyed however the billions or
trillions of other para Dimensions the
r42 parent Dimension created will be
destroyed PD is left with a harrowing
decision to continue living or destroy
itself to save the rest of the
Multiverse in the file a note from r42's
Jones Simpson is written for an SC CP
Foundation overseer 05-1 as part of
operations castling and minimal gain the
remaining Foundation employees were
allowed one family member to uphold
morale Joan is not writing for r42's
05-1 instead she's writing for PDS 05-1
this Dimensions version of her father
she begins with wondering whether she
can call this version of 05-1 her father
as her version of her father recently
passed away she remembers the day the
foundation employees were allowed to
choose that one family member they would
save for the time being her father was
opposed to allowing two family members
as he claimed it would cause unnecessary
stress and schisms among the remaining
few hundred Foundation staff 05-1 chose
to have Joan over her mother and she
understood everything by the look in his
eyes and grew angry but that feeling is
long gone now she began to work with her
father and the remaining Foundation
Personnel that called themselves
hostages behind the backs of those
higher up the ranks on days she felt sad
Joan and her father would go up to the
surface of the Earth in hazmat suits
sitting on the grass and watching over
the empty City at the bottom of the
mountain no Humanity remained with the
only life she could see being Birds her
father promised her that they'd returned
there and build a giant Monument to
humanity at the center of the city she
knew this was a lie Joan remembers when
someone proposed that they should open a
portal the one that opened to PD this
was their fatal mistake as after that
the paradimension began replicating para
Dimensions the countdown went down two
months again and the promise he made to
his daughter became impossible 05-1 died
and left the position vacant Jones says
to the pd's05-1 that she doesn't care
whether they destroy their world or not
or whether the universe will continue
you to exist or if there will be new
life in it her world was crushed long
ago the note also reads the following
it's good that this message is encrypted
with your key that was passed on to me
or these lines would have been deleted
everyone wants to save the world but who
needs it like this empty and cold
without those to appreciate its beauty
without Humanity do whatever you think
is right I truly feel better now love
you Faithfully Yours Joan Simpson we're
not too sure if PD went through with
destroying their Universe to save the
Multiverse but it seems that whatever
decision was made would cause the
destruction of that Universe whether
that be through the use of scp-0000 or
the ZK class cross reality failure event
Humanity will cease but maybe if they
make the decision to use
scp-0000 Sapient life can begin to exist
again and hopefully no pair of
Dimensions will will be made from their
decisions decisions are an extremely
innate part of humanity you decided to
get out of bed this morning you decided
to open up your computer or phone and
you decided to watch this video who
knows the amount of pair Dimensions we
may have created today but in our world
we're not at risk but in the SCP
foundation's Universe anything can be
anomalous even Humanity some things are
Best Kept contained after all this is
the founding principle behind the SCP
Foundation themselves to secure and
contain the most dangerous anomalies in
order to protect human lives but within
the foundation itself our things which
should never be uncovered secrets that
must never be told secured behind
multiple layers of a containment like
the Seven Seals of Revelation is a
threat so high level in its nature that
it can't even be given a class
scp-5999 but in order to truly
understand this late series SCP we have
to go all the way back to one of the
earliest anyone looking for scp-001 will
quickly realize that there are several
different entities and anomalies that
share this designation many reasons have
been given for this classification Quirk
perhaps they were all discovered in the
early days of the foundation before the
current numbering system was introduced
others have suggested that many
different
scp-001s are an intentional misdirection
by the foundation to keep the nature of
the true first SCP a closely guarded
secret one of the many entities and the
one we'll be referring to as scp-001 to
understand
scp-59999 is otherwise known as the
database information about the database
is kept a secret to the entire SCP
Foundation apart from the overseer
Council the reason behind this well that
would be because this scp-001 contains
details of the very nature of the
foundation its self including its
creation not how the organization was
founded mind you how it was created and
by whom we're about to break the most
powerful layer of containment of all the
fourth wall you see to URI the SCP
Foundation and its vast catalog of
user-generated articles on the creative
and the creepy are nothing more than a
source of entertainment it can be fun to
study the lore and the nuances of
different scps appreciating the
imagination and hard work that the
authors put into writing them it can
even Inspire us feel our own written
Endeavors whether that takes the form of
fan fiction independent stories original
scps or even a YouTube series but when
all is said and done we all know that
the SCP Foundation is fictional and they
know it too pieced together from various
fragments of information within their
own archives the database contains
everything the foundation knows about
the real world authors of the SCP Wiki
just like we told you it's time to weigh
a fawn farewell to the fourth wall the
metaphorical barrier that separates what
we know to be real from what we know to
be purely fiction the fact that they
exist in this fictional capacity is
something the overseer Council hopes to
hide from the rest of the foundation's
Personnel but they also have plans in
mind for the SCP Wiki writers
responsible for creating them and
expanding the roster of anomalies they
keep contained the SCP Wiki entry on
scp-001 the database closes with a
proposal a plan from the o5 council to
reach the wikis authors in the real
world through memetic kill agents that
will put them to sleep and then kill
them with that important background
context in mind now let's go all the way
back to the other end of the SCP Wiki
and take a look at
scp-59999 when first accessing the file
you the reader will notice a few format
differences between this entry and
others within the CP archive each
section of scp-5999 is hidden behind an
encryption and accessing these will
reveal the different levels of this
entry remember how we mentioned the
Seven Seals of Revelation at the start
of this video that wasn't a coincidence
in the Bible's Book of Revelation there
are seven symbolic seals securing a book
that John of patimos saw in his vision
of the Apocalypse when these Seven Seals
are broken and the book is opened this
symbolizes the second coming of the
Messiah and marks the beginning of the
biblical Apocalypse in much the same
vein
scp-5999 is sealed in seven different
parts each behind its own encryption
culminating in one apocalyptic ending so
at this point you're probably thinking
what actually is
scp-59999 what could be so dangerous
that it has to stay hidden in multiple
segments while on the surface
scp-5999 is just a story it details one
of the SCP foundation's many
investigations into an anomalous object
nothing too strange about that but
there's something more to it since with
the foundation there always is and it
has something to do with the images at
the header of each section of the entity
at the top of each part of scp-5999 is a
picture of a group of candles seven to
be exact but the further down you read
one by one the candles start to go out
until you reach the end of
scp-59999 delving into the first of
these sections the scp-5999 entry
describes a corpse that seems to be
cursed with multiple anomalous
properties after the assault and murder
of one miss Jacqueline hallcroft her
remains were scattered according to this
entry any person coming into contact
with a part of Miss holcroft's deceased
body or anyone who learns about what
caused her death will experience
anomalous effects these manifest in
various waves for example subjects May
hallucinate that they see a disheveled
woman with wounds similar to miss
wholecroft's before her dismemberment
this site is sometimes accompanied by
Sounds of whispering and even begging
that calls the subject seeing and
hearing things by their name others have
reported hearing an unknown song set to
the tune of Twinkle Twinkle Little Star
the anomalous influence of Miss holcross
dismembered remains is known to continue
until a subject's death with many
reporting seeing the woman's deceased
body lurking in their old photos or
suffering sleep paralysis as they feel
something being forcibly removed from
their guts some subjects even report
discovering body parts and organs
anything from fingers to eyes to teeth
to hair and finding it at random places
such as when opening a drawer or in
their food finally a number of subjects
affected by the remains of Miss
wholecroft have reported a specific
irrational fear the fear that the chains
are weakening even after the foundation
recover for Jaclyn holcroft's bones and
her remains were buried in a proper
funeral the effects that her dead body
parts had over living subjects did not
stop subjects reported their children
went missing and the attendees had Miss
holcroft's funeral Were Somehow
spontaneously disemboweled after the
ceremony to keep these effects to a
minimum the foundation apparently has a
containment procedure in place the
scp-5999 entry details something called
procedure Sevenfold wherein the SCP
Foundation gathers seven civilians and
brings them to a location called
Albright Manor on October 30th these
seven people are sedated and awake on
the night of October 31st all entrances
to Albright Manor are sealed trapping
the civilians inside observe via a
network of surveillance devices
throughout the manner procedure 7-fold
always results in the deaths of the
seven civilian Witnesses brought in by
the foundation whether they are told to
perform a ritual or offered as a
sacrifice is unclear the following
morning Foundation cleanup Crews will
remove the remains of these people
disposing of their bodies with an
incinerator for the rest of the year
until procedure Sevenfold needs to be
conducted again Foundation Personnel on
site at Albright Manor are instructed to
be careful around any surfaces that
contain the phrase this is where I died
by now you are most likely wondering
what the remains of Miss wholecroft and
procedure Sevenfold have to do with
anything we've talked about so far what
is the connection to scp-001 the
database is there something linking an
anomalous corpse with the foundation's
knowledge of its own fictional existence
what does a fear of the Chain's
weakening mean and why do none of these
questions seem to acknowledge what those
seven candles represent or why they're
still gradually going out scrolling
further through scp-59999 doesn't seem
to yield many more answers though in
fact the more of the sections you look
into the less it seems to be about Miss
wholecroft or even make any link to the
database and the deeper you go the fewer
candles remain lit the next few portions
of the scp-5999 entry are dedicated to
completely different investigations that
have little to nothing to do with
procedure Sevenfold Miss holcroft's
corpse and the anomalous effects it
creates are also absent in later
segments of this entry in the SCP
archive so if the cursed body parts of
Jacqueline holcroft are not
scp-59999 then what is one report
details the fates of a mobile task force
trapped in a fog shrouded town here they
encounter a land that appears to be
Undead and evolves into an ungodly
winged Beast before the MTF team's very
eyes another that follows is a
transcript of an exorcism during a
classified Foundation operation One
agent Grace was possessed by a demonic
entity and sent to the Department of
demonology specialist in demonic
psychology Dr Peter McNeil attempted to
remove move the demon inhabiting agent
Grace however after trying to intimidate
the Demonic entity with various passages
from Biblical texts it appears as though
maybe the demon was able to spread its
influence to both agent Grace and Dr
McNeil of course neither of these
reports seem to answer any of the
pressing questions or explain the exact
nature of
scp-5999 as you go further into the
entry you can't help but notice how
often chains are referenced in fact that
seems to be the only thing constant in
all these disjointed segments mentions
of a failure of the chains to hold What
Lies Beneath and chains that have become
too few in number to hold it all create
the sense that something once was locked
up sealed securely away is managing to
break free then finally as the last
candle goes out you are literally
brought face to face with the horror of
scp-59999 and its true nature is
revealed
a decaying desiccated corpse stares out
of the screen at you its eyes are sunken
deep into its skull lips shriveled
almost completely away exposing rows of
rotten teeth could it be Miss holcroft's
body you aren't sure what you are sure
of is The Corpse's face is getting
closer to the screen and now it's
smiling at you you can feel your heart
pounding beating against your rib cage
has the world around you begins to fade
and your life slips away from you the
last thing you see is the Grim face of
the corpse staring out at you with its
dead sunken eye
truth of scp-59999 is that it has been
specifically designed to kill whoever
reads it by whom you may be asking by
the SCP Foundation themselves cast your
mind back to the database and remember
that the overseer Council are aware of
their own fictional existence they know
that they aren't real and plan to use
them a medical agent to take out the SCP
Wiki authors that created them
scp-59999 is that kill agent an entity
created by fiction to kill those living
in reality
scp-5999 works by drawing a person in
offering disjointed and disconnected
horror stories as a means of grabbing a
reader's attention further and further
down through the entry that person will
go searching for the meaning behind
these Chilling Tales and therein lies
the Trap each layer each section of
scp-5999 that you read is another candle
extinguished and with every flame that
goes out a seal is broken a chain
becomes Unbound allowing The Entity
contained within the archive entry
itself to get closer its sole purpose is
to fulfill the proposal laid out by the
o5 council after learning that they were
fictional along with the entire SCP
Universe by pulling you in with the
mystery and Intrigue of the confusing
convoluted stories
scp-5999 is able to deploy jumping out
of the screen towards you condemning you
to a dark and grisly fate or maybe
that's just what the o5 council and the
SCP Foundation wants us to think either
way it might just be safer to get your
SCP knowledge here at SCP explained and
speaking of your rights in the middle of
one of the hottest Summers on record the
days are filled with bright scorching
sun and Searing heat and you've been
laying around with your air conditioning
on full last just to try and cool
yourself off sadly it's not really
working and the heat is becoming way too
much but then you remember there's this
married couple that lives near you with
no kids and they happen to have a
swimming pool in their yard normally
they keep to themselves they'd never let
you use their pool but they've gone out
of town for a few days besides the heat
is killing you you're sure that the
neighbors wouldn't mind if you just took
a quick dip as long as you clean up
after yourself they probably wouldn't
even notice you were even there
cautiously you make your way to their
house it's an unremarkable Place similar
to most of the other houses in this
suburb of New Mexico after checking that
there's nobody else around you climb the
two meter high cinder block wall that
stands around the back Garden as you
drop to your feet sweaty and panting
from the unrelenting summer heat you see
it the pool your salvation water never
looks so appeal
immediately you step Barefoot across the
Sun scorched tiles and sit on the edge
legs and the water it's cool and
refreshing perfect for a day is hot as
today he already changed in wearing your
swim trunks so it doesn't take long for
you to paddle out to the middle of the
pool letting that chilled clean water
cool you off as you're taking a dip you
notice the pool's Jets turning on
automatically it's a little bit odd but
you shrug it off that couple clearly
shelled out for a pool with a lot of
fancy bells and whistles but extra
features aren't why you're here you came
because if you didn't then you could
have melted under all that sunlight
floating on the surface of the water you
relax with your arms behind your head
and close your eyes you don't have time
to realize that coming here was a
mistake instead you start to feel
relaxed so calm so tranquil you're one
with the water around you now it's
almost as though you could just
disappear so you do the police never
find any trace of you everyone else
simply writes it off as a random
disappearance there's not even so much
as a scrap of your body left in the pool
just the clear clean water why because
the swimming pool you decided to take a
cooling dip in wasn't an ordinary pool
it was
scp-242 but don't worry you won't be the
last to make that costly mistake what
you didn't know is that the married
couple who live in that house are
secretly a pair of SCP Foundation
doctors the house isn't even theirs the
foundation procured it after the former
owner her retired out-of-state landlord
strangely vanished he had been
struggling to find anyone to rent the
place so he eventually decided to give
up on the property game and move in
there himself after three days he was
never seen again now that house has only
one rule that must be followed above all
else do not swim swim in the pool
scp-242 is at least to the untrained eye
just an average swimming pool a decent 9
meters in length four and a half wide
and it holds around 53 000 liters of
sterile pool water like we mentioned
before it's even got some Nifty features
like water jets a dual waterfall and a
built-in vacuum unit for sucking out any
impurities and we mean any impurities
you see scp-242 does go by another name
the self-cleaning pool and while that
might not sound as foreboding or
dramatic as the Scarlet king or the
wendigo skull or the horrifying nasty
dude of ultimate Badness okay we made
that last one up we can assure you that
you don't ever want to suffer the fate
of taking a swim in this pool there was
an incident a while ago recorded by the
foundation through a secret hidden
camera the house where scp-242 can be
found had been left vacant for a Time
and once again some opportunists decided
to take advantage of the empty swimming
pool this time it was a couple a man and
a woman in their early 20s they climbed
up the back wall undressed and even
stole a couple of plastic inflatable
rafts from a shed in The house's
backyard the water jets switched
themselves on startling the girl but her
boyfriend told her not to worry the
filter to clean the pool was probably
just on an automatic timer right surely
it wouldn't have been anything to worry
about after swimming together for around
24 minutes the couple both agreed that
the water felt warm tingly even both of
them climbed onto their rafts eventually
falling asleep while still holding each
other's hands but almost half an hour
after the Jets had started something
caused the two rafts to burst the couple
awoke startled by the loud pop of the
splitting Inflatables and being plunged
back into the water the pool around them
immediately began frothing violently
deep red streams of blood swirling
through the water as the couple screamed
in fear and Agony both of them tried to
desperately swim to the edge hoping to
leave the pool and get to safety but
unfortunately that plan didn't work
before they could reach the edge the man
and the woman were Pulled Under the
surface of the Raging Water their limbs
thrashing as they still tried in vain to
escape eventually they vanished under
the Crimson bloody water the frothing
slowly began to calm and the red and the
pool dissipated once again becoming
clear after 48 seconds the couple were
never seen again and a cover story was
leaked to the Press by the SCP
Foundation two weeks after they went
missing according to them the pair had a
lope together somewhere in Mexico if
only that sounds a lot nicer than what
actually happened to them so this
swimming pool clearly has some anomalous
properties that much is obvious but what
exactly are those properties how exactly
does scp-242 work is it an
interdimensional Gateway that drags
people to a nasty alternate universe if
they spend too long swimming in it or is
the swimming pool itself a sentient
carnivorous creature that lures humans
in only to devour them maybe the water
is teeming with invisible flesh-eating
piranhas that can strip the meat from
the bone in a matter of seconds while
good guesses all around but actually
it's none of these it's unclear what
causes the pool's anomalous effects it
could be a property that is completely
unique to the water contained in scp-242
or maybe it's down to the exact shape
and measurements of the pool itself it
could even be a combination of both but
whatever the cause the result is always
the same when any object substance or
even living organism is placed in
scp-242 it will be entirely Rewritten on
a molecular level the genetic anatomic
structure will fall apart and the
subject will be transmuted into sterile
water in fact not just clean water but
water that remains sterile even when
removed from the pool if you took a cup
of scp-242's water and mixed something
like food coloring into it the food
coloring would not be absorbed into the
water instead staying as one
non-missable bubble this process doesn't
happen instantly though it can vary
depending on how contaminated or complex
the substance placed in scp-242 is for
example water sampled from a nearby
River was sterilized and purified by the
pool in about seven minutes a sample of
stagnant pond water riddled with various
diseases and germs took 11 minutes
longer what about 50 000 liters of coal
tar well that one took a little longer
12 long days to be exact but was still
turned into pure sterile water and as
for a living human being maybe ask that
couple that took a dip in the
self-cleaning pool the foundation is
naturally fascinated with the pool and
after extensive examination they have
determined that scp-242 doesn't seem to
have been intentionally designed for the
specific anomalous function it performs
the components of scp-242 beyond the
pool itself the filter the vacuum the
pipes none of these parts nor anything
about the swimming pools design appear
to be responsible for disintegrating
matter until only water remains you
might have noticed that in the case of
the ill-fated couple who took a swim in
scp-242 the water jets and waterfall
features switch themselves on
automatically before the pair's Grim
demise somehow these features are able
to activate without the need for
electricity as disconnecting the pool
from a power source will not stop the
Jets and waterfall from coming on once a
non-water substance is placed into
scp-242 the same goes for the pool
vacuum which apparently cannot be jammed
or malfunctioned even when the bottom of
the pool is a wash with viscous liquids
like that coal tar the vacuum will
continue to operate as normal scrubbing
away at the floor of scp-242 the one
part of the self-cleaning pool that
doesn't work as you would expect is the
water filtration system there is never
any water being cycled into the pool nor
out of it as a matter of fact the pipes
connecting to the filtration system have
all been removed then again who needs a
filtration system when your backyard
swimming pool can just spontaneously
reduce anything to clean water but that
raises another frightening thought
everything that the pool has ever taken
and converted is still in there animals
objects people just swimming around you
perhaps if they could still think they'd
scream and shout and tell you to get
away to run while you still can but the
second your skin touches the water
you're destined to be with them forever
and ever and ever it's enough to send a
liquid chill down your spine okay so if
it's not the actual physical pull that
causes these anomalous effects that must
mean it's something in the water right
perhaps some microscopic flesh devouring
microbe or some ancient curse that was
placed on the water before it was used
to fill up the pool surely if you took a
cup of water out of scp-242 it would
still break down structures on a
molecular level leaving only more
sterile water while the researchers
working at the SCP Foundation thought
much of the same and conducted a series
of tests to determine the exact
properties of
scp-242's water one test involves
submerging two d-class test subjects
each wearing an atmospheric dive suit
into scp-242 the goal was to determine
if it was safe to consume the water from
scp-242 while both inside and outside of
the pool test subject a was lowered into
the water and instructed to drink from a
metal straw by their mouth the eyepieces
of their goggles were blacked out so
they couldn't see what they were
drinking from subject B fill the barrel
with the same water from scp-242 and
then was made to put on an atmospheric
dive suit but instructed to stay out of
the pool test subject a was told to
drink directly from the pool remarking
that the water was warm and had a bit of
a noticeable chemical aftertaste but was
otherwise normal then test subject B
drank some of the same water from the
barrel apparently it was cool and tasted
of well nothing just like water usually
does after a moment more of drink
subject a began belching finding that
they had uncontrollable gas the water
had begun to feel warmer stinging the
subject's mouth while for subject B the
water from the barrel stayed cool and
refreshing the foundation doctors
overseeing the experiment instructed
test subject a to keep drinking which
they did until it felt even hotter to
The Taste one of the d-class's fillings
even fell out and eventually the
structural Integrity of subject A's dive
suit failed presumably disintegrated by
the water from
p242 after a few muffled screams and
gurgling noises test subject a wasn't
heard from again and we can all probably
guess why as for subject B they kept
drinking from the barrel suffering no
adverse effects even after 17 long hours
there were no noticeable psychological
or physical changes even their urine
showed no traces of abnormality the
water from scp-242 left in the barrel
evaporated as normal leaving behind no
residue or any indicator as to why
taking the water out of the pool made it
safer to drink than the same water in
the pool perhaps the moral of the story
is to just be careful where you choose
to take a swim otherwise it could be
your last growing up in a small Virginia
Town near the mountains right on the
border of West Virginia Zane heard all
kinds of stories from his grandmother
Tales of mountain lions who could
transform into ghostly women the talipo
a fluffy rodent-like creature on an
endless quest to get its tail back from
the hunter who took it the Mothman that
appeared with glowing red eyes to warn
of impending tragedy most of all she
warned him about the deer sometimes she
used to say when you're out in the woods
late at night you'll see a deer acting a
little bit funny maybe it's making
strange sounds maybe it's standing up
like a man maybe it's staring at you
from the shadows and won't look away if
you ever see one of these deer promise
me you'll get away from it as fast as
possible don't look at it don't talk to
it just get far far away he promised her
every time but as he got older he
started to forget his grandma's stories
letting them fade away with memories of
the Easter Bunny and Santa Claus he
didn't think about the stories again
until he was older a junior in college
and embarking on a camping trip with his
roommate Josh they're both staying with
Zayn's family for the summer and had
been enjoying the sunshine and fresh air
her they'd gone hiking picked
blackberries and gone fishing to their
hearts content after a while they got
sick of sleeping in the cramped house
and decided to have a proper camping
trip out in the mountains campsites were
crowded this time of year but Zane knew
a spot just isolated enough that they
could kick back enjoy nature and relax
in peace they packed their supplies and
headed out into the forest for a weekend
they would never forget by Nightfall
Zane and Josh had pitched their tents
built a fire and were starting to make
some dinner they roasted hot dogs and
heated cans of beans over the fire and
decided to start telling some classic
scary stories sitting by the crackling
fire listening to the rustling leaves
snapping twigs and the chittering of
animals all around Zane couldn't help
but remember the stories he had almost
forgotten all the strange inexplicable
things that came out after the sun went
down and the forest went quiet he
thought he could hear the footsteps of
something walking by their campsite sir
them but it was probably just his
imagination as Josh told stories about
babysitters stalked by Killers and
drivers picking up ghostly hitchhikers
Zane was thinking about the deer he
shuddered but shook it off and after
some more stories and a few too many
s'mores the two friends decided to get
some sleep after several hours Zane woke
to the sound of Josh unzipping his tent
he sat up ready to yell at his friend
for waking him up but the sight of
Josh's pale frightened face stopped him
there's something here was all Josh
could say his hands Zane noticed were
shaking hey man it's it's okay let's
check it out Zane patted Josh on the
shoulder he was pretty sure his friend
just wasn't used to camping in actual
nature but reach for his hunting knife
just in case he grabbed a flashlight and
switched it on following Josh out into
the darkness he swept the beam across
the clearing and it illuminated a pair
of orange eyes staring directly at him
from behind a nearby tree Mata he
approached the shape trying to get a
clear look at it as it became more
illuminated his stomach dropped it was a
deer but something was wrong with it its
mouth was wide open its jaw working up
and down like it was trying to make a
sound but nothing came out but that
wasn't the worst part as the flashlight
beam illuminated the animal's body Zane
realized that somehow its head was on
backwards what the Josh appeared behind
him gasping shh Zayn shushed him
intensely he suddenly remembered his
grandmother's warnings you know what I
don't feel so great I think we should go
back to the car and head to my place he
gave Josh a look shaking his head as if
to say don't say another word by the
glow of their flashlights the two packed
up their campsite all under the Gaze of
the misshapen deer they drove home in
silence Josh only speaking wants to ask
what was that thing Zayn shook his head
I don't know but it wasn't a deer they
crept back into the house and went to
bed they knew they would never speak of
tonight ever again as Zane began to
Drift Off to Sleep his last conscious
thought was to glance out the window
there in the yard not five feet away was
a deer watching he didn't know it but
that night Zane encountered an instance
of
scp-6448
scp-6448 is an anomalous species of
creatures that appear to belong to the
server Day family nicknamed the not deer
they are highly Intel intelligent and
can be distinguished from ordinary deer
by unusual behavior and physical
deformities some of these have included
legs that bend backwards the eyes of an
animal other than deer forward-facing
eyes jerking movements lack of fear
towards humans and walking on two hind
legs most notably and most frightening
scp-6448 instances will watch and stalk
humans for a duration of hours or even
days they will follow humans home and
steal items from their domains including
weapons food and other personal items
they're most frequently found in the
Deep Woods at night when a person is
completely alone if someone encounters
an instance of
scp-6448 if they acknowledge any of the
creature's anomalous traits it will
attack in order to limit the loss of
life and ensure that the SCP Foundation
employs exercise the utmost caution when
dealing with
scp-6448 the cryptozo division issued
the following guidelines if you notice a
deer that seems off look away and ignore
it if it knows that you've noticed it
it's too late if you hear your name
whistling or something else in the woods
calling for you don't acknowledge it
never acknowledge it exists don't
respond don't go looking for it don't
call back to it if you're walking at
night and you feel something breathing
on your neck or Whispering behind you
the key to your safety is pretending
that everything is normal your survival
is dependent on your ignorance whatever
scp-6448 is they appear to be
intelligent enough to understand when
they are being studied and they don't
seem to like it very much on January 11
1994 a group of three
scp-6448 instances broke into site 41 in
North Carolina using a tunnel they had
carved over a long period of time at the
time there was an instant in containment
but in all the chaos of the breach the
specimen was lost every time an instance
was captured and contained near
scp-6448's habitat we would later Escape
via similar tunnels
scp-6448 was officially classified by
the SCP Foundation in 1980 but those
from the Appalachian region have known
about these strange creatures since at
least
1947. from folk tales and campfire
stories to Second Hand and even
first-hand encounters the locals are
aware of the not deer's existence and
are largely familiar with the
precautions necessary to avoid them
though many of the civilians that
encounter
scp-6448 avoid notifying the authorities
there have been several recorded 9-1-1
calls involving the not deer since 2000.
the following is a log of those calls
February 1st 2000 victim age 41 female
dialed Emergency Services after hearing
their name being called from the woods
near their home the victim recounts the
vocalization being likened to a scream
and a voice that they do not recognize
and requested assistance in locating the
source emergency Personnel requested the
subject Place their phone on the floor
outside the home to listen for the
alleged sounds after two minutes a
vocalization was heard that was calling
to the subject by name emanating from
the nearby Forest the subject was
instructed to investigate the
disturbance themselves and keep Services
updated on the situation the victim then
began to walk into the Woodland getting
about 50 meters into the underbrush
before inexplicably stopping they claim
there to be a noticeably large deer
standing in the way of the path she
begins to walk closer though States it
does not move subject diverts From the
Path and begins walking in a different
direction after 30 minutes no source of
the voice is determined the caller
returns to the residence June 13 2002
victim a h-28 male calls 9-1-1 regarding
a home break-in the caller notes
numerous items to be missing from their
residents and requests and investigation
operators dispatched two investigators
to visit the home and and pertain a
potential perpetrator the pair note that
based on earlier CCTV images all Cutlery
sharp objects Firearms light bulbs and a
single copy of the novel The Day After
Roswell are missing also noted is that
there is a complete lack of any
fingerprints at the scene with no doors
or Windows having been broken into
analysis of the home CCTV footage
revealed there to be a two-hour period
of missing film with the exception of a
single frame containing a service Nippon
on its hind legs reaching towards the
camera its frontal Hooves have been
warped to resemble fingers no footage of
the entity exiting the home was
discovered November 19 2005 a cattle
farmer age 54 male reported to local
authorities the sudden appearance of
over 30 percent of his largest herd
response teams surged the nearby area
for four hours though found no trace of
his cattle the victim was recommended to
set up trail cameras and note any
unusual activity overnight at 1 11 am
two
scp-6448 are seen walking through the
field before fleeing one places an
object into the ground later discovered
to be a single Fork a week after this
discovery 200 discarded bovine Hooves
appear at the location March 4th 2009
victim age unknown gender unknown dials
9-1-1 to request assistance from Animal
Services the victim is standing within a
forest in front of a service elephus
which is violently contorting the victim
attempts to State you better get a vet
or something I don't think it's well
before piercing Screech is heard and the
line Falls silent recovered footage
depicts the aforementioned animal
squirming seemingly in pain a vicious
churning is audible as a black mass UPS
out of the instance and the video turns
to static October 11 2012 victim age 23
male is a junior Wildlife officer at the
Cherokee National Forest Tennessee they
radioed their supervisor in the early
morning regarding a herd of undecolius
virginius within the reserve supposedly
there is a single animal that upon first
glance appears average though possesses
Divergent attributes including backwards
joints enlarged abdomen and
forward-facing Eyes Upon stating this a
distant whistle is audible the victim
stumbles slightly they begin to say what
the did it just whistle at me before the
sound of hooves rapidly getting closer
is heard notably the hoof steps did not
sound to be in the traditional Gallop of
a servid October 12 2012 the former
victim supervisor calls authorities
following the victim's absence from The
Reserve Night Shift following this their
radio begins to crackle the victim's
voice can be heard on the other end and
he requests the supervisor's attention
he calls regarding a herd of audacolius
virginius within the reserve they claim
there is a single animal that upon first
glance appears average though possesses
Divergent attributes including backwards
joints enlarged abdomen and
forward-facing eyes suspecting the
creature to be a rare genetic
malformation the victim requests their
supervisor to come to the location the
supervisor questions the victim about
what happened the night previous there
is no reply upon the supervisors and law
enforcement's arrival at the site a herd
of approximately 80 odacolius virginius
was present a single entity is in the
field Center and appears to be standing
separate from the rest of the group it
flees the scene upon realizing the law
enforcement's presence where it formally
stood lay a standard two-way radio April
8 2016. victim age 35 female dials 9-1-1
using a satellite phone distressed they
State they are in redactive County and
are being followed she claims that
despite seeing no one for the duration
of her hike she quote feels as if she's
being watched and has heard someone
walking behind her at various points in
the trip the victim is unable to give an
adequate description of their location
but knows the route to return to her
residence operators request the victim
to return to a point wherein she can
provide a sufficient Geographic
description of her position the victim
remains on the line for the duration of
the hike back to a readily used portion
of the Wilderness Trail along the
journey various unnatural sounds can be
heard these include footsteps Rock
slides coughing whispering and whistling
nearing the main trail all Woodland
noises such as birds and winds see
suddenly and the victims State she can
see a malformed deer carcass coated in a
thick layer of black slime at this time
human screams can be heard in the
distance operators request the victim
continue and ignore the other stimuli
agents embedded in local law enforcement
suspecting as
6448 involved notify gamma 4 to the
situation 20 minutes later the victim
returns to the main trail gamma 4 now
operating the 9-1-1 call informs the
victim not to respond to any further
unusual activity and greatly outlines
service protocol for the duration of the
victim's journey to her home two sets of
breathing are audible the victim
successfully returns to her residence
and shuts the door behind her now out of
sight from
scp-6448 Agents inquire of the victim's
address and the victim promptly complies
operatives instruct the victim to have
possession of all firearms and weapons
on the premises and to barricade herself
inside a safe space with one exit point
the victim swiftly begins grabbing all
available weapons and throwing them
inside a wardrobe it is at this time
there's a knock on the front door the
victim does not respond and continues to
hoard sharp objects from kitchen drawers
the knocking becomes more violent as the
handle is jostled and is shaken
incessantly a voice on the other side it
repeats the phrase hello it is me hello
let me in in a calm manner as the door
begins to shake the victim retreats to
her wardrobe armed with a small firearm
upon sealing herself in the space the
knocking ceases and footsteps can be
heard becoming further away the sound of
Galloping is audible as the front door
caves in hoof steps can now be heard
inside the home The Entity continues to
repeat hello it is me hello let me in as
it searches the small building a bright
light flashes overhead seemingly
circling the house eventually The Entity
enters the victim's bedroom through a
small slit in the wardrobe door the
victim can see a service canadensis
standing on its hind legs and surveying
the room its movements are crooked and
stiff seeming to struggle to stand in a
bipedal fashion it slouches down to a
quadrupedal Crouch similar to The Stance
of an arachnid it inhales heavily and
its head locks on The View of the
Wardrobe it is noted as possessing human
eyes it scampers towards the subject and
opens the door a single gunshot is heard
responders found no trace of either
scp-6448 or the victim containment of
scp-6448 is focused on the investigation
of any deer exhibiting anomalous traits
in and around the Appalachian area any
civilian sightings of
scp-6448 are to be handled by mobile
task force gamma 4 or the green Stags
any possible deaths resulting from
scp-6448 will be blamed on hiking
accidents and any reported sightings can
be explained away with chronic wasting
disease CWD occasionally referred to as
zombie deer disease is a prion disease
affecting members of the cervide family
symptoms of the illness include loss of
motor function control and damage to
decision making as well as gradual
degradation of all mental faculties it
is 100 fatal however though the disease
does exist most recorded cases of it in
the Appalachian region can actually be
attributed to instances of
scp-6448 any captured instances of
scp-6448 should be transported to psyc44
for the cryptozoology division's
containment and study on November 29
2019 they finally got their chance to
bring a not deer into custody the green
Stags were able to capture an instance
of
scp-6448 with the help from MTF new 7
hammer down and their heavy Vehicles
Division as well as some experimental
shock rifles one not deer was knocked
unconscious in the conflict and its body
was loaded onto an armored helicopter
and flown straight to site-44 in Essex
England at the site it was then placed
in a reinforced steel containment cell
and heavily sedated this entire process
went off without a hitch as the entity
began to regain Consciousness
cryptozoology specialist F Oz watched it
through a one-way glass window and
attempted to speak to it through the
intercom greetings
scp-6448 researcher Oz began at the
sound of his voice the creature jumped
to its feet staring at the intercom can
you understand me we've seen your genus
speak English just fine in the past the
animal did not answer but began licking
one of its legs and behaving as if it
were an ordinary deer researcher raw
aside impatiently please we know your
secret the knocked deer stopped what it
was doing freezing completely still as
it listened to the words admittedly it
wasn't exactly well kept if you just
look at yourself for more than a few
seconds it is very clear that you're not
normal at this the creature which had
been facing away from the window
swiveled its neck 180 degrees breaking
its own spine with an audible crack it
stared unblinking at the window and
directly at researcher Oz Oz turned to
the containment staff suddenly anxious I
thought you said this was one way the
staff assure him that it was and there
was no way the not dear could see him
still its eyes were locked directly on
his face he shook off the sense of
unease and continued his line of
questioning are you something imitating
dear it is clear that if so you possess
basic anatomical knowledge of them
though details are clearly faulty in
fact a better question would be how if
in fact you are not what you pretend to
be the not deer opened its mouth at this
revealing unusually sharp teeth it moved
its jaws if attempting to speak but only
a choking sound came out
shall we move on Oz asked but I'm more
concerned with here is why you take on
people is it a vendetta spiked food for
the first time in the interview the not
deer blinked it was an unnatural
movement forced and deliberate like the
creature was attempting to engage in an
ordinary Behavior rather than actually
experiencing an involuntary impulse
responding is mandatory research draws
prompted the creature did not react if
you will not comply moz's tone grew
Stern frustrated maybe you'd like to see
your brand new containment cell at last
The Entity spoke
pictures
research
its voice resembled the distorted
version of Oz's research what kind of Oz
wasn't able to finish his question July
1947 the creature said before ramming
into the one-way glass and cracking it
as Oz stumbled backwards from the force
the creature collapsed on the ground
seizing and screaming as its abdomen get
the Stags in here now Oz cried out but
it was too late the black mass of
something shiny and tendril leaped out
of the not deer scuttling around the
cell before shattering the window and
leaving the empty shell of a deer behind
the site-44 breach system activated and
attempted to initiate emergency
containment protocols but the mysterious
black mass escaped its sector made its
way toward the main exit broke through
the glass of the front exit door and
vanished into the Shrubbery outside the
escaped anomaly could not be found and
recontained ever since this incident
there have been a record-breaking number
of chronic wasting disease cases
identified in Deer here in the
surrounding area as well as an
unprecedented increase in UFO reports
further research is currently ongoing
but it is unknown whether we will ever
truly know what these creatures are only
one thing is for certain they are
definitely not dear in 1997 a massive
gray cloud of gas and smog settled over
the ordinary town of Dale Port New
England phone lines were cut off and any
attempts to enter the town were met with
failure there was a complete and total
blackout of information coming in and
out of delport whatever was occurring it
was anything but normal and clashed with
the town's easy going and peaceful
atmosphere an anomalous event of this
size and scale was impossible to miss
and naturally caught the attention of
the SCP Foundation before it did the
outside media who would report on the
mysterious occurrence and draw
unnecessary amounts of attention to the
town the founder nation was lucky enough
to maintain a hold over the situation
little over three hours after it had
begun and they were already starting
their usual cover-up story operations
keeping the situation in daleport well
away from the public eye still they were
unsure of what was occurring and what
they were dealing with themselves if
they were going to get to the bottom of
this mysterious smog covering an average
New England town they were going to be
safe and have to play it resourcefully
as the SCP Foundation is known for doing
the status of delport's residence
whether they were alive or dead was
completely unknown and so the foundation
began their rescue efforts a containment
perimeter surrounding the town was
established and relevant Witnesses
outside of the Town were detained and
amnesticized with convincing cover
stories already being deployed for the
foundation even an entire town
undergoing an anomalous event was
something they were well prepared to
deal with having handled similar
situations multiple times of the decades
the foundation began its research on
delport by observing what exactly The
Cloud of smog covering the town was the
foundation wasn't keen on sending its
Personnel even the so-called disposable
d-class to their death so the first
exploration into the cloud was carried
out by an unmanned ground vehicle
operating under the call sign
ugv-1 this Unstoppable carrier was
equipped with all the stops including
atmospheric sampling sensors audio video
recording equipment and an open circuit
biological sampling instrument which
contains skin tissue and several live
brown rats whose reactions would
indicate to the foundation whether or
not the smog was safe to be exposed to
or not the ground vehicle departed and
when it returned about a half hour later
it brought with it a whole host of data
about the gas covering Dale Port as it
turned out the smog was composed of
sulfur nitrogen and carbon oxides
concentrated at a level where irritation
would occur upon contact with humans but
it wasn't lethal neither was it
anomalous as the samples the vehicle
carried in with it were unaffected in
any anomalous manner the video recording
displayed a flat empty Wasteland inside
the gas cluster with little discernible
features after a certain point radio
communication with the vehicle became
degraded and the foundation returned the
carrier to the town's perimeter as more
resources and supplies arrived on
location the foundation ramped up its
research efforts this time 2D class were
sent into the gas cluster both aboard
another ground vehicle carrier this time
the truck was equipped with a higher
wattage radio transceiver than the first
one which the foundation hoped would be
enough to maintain communication
throughout the anomaly at a kilometer
from Beyond The Boundary The d-classes
Departed the vehicle and were asked to
remove their protective suits they
experienced no anomalous effects from
exposure to the gas the medical
Telemetry showed that one of the classes
was having difficulty breathing the duo
reported the same flat featureless
terrain the first vehicle's recording
had captured when radio interference
occurred again the foundation pulled the
vehicle back and the 2D classes were
recovered safely with no abnormal
effects occurring as a result of being
exposed to the gas still there was no
indication of what was actually
occurring in daleport it was only that
lifeless gray Horizon and the foundation
wanted answers a third expedition was
carried out this time manned by mobile
task force operatives equipped with all
of the latest gear as well as several
large Vehicles the vehicles split up but
Communications quickly pointed out
differences between the team's
surroundings One spotted an upward
incline while the others only saw the
same terrain as before minutes later the
incline team reported that they were
going down an incline the team that
hadn't seen the incline reported that
they were now seeing it and they were
following the other vehicle downwards
another team noticed red and blue blue
patterns in the sky while voices on the
radios began speaking in an unknown
language after minutes of radio
interference the foundation picked up
the sound of a firefight with mobile
task force operatives giving wildly
varying descriptions of the attacking
forces whatever was happening was
incomprehensible and for whatever reason
the foundation was entirely unable to
communicate through their radios after
around 30 minutes of noise an unknown
voice gave a mysterious gibberish-filled
message to the foundation it's a little
silly to hear but there's certainly some
strange undertones within the voice said
this is
currently covering the sound of their
horn rather using my value
foreign
again
shall survive
it was clear that something had taken
over the town of delport and that this
mysterious voice while threatening
sounding was apparently protecting the
people inside it mentioned that the
foundation's men were in safe hands and
that evil had been summoned to the town
the foundation didn't know what to make
of the message or if they could trust
the entity that made it but they didn't
have much of a choice they attempted to
send more unmanned operations into the
town but they were unable to reach their
destination somehow always winding up
back where they started shortly after
departing after a week and a half of
fruitless Expeditions and no new
information the gas blocking the town of
delport dissipated completely leaving
the town accessible and able to be
explored fully by the foundation a
containment crew fully set up a
perimeter around the area with secure
cameras and an entire facility on the
outskirts of daleport named area 37 to
oversee and support the foundation's
research efforts inside the town which
which was now officially categorized as
scp-1936 with the gas now dissipated the
foundation began to investigate the
anomalous effects left in its wake the
town itself was altered with buildings
physically differing from their previous
States and a large portion of them
having become topologically inconsistent
there were rooms that would appear
bigger or smaller than they should be
with some growing so small after they
had been entered that they trapped
occupants inside and prevented them from
moving resulting in a number of
unretrievable foundation Personnel
becoming stuck and lost inside the
anomaly forever other doors would lead
to different locations at different
times of the day or corridors that led
to multiple locations at the same time
despite only leading to one these
difficult to describe spatial anomalies
were so dangerous and unpredictable that
the foundation forbade any exploration
into
scp-1936 without explicit authorization
but while the town itself was a affected
what about the people inside it the
normal people who were caught up in the
anomalous fate of daleport what happened
to them the foundation was unsure and
while no survivors were found within the
town itself a large number of human
remains of daleport citizens were
recovered during the exploration efforts
most of these remains demonstrated
anomalous properties presumably gained
as a result of the devastating anomalous
disaster that plagued the town a week
prior some of the remains the foundation
recovered were incredibly strange such
as a smear of entrails found alongside a
small plant that gave out a constant
Flame the pile of viscera picked up
radio Transmissions from up to six miles
away with sound being created through
vibration of tissues another was a torso
embedded in the wall of a building
slight movement of the Torso was visible
when investigating Personnel spoke and
blood continually manifested in mid-air
15 centimeters above the Torso on the
Main Street of the Town several corpses
were discovered with their flesh skin
and bone all removed from a circular
portion of their foreheads skin and
brain tissue surrounding their wounds
had undergone severe charring outside of
the public library several floating
torsos manifest at certain times each
day simulating the Motions of running
alongside the road after three minutes
the torsos attempt to leave the road and
Fade Out a young woman's body flowed
steadily upwards when any force is
applied to it regardless of the Force's
Direction the body is currently
suspended 57 meters above the ground
floating over daleport and these are
just some of the strange anomalies found
within
scp-1936 while it's unknown what
happened to these civilians their bodies
were clearly affected by whatever
occurred the week prior while the
foundation was unable to access the town
of delport something in that strange
anomalous gas triggered a highly
destructive event that had grave
consequences for ordinary people and the
foundation was none the wiser as to what
it was
still they continued their search of the
area and over the next few weeks they
discovered a number of recovered
materials from the wreckage and debris
of
scp-1936 the first were a series of
written documents composed by the town's
previous inhabitants these were
recovered from laptops and journals for
red in that same nonsensical tone that
the mysterious voice spoken during the
mobile task Force's Expedition one note
said that the writer was running out of
canned food and that there was constant
screaming coming from outside their
house and something trying to break into
it the note talked about the town's
Reverend described as having too many
spaces in him who was walking past the
rider's windows and ranting about total
nonsense the note also read that the
writer was fearing that as they put it
one of the big guys was coming their way
and that they could hear the pounding
constant sound of drums but one note
remains consistent found in multiple
locations throughout SCP 1936
predominantly in public toilets and
stitched into the internal organs of the
daleport resident's bodies it reads I am
so sorry that I could not save you
signed pangalos the foundation had heard
Rumblings and rumors of the entity known
as panglos who was supposedly a god with
a helpful affinity for Humanity but
there was no concrete evidence pointing
towards the being's existence whatever
happened in daleport was pangloss trying
to stop it the message certainly reads
that way surveillance footage from a gas
station painted an even more terrifying
picture an ordinary gas station cashier
was doing his job bringing out a
customer's items when the window next to
him smashed open and an impossible
looking tentacle-filled entity made its
way into the building the tentacle
creature lashed out at the two of them
brutally murdering the customer with the
force of the impact of its slippery
writhing appendage the cashier hid
behind the counter but the footage shows
the entity also making its way behind
the counter and the gruesome visual of
blood splattering the walls behind the
register as the entity quickly took the
cashier's life but then mysteriously an
individual enters the gas station
wearing a bowler hat and a waistcoat the
footage distorts as they enter the shot
then their face is revealed instead of
ordinary features like a mouth or eyes
they have a triangle branded into their
skin the tentacle entity moved back in
fear of this well-dressed individual
clearly afraid of them then a series of
multi-jointed appendages burst forth
from various points on the individual's
body and they lunge forward attacking
the tentacle entity the footage cuts off
there with the individual throwing the
tentacle creature through the wall of
the gas station whoever this individual
was it was clear they didn't take kindly
to the rampaging tentacle entity some
Foundation researchers began to
speculate that the individual was
pangloss themselves who is trying to
save Dale Port as best they could but
there was obviously no no way to be
certain of the mysterious person's
identity more footage showed a car crash
outside of a public library which
resulted in a spectral translucent
entity Breaking Free from the broken
Lamppost that the vehicle collided into
the car's passengers immediately ran but
the ghost-like entity chased after them
this continues until the ghost emits a
large Blue Shockwave of unknown energy
which passes over the people turning
them completely transparent and causing
them to fade away the foundation
recognized that it was another
mysterious surreal entity rampaging
through daleport clearly whatever
happened here was anything but normal
another collection of footage this time
focusing around daleport's town hall
depicted the building in complete ruin
the roof was collapsed the front doors
were missing and the entire structure
was toned in a blue violet Hue in front
of the building was a convoy of vehicles
civilian trucks and cars as well as the
ground vehicles of the mobile task force
squads that went missing after they were
sent into the anomaly it was clear this
footage took place shortly after the
foundation attempted to enter the gas
surrounding daleport and lost connection
with the task forces that were sent in
the footage shows the foundation
soldiers as well as the civilians of the
Town fighting against another
strange-looking entity this time shaped
like a fractal structure eventually they
Retreat into the town hall building
narrowly escaping from the strange
creature and directly into a circular
blue violet Vortex after all the
civilians and Personnel have escaped the
phrase pangloss grants you Sanctuary is
burned into the stonework above the Town
Hall's entrance it was this footage that
gave the foundation a better idea of
what occurred in
scp-1936 though the strangeness of the
visuals didn't clear much up whatever
disaster happened in daleport whatever
resulted in these absurd hostile
entities being Unleashed upon the town
was actively combated by pengloss the
deity who was trying its best to move
civilians to safety but one question
remained if pengloss was transporting
civilians to safety where did they wind
up why did the foundation not discover
any survivors inside daleport well their
answer came a few weeks later when in a
shocking turn of events 94 live
civilians and nearly all of the Missing
Foundation Personnel manifested inside
the area 37 facility pengloss's
emergency escape method worked and the
civilians were confirmed alive and
without harm it's not very often that
missing persons are actually recovered
in the foundation's line of work so hats
off to pengloss for managing to do some
good in this horrifying situation
interviews with the recovered
individuals indicated that they all
suffered memory loss regarding the
events of daleport so unfortunately
there was no new information to be
gained from their recovery but inside
the anomaly Foundation Expedition teams
uncovered more documents and pieces of
evidence this time referring to a cult
named the victory society which the
foundation began and to believe was the
cause of the mysterious gas arriving
over daleport and the town's destruction
little is known about the victory
Society but it is believed to be a
religious organization that was
localized to daleport one note recovered
from the body of a victory Society
member was a list of things that the
cult needed which included a strange and
ridiculous combination of items
including two trout a bottle of milk
beetles ice dead bodies human eyes and
assorted souls in the margins of the
note there were more personal thoughts
which the writer lamented the difficulty
in acquiring some of the objects another
note was found on the inside of the book
this time detailing a great religious
battle between gods and entities that
the foundation had never heard of once
again it was written in that lofty
nonsensical tone detailing an
all-encompassing Mist that would descend
upon the world which would prevent those
from entering the location the text
described as the place where an event
known as The Awakening would occur if
this text was to be believed delport was
the center of a battle between
incredibly powerful extra-dimensional
anomalous entities who clashed together
with little regard for the residents of
the Town it seemed that penguos the
entity who saved the civilians was just
trying their best to move as many people
as they could to safety away from the
Havoc of The Surreal Battleground that
delport was becoming more documents this
time from the victory society's Reverend
leader detailed the cult performing a
ritual again and again the Reverend
stated in this notes that the ritual was
for in his words the good of everybody
and that the Victor would walk from the
rebels of man and restore Clarity to
those who remain the notes also included
a transcription of a speech given by the
reverend in which he addressed the
victory Society cult with haunting
premonitions of what would come his
voice painted a harrowing picture
brothers and sisters we come together to
Bid Farewell today it has been an honor
to work with you all I could not have
hoped for a better group with which to
secure the future of mankind from the
dawn of time terrible impossibilities
have spawned from the darkness between
Stars not Hayden life simply being
indifferent to it we are as ants to
these Abominations these demented gods
they are so far above us but we are but
in six accordingly we shall look as such
in order to gain the forgiveness in
favor of the Gods we must learn to know
our place before them each of these
things seeks dominion over the laws of
reality itself impose in the nature of
their Twisted existence upon stars and
planets and people the only answer to
this threat these Gods Must Be destroyed
the Slate wiped clean we could not do
this by no means no but we cannot allow
these things to exist a kingdom cannot
have a billion Kings we cannot kill the
gods no Only a God can kill a God we
will bring them here and ban them bind
them until their blood loss is satiated
until all but one is dead always a
single God remains the Victor who
returns to whence they came as the only
God remaining and without the mystery of
delport was solved the victory society
called sought to wage war between the
gods of the universe until one
Victorious being would emerge the town
of delport was used as a Battleground
with all the anomalous effects occurring
as a result of the combat between these
terrifyingly destructive entities and if
you're familiar with the deities that go
toe-to-toe with the SCP Foundation you
know these guys aren't a joke the
Scarlet King and his Legions of devilish
followers the almighty broken God and
the Mysterious benevolent Serpent of the
library are just some of the the
powerful religious entities the
foundation has researched and cataloged
and if what came to delport was anywhere
near as powerful as those examples it's
a wonder the rest of the world is still
here after the fact another piece of
surveillance footage taken from in front
of a church in Dale port center depicts
these violent deities in combat with one
another beings of massive size and
incomprehensible shape battling with one
another in an ordinary Suburban town the
victory society's goal may have been
incomprehensible and difficult to
understand but the foundation will never
forget what happened in the town of
delport and the destruction these
impossible entities caused but a single
question remains we know that pengloss
transported some survivors from the
scene but what was the result of the
battle what happened the victory Society
mentioned that a single entity would
emerge Victorious from the battle but
who was it which God was so terrifying
so powerful that it slaughtered the
others and crowned itself came amongst
the anomalous Pantheon perhaps some
questions are better left unanswered it
goes without saying that the SCP
Foundation has a storied history with
ancient anomalous groups of interest
from the metal worshiping mechanites to
the fire-loving Brazen heart to even the
brutal Empire of the slave owning Deva
who swear allegiance to the dreaded
Scarlet King but perhaps the most
dangerous and downright disgusting of
these groups are the flesh worshiping
disease-loving body warping Circus the
sarcasts believe in returning Humanity
to a nightmarish primordial State they
utilize anomalies to achieve this goal
such as the horrible
scp-610 also known as the flesh that
hates a disease that converts human
beings into mindless beasts of Twisted
flesh driven to spread their disease
further and further the sarkists were
once a world superpower controlling much
of modern day Russia and Eastern Europe
from the holy capital of aditum a city
ahead of its time with towering blood
red temples wide winding roads and the
castle of grand karcissist ion an
immense blistering red and gold
structure that was as beautiful as it
was imposing it would only make sense
that the former area of the sarkic
Empire would host some of the most
ghastly of the sarkic anomalies it
should not be forgotten that while the
sarkists are a group of interest for the
SCP Foundation they are first and
foremost a religion one with ancient
practices of blood and Human Sacrifice
while the SCP Foundation is famed for
its containment procedures when it comes
to the likes of actual deity entities
containment isn't quite as
straightforward the standard put it in a
box until it stops trying to get out
technique just won't cut it the deities
require specific practices that
sometimes go against the core values of
secure contain protect take
scp-2845 for example this entity known
as the
is a being that requires an intense
deadly and specific ritual to keep it
properly contained the SCP Foundation
even had to Outsource help in containing
this anomaly anomalies such as these
place the SCP Foundation at a Crossroads
of action or inaction when this issue is
combined with a sarcic anomaly that
could bring catastrophic results should
containment fail they need to make the
difficult choice of letting the anomaly
stay where it is without intervention
for the safety of the world this
nightmare started in the year 1916
during the Battle of Transylvania of the
first world war as bullets flew and the
smell of smoke pervaded the noses of the
scared soldiers bloodlusting beasts were
waiting their time to strike staking
behind the unnaturally curved trunks of
the trees that lived in the nearby Hoya
Forest soldiers armed with weapons and
tactical armor were quickly and brutally
attacked and consumed by entities that
would become known as the pale men at
the time not much was known about these
pale men and they were believed to be a
myth among the local populace meant to
scare invading soldiers from stepping on
Romanian land but when 244 people go
randomly missing in a single night with
no obvious signs of death no bodies ever
being found and reports of pale men
dashing through trenches and within the
surrounding Hoya Forest the SCP
Foundation would surely have to
intervene this would not occur until
1919 however as World War One raged on
diverting Foundation attention away from
these mysterious deaths agents Frederick
Harper and Rhys Gorman posing as
military officials and local law
enforcement began to speak with the
locals around the Hoya forest and the
surviving soldiers while shell shock
rocked the Soldiers with guilt and
Terror Gorman was able to ascertain that
the soldiers stories of the pale men
were too consistent to be a falsehood
created out of stress the pale men were
described as living vampires more bat
than human and deadly fast appearing in
quick flashes before dragging the
unsuspecting victims to their untimely
deaths within the Hoya Forest meanwhile
agent Gorman spoke with members of a
village within the Hoya Forest near the
battle side their demeanor was cold
which was expected he was an outsider
speaking rudimentary Romanian in an
obviously foreign tongue the Village
People claimed ignorance declaring that
they had never heard stories of pale men
and did not subscribe to fairy tales
Gorman realizing he was unwanted nearly
cut his losses before the Elder of the
village stopped him this elder an old
man draped in hand-knit scarves and red
silks invited the agent into his home
and gave him the troops these villagers
were followers of sarcasism the home of
the Elder was decorated with sarkic
glyphs and paintings detailing the
stories of yaldaboth the primary god of
the sarkists battling mechan the
legendary broken God an electron sat
Scrolls and Dusty tomes detailing sarkic
history from former Kings to stories of
battles that were waged against the
mechanites and Daylights the Elder
explained that there was a sarcic God
within the Hoya Forest known as the
mother who sends out her children to
feed and help her grow even larger the
village worshiped the mother and tried
their best to keep her at Bay by
conducting ritual sacrifices to her and
her brood however the Advent of World
War One LED to difficulties and
containing their rituals as they were
living in an active war zone and the
mother's children and their hunger were
impossible to control leading to the
unfortunate deaths of the soldiers agent
Gorman eventually able to convince the
Elder to show them where the mother
resided a temple superficially
resembling other Eastern Orthodox
monasteries but this was no house of God
that you or I would recognize on the
lower level it contained an ancient
Feast starving for blood and sacrifice
this place soon became designated
scp-2191 otherwise known as the Dracula
Factory new containment procedures were
quickly enacted 20 armed guards were
placed around the temple with strict
orders to dispatch any entity that exits
the structure standard containment
procedures for anomalous buildings were
enacted as well preventing all
non-foundation Personnel from entering
scp-2191 and authorizing the use of
lethal Force when necessary access to
scp-2191 has allowed Foundation
biologists to research the entities that
were known as the pale men these
creatures were found found to be
genetically human but with a variety of
alterations that should have resulted in
fatalities these entities were
subsequently designated
scp-2191-1
scp-2191-1 entities appear to be more
bat than human with large conical ears
that end in sharp tips upturned noses
and the ability to communicate via
echolocation this echolocation ability
comes in handy as
scp-2191-1 are completely blind their
eyes have recessed into their skulls and
a layer of skin has grown over them the
entities also lack pigmentation leaving
them Starkey pale appearing to be made
more of porcelain than flesh or bone
these entities are predators solely
hunting living human beings ignoring
human cadavers or any non-human animal
they hunt by spreading through the Hoya
forest and chasing their victims once
caught
scp-2191 entities will inject their
victims with a paralytic agent by
stabbing them with a sharp bone that has
grown from their wrists they will then
unhinge their jaws allowing a leech-like
entity to exit their mouths and begin
the feeding process by latching on to
the victim's neck this leech designated
as
scp-2191-2 will first inject the body
with digestive enzymes converting organ
muscle and bone into liquid before
consuming the resulting fluids the
feeding process can last anywhere from
20 to 50 minutes depending on the size
of its prey these are highly skilled and
sophisticated predators and while they
lack the higher intelligence of
non-anomalous humans they make up for it
in ruthless ferocity it would only make
sense that the foundation would enact
strict containment procedures to avoid
the loss of human life but while these
containment methods worked for a time a
series of anomalous fans connected to
scp-2191 transpired over the next 70
years the first event was in late
September of 1932. the irsos earthquake
devastated the chakadiki peninsula of
Greece leaving houses crumbled civilians
homeless and causing 490 reported
casualties surveys of the damage
conducted by the Greek government found
that 126 people who lived in the
affected areas could not be accounted
for the question now arises where are
these missing people seven years later
in 1939 this time in Turkey the erzinkan
earthquake struck the country resulting
in the catastrophic deaths of
approximately 33 000 people among the
survivors reports of a Great Serpent
were given from all who witnessed the
event the foundation then intervened
posing as members of an international
Disaster Recovery Agency reports from
the locals remained the same a Great
Serpent a deep red and black in color
and incomprehensively massive casting
Dark Shadow miles long rose from the
ground at the onset of the earthquake
and writhed in the air as the Earth
shook for a period of three years
nothing related to scp-2191 transpired
and the foundation believed that the
anomaly had gone dormant that was until
an earthquake struck verenza Romania in
1940 while casualties were low compared
to the earthquake in Turkey reports from
local survivors had repeated claims that
pale men attacked the fleeing people as
the earthquake occurred chasing after
them and tackling them never to be seen
again with a large-scale event like this
and potential witnesses to anomalous
beings the SCP Foundation was risking a
broken masquerade scenario should the
information spread broken masquerade
scenarios are considered an XK class
scenario by the SCP Foundation and as
such they employed a media blackout and
had newspapers state that the witnesses
of these vampire attacks were nothing
but Superstition in March 1953 in Turkey
the yenis going earthquake led to the
deaths of over 1 000 people the
foundation once again posing as members
of an international Disaster Recovery
Agency interviewed survivors and
attempted to find any connection to the
preceding events reports from survivors
again told a consistent story they
witnessed the arm of a blood red octopus
rupture from the Earth when the Quake
began behaving similar to The Great
Serpent writhing in the sky and reported
that pale men were seen attacking
survivors in the night as they searched
for places to sleep these sightings of
pale men persisted for over a month
after the earthquake before amnestics
could be distributed another event
occurred in March of 1977 in Romania it
was a similar story to all the others
with over 15 100 civilians dying as a
result of the varancia earthquake and
800 civilians being declared Missing
Foundation officials embedded in the
Romanian government were told that
reports of pale men and tendrils pulling
victims beneath the ground begin to
surface leading to Media blackouts and
amnestic distribution as Panic spread
throughout the region the foundation
couldn't figure out what was causing
these events when they began instituting
the containment procedures around
scp-2191 no
scp-2191-1 entities were able to exit
the temple without being quickly
dispatched so how were these events
occurring especially in areas so far
away from the Hoya Forest could it be
that the large creature seen breaching
the Earth was responsible the foundation
decided to return to the village that
originally told them about the temple to
interview their Elder once more Dr
Judith Lowe was given permission to
conduct the interview she was a senior
employee of the SCP Foundation and had
multiple afterwards in sarkic history
and sarkic anthropology her expertise in
the subject was unmatched Dr Lowe had
written multiple studies on the sarkic
culture and understood the only thing
that satiates sarkic Gods blood with
this knowledge in mind Dr Lowe met with
dragon negrescu the current Elder of the
village the Raga was an old woman
wrapped in the red silks and scarves as
the previous Elder Dr Lowe began to
interview and jumped immediately into
the subject asking draga what she could
tell her about the temple draga replied
stating that the temple was home of what
they called the mother the mother was
not unlike a queen bee as she sends her
drones out to collect blood much like
bees collect nectar Braga continued
stating that her Village acted as the
beekeepers to the mother helping the
hive flourish and stay full before the
SCP Foundation intervened daraga
expressed that it was imperative that
they would be allowed to continue you
their sacred duty of satiating the
mother Dr Lowe needed more information
on who exactly the mother was
told her that the mother was once a
princess and the daughter of a sarcic
blood Empress in additum the ancient
sarkic Capital she was a strikingly
beautiful girl wearing the finest of
clothes and had long dark red hair a
trade common to those with ancient royal
sarkic bloodlines when she walked
through the streets of aditum All Eyes
turned toward her the grand karcissist
ion was struck by her beauty and
kidnapped the princess claiming her as
his own she became his mistress while
she first hated her position she slowly
grew to worship Grand karcissist ion as
a god while Grand karcissist ion is seen
as a deity now he was not during his
reign as the king of the sarkic Empire
the princess begged to Bear ion's
children as a result she was blessed by
the Grand karcist and was planted in the
Koya Forest to grow large and wide ion
commanded the princess to bear as many
children as she could muster and she did
the princess birthed ion's children the
pale ones for all of eternity and would
let them feed as ion would want draga
stated that she and her Village are no
different than the pale men as they were
tasked with keeping the mother fed and
satisfied draga then let slip this
chilling
remarks and womb sweats and soon she
will rupture all around you he's thinner
for the gods it seems as though the
foundation's containment efforts led to
the deadly earthquakes and deaths of
thousands of people by stopping the
practices of this Village to contain the
mother through ritual they had
potentially caused an XK Class end of
the world scenario one question remained
though where is the mother an
investigation in to the tunnel system
located below
scp-2191 would lead to the answer mobile
task force units that specialized in
underground exploration such as the mole
rats were sent to the tunnel system
below the temple armed with weapons to
dispatch any loose
scp-2191-1 entities these agents
discovered a grisly site a massive
writhing Mass below
scp-2191 researchers believing draga's
story ascertained that this was the
mother and designated it as
scp-2191-3 this entity is a massive
blood red organism buried deep beneath
the Earth where
scp-2191 stands the true size of the
entity has proven entirely impossible to
measure but root-like appendages have
been found to extend throughout the
tunnels below the Earth these appendages
were found to secrete a toxic highly
corrosive acid
scp-2191-3 uses the fluid to create
tunnels which explains the odd tunnels
below
scp-2191-2 measurements placed the area
scp-2191 spread to approximately 6600
000 square kilometers under the Balkan
Peninsula
for comparison's sake
scp-3000 the amnestic producing eel God
and a toshisha is a measly 900
kilometers in length at maximum with
that in mind now we can see the
gargantuan problem the SCP Foundation is
dealing with
scp-2191-3 is sapient meaning it has an
innate sense of understanding and
self-awareness and exerts control over
scp-2191-1 and
scp-2191-2 organisms via the release of
complex pheromones
scp-2191-1 entities act as feeder drones
for
scp-2191-3 it has since been discovered
that civilians native to several
isolated villages in the vicinity of the
Hoya Forest have actively provided human
sacrifices for
scp-2191 as a means of minimizing the
seismic activity that occurs when it is
famished and this work to satiate The
Entity and prevent further damage to the
earth and its people the foundation now
stood at the Crossroad between active
containment and allowing the people who
knew and understood the anomaly to
contain it themselves the foundation
motto is secure contained protect
however if they allowed Raga negrasku
and her Village to continue their
sacrifices they will be unable to
fulfill any of these core values but
scp-2191 will not be wrecking Havoc this
dilemma led to the involvement of the o5
council a joint statement from them
reads there are some who wish to believe
that the foundation has never nor will
ever cater to the designs and desires of
an anomalous entity Foundation efforts
to contain
scp-2191 are now thought to have
inadvertently led to the deaths of
approximately 40 000 people over 45
years the obvious choice would be to
neutralize the threat and we've tried
the number of Civilian and Foundation
casualties being well beyond acceptable
numbers in order to contain the larger
threat we must allow it to feed we are
aware of the offense caused by this
procedure this is not the first time
Nord will be the last that the
foundation has been forced to commit a
lesser evil in the prevention of a
greater one we do believe that in the
end our current method is the most
preferable with regards to both ethics
and efficiency we are fully aware that
every sacrifice feeds
scp-2191-3 allowing it and its brood to
thrive but we are not about to sacrifice
the entire Balkan Peninsula to
neutralize that threat not yet it was
clear that the SCP Foundation had no
choice but to allow the villagers who
lived around
scp-2191 and the mother to continue
their practices upon their involvement
there was catastrophe after catastrophe
that would only stop once the correct
people draga negrecu and her villagers
could return to their way of life and
end this madness a final contain
procedure was ordered as a result the
SCP Foundation would maintain
surveillance operations via the use of
closed circuit security cameras and
Drone footage all Personnel of the SCP
Foundation would be prohibited from
directly interfering with
scp-2191 or the ritual practices of
communities within the vicinity of the
Hoya Forest which include blood or human
sacrifices to
scp-2191 exploration of scp-2191 would
only be allowed by remote controlled
drones lethal force is only authorized
should
scp-2191 or any of the creatures that
live beneath it breach containment
should the foundation fail in upholding
the ritual practices that keep the
mother at Bay well dragon rescue said it
best all around them is Tinder for the
gods morality tends to get lost very
quickly when you start working at the
SCP Foundation during the Whirlwind of
basic training site orientation and
learning the difference between Euclid
ketter and formula object classes you'll
have to make peace with the fact that as
a new member of foundation staff you'll
probably end up having to turn a blind
eye to doing some morally compromising
things then again it's such a normal
everyday Occurrence at the foundation
that almost everyone working for them is
desensitized to whatever ethically
dubious or downright violent tasks they
have to partake in and at the end of the
day everyone knows that it's all for the
greater good to keep anomalies securely
in containment for the benefit and
protection of humanity but the one part
of foundation life that Simon Bennett
just couldn't reason with was the very
existence of d-class personnel now
anyone with previous knowledge of the
SCP foundation's dubious practices will
of course be aware of d-class but to
Simon who had just been recruited as a
member of site security Personnel the
whole concept was not only alien but
completely abhorrent d-class personnel
as he'd come to learn were completely
Expendable their ranks were filled with
convicted felons almost all of them
guilty of violent crimes the foundation
seemed to have a habit of plucking
inmates from the highest security
prisons and penitentiaries in the world
covering their tracks by staging the
deaths of these unwilling recruits into
d-class from there these criminals were
essentially used as little more than
human Lab Rats and it was this part that
really didn't sit well with Simon the
very idea left him torn on the one hand
d-class were arguably the worst of the
worst most if not all of them were
guilty of horrific and brutal crimes
some that could never be forgiven by
anyone but on the other Simon struggled
to rationalize taking these prisoners
from their incarceration only to subject
them to a no homeless creatures and
entities most scps could do things to a
d-class that were almost as bad as what
these convicts had done to their victims
and some could Dole out far far worse
Fates did their actions make their cruel
faiths justifiable did d-class Personnel
deserve the amount of punishment for
their crimes Simon didn't know it was a
perplexing moral conundrum most days at
the foundation those questions echoed
around his head he was probably better
suited to a role in the Ethics Committee
than Rank and file security he was
uncertain if it was better to leave a
violent murderer to serve their sentence
in prison until their eventual execution
or abduct them and use them as a d-class
guinea pig it wasn't long before his
fellow security officers tried to
dissuade Simon from questioning the
foundation's methods reminding him how
lucky he was to be selected to join them
and how an easy application of amnestics
could take that all away leaving him not
only jobless but is memory wiped as well
ultimately as weeks turned into then
became years in the blink of an eye
security officer Bennett's moral compass
was ground down he started getting used
to the idea of the foundation's way of
doing things asking fewer and fewer
questions to oppose how morally and
ethically ambiguous a lot of their
experiments and procedures were
obedience to others slowly became apathy
and the Simon that had once been
concerned with the ethics of d-class
experimentation soon began looking at
them as Expendable assets just like the
rest of the SCP Foundation did he even
started to resent a few of them that
seemed to have gotten off easy on a few
occasions a member of d-class personnel
got to interact with the friendly kind
of anomaly it didn't seem fair Simon
thought that while he and the other
security Personnel had to put their
lives on the line whenever a dangerous
SCP breach containment meanwhile a
d-class who might have been a multiple
murderer or domestic terrorist got to
sit in a testing chamber with a friendly
entity like scp-999 the Tickle Monster
keeping up to date with the special
containment procedures for the various
anomalous objects and beings held at the
foundation was an essential part of a
security officer's job ongoing testing
and new discoveries that were about an
entity often led to them needing new
updated measures to keep them securely
contained but it was during a routine
check of these procedures that Simon
came across something strange well maybe
not so strange when you work at the SCP
Foundation but definitely a noticeable
level of strangeness reading through the
containment procedures for one of the
anomalies housed at the site Simon found
a list of instructions fairly standard
stuff for the foundation the strange
part was that he was sure that he had
never read this list before but at the
same time it wasn't a new update
recently added to an entry in the SCP
archive it was paradoxically brand new
information a detailed description of
containment measures yet also seemingly
something that had been written and
archived ages ago reading through
through the instructions they described
a process that was essential to keeping
one of the site's anomalies secure it
had even been given its own name the
special containment procedures referring
to the whole practice as a monthly
termination the more that Simon read his
eyes would widen further as he learned
exactly what the steps of this process
entailed in his earlier days he wouldn't
have thought of this so-called monthly
termination as excessive a needlessly
cruel act even by the standards of the
SCP Foundation but that was the old
Simon a man who hadn't yet become Jaded
by his work before he had come to adopt
the same apathy in this regard for life
as his fellow Foundation Personnel
reaching the end of the passage
describing monthly termination Simon
alerted the other security officers
making sure they read the procedure too
some unknown feelings stirred deep
within Simon telling him this needed to
be carried out and it had to happen
right now before long members of staff
had been told to read the entry monthly
termination each one passing it on to
their colleagues then Simon and a large
Detachment of other guards began
marching towards the cell blocks were
d-class Personnel were imprisoned almost
a third of the site's incarcerated
inmates were rounded up it couldn't have
been any more than a few hundred Simon
wasn't sure he couldn't see all of them
from where he was standing but mostly he
didn't care all he could focus on was
following the monthly termination
procedure to the letter together he and
the security Detachment escorted the
collected d-class Personnel through the
facility single file all Marching In
efficient and perfectly synchronized
motion it was almost like a
choreographed military display if he
hadn't been so preoccupied with thinking
only of the procedure Simon might have
realized how strange all this was all
the Personnel were moving at once in
such Flawless timing even though this
hadn't been planned in advance and yet
he and the other Personnel had only just
learned about monthly termination and
yet they were carrying it out as if they
had done it a thousand and times before
the security officers continued ferrying
the d-classes through the facility
eventually leading the convicted felons
to the main entrance the doors were
opened without question nobody who had
read the monthly termination
instructions saw what was going on as
anything out of the ordinary a long
winding row of inmates in Foundation
issue orange jumpsuits were then guided
out of the site's main doors instructed
by the security to keep walking even
further none of them knew how far they'd
really walked a lot of d-class personnel
complained and moaned but the few that
tried to leave the single file lines
were quickly put back in place by the
security department most of them were
directly verbally aggressive cursing and
threatening the security officers but
they seemed compliant walking the way
they were told to it was as if they had
to obey almost like their legs wouldn't
let them resist one begged to be let go
turning to Simon and pleading not to be
taken wherever it was they were going
I'm sorry Simon replied plainly with
barely any emotion behind his words it
was a lie he didn't feel sorry in fact
he hadn't even been sure why he
apologized at all the reply had happened
almost unnaturally like something else
was speaking through him he wasn't even
sure how far away they'd gotten from the
facility it might have felt like miles
if he hadn't been thinking about it but
he wasn't none of the officers were they
were following their instructions
totally unaware that they'd been walking
for so long that they were starting to
get blisters they all somehow knew they
had gotten far enough beyond the reach
and sight of the foundation facility
they started in so far in fact that the
surveillance systems wouldn't be able to
see them still moving with the same
complete synchronous timing Simon and
the other security officers herded the
d-class Personnel towards a wooded
clearing they formed a ring around the
inmates before pushing them down onto
their knees a few of them hung their
heads some even shedding a tear they had
already figured out what was about to
happen those that had him quickly caught
up when they saw the security officers
covering or deactivating their head
cameras then reaching for their arms
when they returned to the facility Simon
and the other officers would all give
the same story they collectively led a
third of the science d-class to an area
out of surveillance range and executed
them all with their handguns at least
that's how they all remembered the
incident but what they thought they'd
done didn't quite match what had
actually happened naturally the
foundation higher-ups quickly got wind
of what happened and of such a massive
expenditure of their Expendable d-class
resources the incident forced the SCP
Foundation to launch a full-blown
investigation into the actions of Simon
the other security officers and
additional Personnel on site they
quickly recognized the pattern of
behavior they had seen it before they
already knew not one of the guards had
actually fired their weapons in fact
none of them had been acting of their
own free will Simon and the others had
no idea that the monthly termination
procedure didn't exist in the
foundation's records and was actually
the symptom of an
scp-2193 of
all those d-class that had been rounded
up and marched out into the middle of
nowhere were still gone though not shot
Point Blank like the officers thought
but the prisoners were still no longer
alive either although he'd never
remember it when Simon had been stood
amongst his fellow officers one of the
d-class had begun floating upwards
lifted off the ground by some invisible
force the convicted felon drifted about
three meters in the air without warning
The Prisoner was then launched up
practically fired towards the sky like a
rocket traveling into the upper
atmosphere at several times the speed of
sound one by one the members of d-class
All Began experiencing the same thing
floating off the ground only to be
catapulted up into the stratosphere with
such speed and force that they vanish
from view in seconds meanwhile all Simon
and the other security officers did was
stand by and watch keeping their head
cams covered or Switched Off The Last of
the d-class prisoners stood in the
clearing the one that had asked Simon to
be set free he was still asking begging
to be helped down as his feet hoisted up
against his will practically screaming
for someone anyone to do something his
eyes locked with Simons for a split
second before he too was sent hurtling
into the sky moving that high in that
fast isn't something a human being is at
all likely to survive now rid of the
d-class that they had led to their
deaths all the gathered security
Personnel looked up it was night
Starlight cast across an Inky canvas of
dark sky but Simon was fixated on the
moon they all were none of them could
take their eyes off it as it slowly
appeared to Blink like a watchful eye
hanging in the space above them not one
of them would remember what they had
seen or what they had truly done no
member of d-class was a saint it's true
they were murderers criminals and
dangerous individuals maybe some of them
were so bad that they did deserve to be
used as test subjects to die at the
hands of anomalous entities but then
again does anyone really deserve to go
out like that little is known about the
point of origin of scp-2193 while it
affects the documents stored within the
foundation's database it does not
function like a computer virus or
artificial intelligence instead
scp-2193-1 is an anomalous piece of
information or an info Hazard as scps
like this are known it has been known to
infect digital files specifically the
special containment procedures for
various entities objects and creatures
that the foundation has recorded in its
archives even their most talented
computer engineers and anomalous
researchers cannot determine how this
info Hazard is able to accomplish this
it seems to infect files at random
without any repeating pattern in its
timing or the type of SCP files it
appears in upon infection a file now
containing
scp-2193-1 will include references to a
monthly termination of d-class personnel
making it as an essential process for
keeping an anomaly secure anyone that
reads this suffers from what is known as
a memetic effect essentially they will
believe what they have read and believe
that they have always been aware of this
information on top of that a person
infected by scp-2193-1 will accept it as
true that the monthly termination is a
legitimate and accepted practice within
the SCP Foundation they can't be
convinced that killing hundreds of
d-class personnel is anything less than
justify now you might be forgiven for
thinking that uninfected Personnel can
easily explain to those who have been
affected by a cp2193-1 that the monthly
termination isn't an official Foundation
policy but this info Hazard has proven
itself to be particularly infectious
when spreading its memetic influence any
member of foundation Personnel not yet
exposed to
scp-2193-1 can be easily convinced that
the monthly termination is both morally
acceptable and a foundation held
procedure that is absolutely necessary
for anomaly containment if anyone that
has read and therefore believes the
monthly termination process the and they
will display a lack of cognitive
dissonance whenever someone attempts to
present them with information that
conflicts with
scp-2193-1 while no document within
their internal database has a record of
the monthly termination procedure back
in January of 1999 the foundation was
able to witness the process second hand
via one of its agents during an scp-2193
event agent yassan's head camera was
left uncovered recording excerpts of the
precise and perfectly choreographed
execution of numerous d-class Personnel
much like the event Simon was a part of
an unknown anomaly caused the Earth's
moon to appear to Blink It is believed
by some within the foundation that this
is the result of a form of Eldritch
entity a being that demands a
substantial Human Sacrifice every month
this being as of yet remains
unidentified just as unclear is this
anomaly's intentions motives or how it
is able to affect or perhaps use the
moon of course the SCP Foundation has
its own Personnel stationed up there
however during recorded instances of
scp-2193 events their agents at Luna
area 32 have reported no unusual
activity or abnormalities at the
corresponding times the running Theory
among some Personnel is that the moon
isn't this unidentified being's actual
eye but some kind of ocular device like
a spyglass that allows it to observe the
monthly termination whatever this being
is it apparently possesses an immense
level of power how exactly it is able to
create
scp-2193-1 and infiltrate the
foundation's internal database with that
info Hazard is still unknown as is the
exact reason why it goes to such trouble
such incalculable lengths seemingly just
for the purpose of killing so many
d-class inmates the immediate assumption
albeit admittedly amorbid and cynical
one held by most Foundation researchers
studying scp-2193 is that this entity
needs this almost ritualistic monthly
sacrifice in order to sustain itself
what idea suggests it could be a
creature that opposes how the foundation
uses its d-class Personnel maybe it just
like Simon used to questions the
morality of convicts being used as
Expendable guinea pigs and as such it
uses its Eldritch levels of power to
remove them from the foundation's reach
for good or perhaps despite its
subterfuge this being feeds on those who
have wronged others making d-class
Personnel Prime candidates that would
certainly explain why the monthly
termination procedure causes security
officers to only bring the foundation's
force of expendable convicts and after
all there are benevolent scps out there
even friendly ones so it stands to
reason that this being could be trying
to rid the world of people who are bad
enough to be put into d-class but then
again this world is rarely so kind
scp-2193-1 makes Foundation officers
bring D classes out to where they can't
be seen causing them to cover their head
cameras and believe a phony story about
execution by sidearm so nobody knows
what really happens to them it even
hides the info Hazard detailing the
monthly termination procedures at random
moving it around to a new file whenever
it's detected such great effort is taken
by this entity to cover its tracks which
would suggest a far more nefarious goal
it is entirely possible that this being
does all this simply to amuse itself
expending countless lives and Foundation
resources purely for a sick sadistic
form of entertainment with no way of
knowing the entity's true intention the
SCP Foundation can only sit and
vigilantly wait an artificial
intelligence surveying their database
for the next instance of
scp-2193 he had been pacing back and
forth all night so many hours spent
walking to and fro in his quarters that
his feet were starting to develop
painful blisters yet Jace couldn't bring
himself to stay still after his
unsettling Discovery over the course of
the night it had driven him almost mad
but it wasn't just the fear of the
inevitable Calamity he had learned of
that was keeping him up and worrying him
into a state of near Insanity it was the
LIE the smoke screen that had been used
to cover up the truth and it came all
the way from the top Jace Jacoby had
been working as a researcher within the
SCP Foundation for the better part of a
decade sure it wasn't an easy job at the
best of time
in fact it could be dirty dangerous and
even downright deadly were but Jace had
learned to take comfort in the bigger
picture and it cultivated in him a
loyalty for the foundation and what they
stood for the reassuring knowledge that
he was playing but one small part in
protecting the world from anomalous
threats usually helped him sleep a
little easier at night this was not one
of those nights completely by accident
the researcher had learned of a terrible
truth he'd seen a lot of horrible things
while working at the foundation from one
horrific endlessly regenerating
omnicidal reptile to a monstrous
creature comprised primarily of giant
teeth protruding from its body but what
he had uncovered in the depths of the
SCP foundation's own archive terrified
him for a whole different reason because
it seemed to undo every good thing Jace
and all the other Personnel had done in
the name of the foundation he believed
that they were the good guys that their
efforts were to prevent total Global
destruction instead it turned out that
they were just pawns being familiar with
a whole filing cabinet's worth of
special containment procedures for
various anomalies Jace was familiar with
the term 220 Calabasas it even almost
been considered to receive high enough
security clearance to be given the full
details as to what it entailed he was
aware already that it was the name given
to a process that was required to be
performed by Foundation staff as a way
to keep
scp-2317 actively contained
scp-2317 was a wooden door leading to
another dimension or at least it
appeared to be after accessing some
restricted files a suppressed secondary
level of information hidden underneath
the scp-2317 entry Jace discovered what
was really going on
scp-2317 was in part a door to another
world as its nickname suggested but that
wasn't the whole story Beyond the Door
Leia barons salt plane the only
structure is visible for Miles being
seven identical Stone pillars with
ancient symbols carved into their
surface frequently a small group of
foundation personnel and security staff
would be sent into
scp-2317 each one of them given a
specific role to undertake as they
performed 220 Calabasas that process
required for active containment was more
like an occult ritual involving holy
water an obsidian edged knife chants
that invoked ancient powerful gods and a
chicken to act as a live sacrifice if
Jace had just learned those specifics of
220 Calabasas he wouldn't have realized
that the ritual was actually a phony
even a pretty convincing one at that
buried beneath the pillars was chained
something of unspeakable unknowable
power it had gone by many names each
invoking a particularly nasty sense of
trepidation The Sire of tyranny
or simply the Devourer of world the 220
Calabasas ritual was supposedly a way to
keep the Beast locked below to
strengthen the seven chains each
latching the ancient monstrosity to the
pillars above except it didn't it was a
smoke screen the ritual did nothing to
keep the shackles of the Devourer intact
there was but one chain remaining one
more tether keeping the ancient Beast
caged and over the years no matter how
many times the foundation performed 220
Calabasas it was eroding getting weaker
and weaker it was inevitable the
Devourer of Worlds would one day be free
and yet that wasn't even the worst part
about what Jace had uncovered what could
possibly be worse than learning an
Eldritch deity intent on furling Doom
couldn't be contained with the one
method the foundation had while it was
at the foundation new it had known for a
long time that 220 Calabasas was nothing
more than a charade with all the
effectiveness of a Band-Aid over a
broken leg as if that wasn't bad enough
Jace had traced the source of this
cover-up right to the very top to the
highest operational level within the SCP
foundation's hierarchy the o5 council
was responsible they had known for a
long long time about the ineffectiveness
of 220 Calabasas and yet hadn't pursued
any more permanent solutions to the
looming threat posed by a cp2317 and the
Devourer after a sleepless night Jace
could hold it in no longer he had to
tread carefully given how far up the
chain this conspiracy went it was hard
to know who to trust something had to be
done that much was clear to him whether
that involved sealing or outright
destroying
scp-2317 but if those tasked with
overseeing the entire Foundation were in
on this cover-up then Jace had to be
extremely careful about who he went to
for hell there was only one person he
was certain he could rely on and share
his findings with in secrecy senior
researcher Alice had long been a good
friend of Jace's in fact he'd even go so
far as to say Ellis was his only real
friend within the foundation the more
experienced member of personnel had
practically mentored Jacoby from his
earliest days as an SCP researcher Alice
had helped him get to grips with certain
difficult containment procedures and
even taken the fall for Jace after some
of his early mistakes nearly caused a
Containment Breach researcher Alice's
seniority meant he only got away with a
metaphorical slap on the wrist but most
crucially for Jace right now Ellis
wasn't a high enough rank to be even
close to any of the upper echelon
Foundation doctors like Dr bright or Dr
gears nor was he senior enough to have
any direct dealings with the o5 council
if there was anyone working at the
foundation that Jace could possibly
confide in about his findings regarding
the truth behind
scp-2317 and 220 Calabasas it was Alice
and maybe between them the pair could
put their heads together and avert the
catastrophe of the devourers in
inevitable Escape Jace was nervously
pacing back and forth while Ellis's eyes
were glued to the terminal in his
quarters he had shown him a saved copy
of the full archive entry on his CP 2317
detailing everything not just the steps
required to perform 220 Calabasas but
the additional information about the
ritual not working and at the o5 council
knew it after a long painful wait for
researcher Alice to scan through the
entire file he leaned back from the
terminal screen and sighed well this is
hardly ideal he stated matter-of-factly
hardly ideal Jace echoed his fear of
what all this meant manifesting itself
as a frustrated Outburst I think you
might be underestimating it a little
there Alice this isn't just some mild
inconvenience we've now got to live with
we're talking about the end of the world
as we know it XK class and on top of
that the council knows it's coming and
are doing nothing about it instead
they're making these high clearance
Personnel go and pointlessly Slaughter
chick Dickens and recite meaningless
prayers about Seven Seals Seven Rings
seven Thrones for the Scarlet King
Jacoby calmed down Ellis replied
strongly let's talk about this
rationally for all we know this file
here could be a part of scp-2317's
containment procedures that's what I'm
saying the procedure is ineffective he
argued let me finish the senior
researcher responded calmly we know of
dozens of other anomalies that employ
info hazardous or mimetic effects and
sometimes it's not uncommon for entities
of such nature with capabilities to
infect information itself to be combated
via the use of deliberate necessary
misinformation this file might not even
be an accurate description of scp-2317
it could easily be a method for
containing something else no that
doesn't Jace paused holding his forehead
sorry all this has given me a headache
could I trouble you for some water of
course Ellis answered he got up from a
seat and filled a plastic cup from a
cooler in his quarters while his back
was turned Jacoby didn't see Alice slip
something into the water thanks Alice
Jace said as he gulped down the whole
cup like I was saying that theory of it
being a memetic threat doesn't make
sense you've seen scp-2317 from a
distance we both have it's a physical
dimensional Gateway I mean a door to
another world is literally its code name
for God's sake why would there be a real
door with an intangible info Hazard
behind it Ella stroked his chin
pondering quietly for a moment Jace's
Vision seemed to get a little blurry but
he blinked it away okay so if we take
everything in the scp-2317 file is
Gospel then answer me this what do you
propose we do about it his mentor asked
we have to think radically together I
think you and I need to come up with an
alternate permanent solution to the
impending threat posed by a CP 2317 then
we present it to the o5 council storm
into their chamber if necessary and
demand them to implement it the next 220
Calabasas is scheduled for a few hours
from now we need to bring them something
that will actually work not just that
performative pantomime they put on as a
smoke screen otherwise Alice Jace paused
for a moment hearing his own voice crack
with despair if we don't the Devourer is
going to destroy everything you said the
words permanent solution elaborate for
me please Ellis responded look I think
we have only two options the frightened
researcher said Jace noticed he was
starting to feel drowsy lightheaded even
aiding to shake himself to stay upright
and conscious we either find a way to
seal scp-2317 or we destroy the door to
another world outright the 220 Calabasas
procedure that no Rich
ritual they take a one kiloton nuke and
with um in case of containment failure
right we detonate one of those inside
the dimension pray that it kills the
devour
worlds then we shut the door and blow
blow that up the eyes too suddenly
Jace's legs gave out underneath him like
they couldn't support his body weight
anymore he landed on the floor with a
thud while Ellis loomed over him with a
sympathetic look on his line face
here he's drunk me Jace barely managed
to get the question out I'm sorry Jacoby
Ellis side believe me when I say I would
have preferred to talk you out of these
seditious thoughts the duty to the
foundation comes first you understand
the door opened Bevy clumping of boots
against the floor Jace could barely turn
to see the squad of security guards
entering the room they lifted his body
up off the ground getting limper by the
second and began dragging him out by his
arms with all his waning strength he
kicked and thrashed his legs as they
trailed beneath him being taken away by
the guards Jace yelled for his mentor's
help he kept trying until his voice
became slurred imperceptible sounds not
even words anymore the world around him
started sinking into darkness as
whatever he'd been dosed with took full
effect as Jace was hauled off struggling
not once did Alice dare to look him in
the eye Jay said no idea how much time
had passed only that he'd been
chemically knocked unconscious for most
of it opening his heavy eyelids he had
no idea where he was the room around him
was in Pitch Darkness for a second he'd
wondered if he'd been executed by the
foundation and was currently dead his
Consciousness trapped in an endless Inky
void then another concerning thought
pushed its way into his head had they
thrown him into the Devourer of world's
prison was a cruel callous move even for
the SCP Foundation to offer Jace up as a
sacrifice for daring to look further
into the truth behind
scp-2317 the column of light cut through
the dark from somewhere above him
leaming down so bright that it was hard
to look directly at it the spotlight did
little to illuminate the rest of the
room although squinting in the dark the
researcher could detect the outlines of
several figures sat in a circle facing
him 13 of them to be exact with one
extra taking their seat he was just
awake enough to remember a crucial
detail that explained where he was there
were 13 members of the o5 counts all
along with one administrator hello again
researcher Jacoby came a voice from one
of the seats encircling him tell us do
you know why you're here
you Jay stuttered before his fear once
again erupted in an explosive Outburst
you all knew about scp-2317 you had us
perform 220 Calabasas time and time
again knowing that it was doing nothing
to keep the Devourer contained if that
creature gets loose no when it does it
will destroy everything and everyone the
foundation is meant to contain anomalies
not pretend to we have a duty to every
adult child on this planet to protect
them from this entity do not exposit the
foundation's mandates to us Jacoby
another of the council member's voices
replied sounding not in the least bit
concerned if anything they sounded bored
the SCP Foundation acts in accordance
with Council dictates not by if I'd have
a moral framework you have chosen to
impose on this organization but the
Devourer of world is coming Jace pleaded
you all know as much I I've seen it in
the scp-2317 file inevitable you used
that exact word we are aware of the
threat phase by
scp-2317-k or the Devourer as you called
it a third council member interjected
but rest assured at the time 220
Calabasas was established to provide an
illusion of containment we calculated it
would take several decades for the final
chain holding the creature to give way
that time might have already elapsed the
researcher argued and in the meantime we
have no countermeasures prepared no
strategy and the rest of the Personnel
have no idea that this threat is coming
almost exactly the same wording as last
time one council member said not
addressing the rest directly but still
just audible enough for Jace to detect
it what do you mean last time yes
thinking back a few short moments to the
beginning of this exchange wait what why
did you say hello again when I woke up
here there was a horrible nauseating
silence throughout the room for a moment
Jace had already worked out the answer
why would the council bother telling him
the truth now I figured this out before
haven't I he said a handful of times one
of the voices replied if not use and
another member of personnel every now
and then someone snoops and covers
something they shouldn't and you make
them forget it Jace finishes their
sentence for them before he applies
gymnastics the voice said observe
today's 220 calabases procedure is
already on the way a huge curved screen
blinked to life it filled half the
circumference of the room but wasn't
enough to give Jace any clearer of a
look at the o5 council each one of them
was cast as shadowy silhouetted figures
against the images now appearing on the
screen it was footage being streamed
live from one of the Personnel cleared
to enter
scp-2317 they were already in the middle
of Performing the phony ritual spritzing
holy water over the Seven Pillars
unaware that one of them was still
linked to a chain keeping the Devourer
imprisoned below suddenly there was a
rumbling a shaking reverberating through
the ground on the video feed like an
earthquake or something moving
underneath oh my
Jace breathed as he watched in horror
it's happening the Devourer is coming
now get them out of there some of the
o5s mumbled awkwardly to themselves we
shouldn't act with too much haste it
could just be the creature reacting to
the ritual one hypothesized it's been
imprisoned for a lot longer than a lot
of us have lived it's bound to get
Restless another concurred besides the
security team are armed with a nuclear
device in case the worst should happen
on the screen the Tremors were
continuing the Personnel member in
charge of applying the holy water
dropped the silver aspergillom and
asporium containing it spilling its
contents Over The Salted earth below
without any further warning the ground
started to crumble in the feed an
enormous clawed hand bursting up from
underground it was followed by the
hulking shape of something much larger
breaking through the salt plane sending
a tidal wave towards the Personnel
member whose body cam footage was being
displayed the feed cut out and the room
was dark once again it's too late Jace
stared at the council in a mix of Terror
and disgust you did nothing and now it's
too late before any of them could reply
another Tremor rang out this time
beneath Jace's own feet the Devourer of
Worlds was here it was bursting through
the wooden door of
scp-2317 and tearing the foundation
facility apart with its immense size as
it emerged the walls cracked the entire
building beginning to crumble around him
and the o5 council were all hurriedly
exiting the chamber to whatever plans or
bunkers they had to ensure their own
personal survival suddenly the huge
weight of something dropped through the
dark and collapsed on top of Jace
standing up amongst the wreckage of the
obliterated building the Devourer of
Worlds Drew itself up to its full height
it was an impossibly large creature
humanoid and obese its entire body was
covered head to toe in thick armored
scales with horns atop its jawless head
from one of them hung the final chain a
withered shackle no longer keeping the
monster held within its underground
prison the seven chains had all failed
the ritual 220 Calabasas had failed in
fact it never worked in the first place
far below his arms pinned painfully
under a heavy slab of concrete Jace
stared up at the Towering form of the
Devourer he had felt scared as the
building came down around him and even
now there was a lingering fear of his
own death but there was something else
there too a sense of feeling oddly
relieved not necessarily glad to be
right about the impending doom or even
pleased to know this ancient trap deity
was about to destroy the whole planet
but at least the Devourer of Worlds was
honest he thought there was no
subterfuge no rituals acting as a smoke
screen no more lies just an honest
Simplicity of a creature whose only goal
was to bring an end to everything as
Jace watched the Devourer raised its
hands up reaching the highest Pinnacle
of the sky then brought them straight
back down to earth it planned both deep
into the skin of the world deep enough
to crack the very surface open mantle
and magma were spewing everywhere like
blood from the gaping wounds had left in
the planet Jace Jacoby closed his eyes
as the ground beneath where he lay
trapped ripped open plummeting him into
the dark it had been a long day
Expeditions like this were normally
tiring but with the intense heat of the
Egyptian sun bearing down on them every
minute felt like ours and every hour a
lifetime Seth and Kayla were determined
not to quit they had traveled Halfway
Around the World to get to this site and
they weren't about to let the elements
stop them from uncovering the secrets
they were searching for the rumors had
dated back centuries stories of a hidden
tomb lost somewhere out in the desert
and as a likely pair of budding
Adventurer and an accomplished
archaeologist neither one of them could
resist the chance to try and hunt down
the tomb if they could uncover it they'd
have one of the greatest archaeological
finds of the century on their hands both
Kayla and Seth would forever be
remembered as the ones who discovered a
supposedly unfindable ancient tomb
having found their way to some ruins the
remains of a temple that had been all
but raised to the ground ravaged by the
forces of time Kayla and Seth had
started searching for the tomb's
entrance the reason it had stayed
uncovered for so long was the amount of
sand that had covered it over the
centuries storms from the desert
constantly rearranging the grains and
piling on more but right now the skies
were clear and all they could do was
keep digging until at long last their
shovels struck Stone clearing a path to
the entrance Kayla flipped on a torch as
she led her archaeologist friend down a
flight of stairs carved into the stone
Seth followed her as they Traverse
further and further down the air getting
stale the deeper they went the whole
while there was a non-concern at the
back of both of their minds that the
rocky ceiling above could give way at
any moment trapping them both
underground but before each of them
could voice their worry out loud they
arrived at a large stone door left wide
open about 20 meters beneath the surface
is this really it Kayla asked in
disbelief it might be Seth replied the
excitement in his voice like that of a
kid on Christmas morning standing before
them beyond the threshold of the open
entrance was a chamber of stone its
ceiling was Secure about seven meters
high and the walls had been covered in
hieroglyphics immediately Seth shot over
to the nearest wall pulling a battered
Journal out of his bag to start to try
to translate what had been written while
he was doing that Kayla's attention fell
over the rest of the room for a tune
there was a surprising lack of a
sarcophagus nor any other similar
resting place for a body with no signs
that anyone else had already been here
to remove one either all there really
was within was a few goals randomly
placed around the chamber Kayla's
Torchlight fell over one of the bowls
and she knelt down to take a closer look
at its contents it was filled with bread
they were all holding different foods
dates figs dried fish and lentils of
course it wasn't uncommon for offerings
to be left with the deceased during an
ancient Egyptian burial but strangely
none of these perishable foods seemed to
have decayed in the centuries this tomb
had been lost for in fact it all looked
quite fresh like it was still good
enough to eat although the temptation to
actually eat any of it quickly
disappeared when Kayla reminded herself
that while it might not look it the food
down here had to have been hundreds
maybe thousands of years old despite how
perfectly preserved it appeared I think
I've got something Seth called
enthusiastically there's definitely a
story in these hieroglyphics you sure
were in the right place Kayla asked as
she crossed the room to where her
colleague was for a tomb it doesn't seem
like anyone was ever buried here I've
got a theory he replied this place might
be more of a metaphorical tomb right
that makes complete sense her sarcasm
was unmistakable look here he said
pointing to one of the drawings on the
wall as he spoke it depicted a figure
laying dead in a square space I think
that's meant to be this room someone
dies here and then Seth's finger moved
to another of the hieroglyphics one that
Kayla recognized it showed a being with
the body of a man and the head of a
jackal taking the dead figure down into
the Afterlife this was Anubis one of the
ancient Egyptian gods associated with
the afterlife according to Legends and
other texts gathered from the pyramids
in Giza Anubis oversaw the process the
Egyptians would perform to embalm their
dead preserving them for their trip to
the next World Anubis takes whoever they
are to the Judgment Hall of the
afterlife to be brought before Seth
explained only to be cut off Osiris got
a fertility the afterlife and the dead
Kayla interrupted she had already
spotted the next being depicted in the
glyphs a tall figure with a distinctive
headpiece holding a symbolic Crook and
flail oversaw Resurrection Life probably
many other things yeah he was a god with
a few different hats Seth attempted to
joke well just the same one had he's
always shown wearing also technically
not a hat the Atif was a type of crown
and so hold on Kayla interjected again
didn't Osiris only bring the Pharaohs in
for judgment who was this person that
died I mean the Egyptians never went to
this amount of trouble for their Average
Joes and the gods wouldn't pay them any
mind unless there were important somehow
I'm not sure Seth answered earnestly at
any rate this could all just be a myth
that's why I think this tomb is
metaphorical it wasn't built to house a
dead person but to keep people believing
she finished his sentence for him he
then pointed out the next part of the
glyphs the dead figure arriving in the
afterlife carried by Anubis for judgment
and then handing an object to Osiris
Seth explained there was a certain myth
surrounding Osiris and his resurrection
a story that told of all of his dead
body parts being found except one
without it the God could not be fully
resurrected my theory is that is
Osiris's missing appendage as it were
Seth's face was red as he tried to keep
his composure after our mysterious
friend handed it over the hieroglyphs
showed the nameless dead figure being
taken from anubis's Hand by Osiris who
then placed them back in the room they
had started in the same chamber Seth and
Kayla were standing in it seemed they
had been resurrected after death giving
Osiris something that the God had wanted
had earned this figure a free pass back
to the land of the living the glyphs
also showed bowls of food around the
tomb like the ones Kayla had found
dotted around the room there was a type
of Aura drawn around the unknown figure
now almost like a personal Shield
according to the drawings and symbols on
the walls and Seth's hastily translation
of their meaning this was some form of
protection granted by Osiris himself the
arrow was meant to prevent the figure
from harm meaning they couldn't die
again however the next portion of the
story showed Anubis damaging The Shield
possibly out of jealousy or spite or
perhaps defying Osiris tampering with
the natural Order of Things by
protecting the figure from Death as well
as causing damage to the aura of
immortality that Osiris had bestowed
upon them Anubis trained the figure of
all of their blood which then caused
them to go and do the same to others
Seth continued interpreting aloud it
would find people drink their blood to
sustain it like don't say it Kayla said
I mean it's a lot like a VIP Egypt gave
us mummies they can't have another
native monster from horror B movies she
interrupted well maybe the legend found
its way here somehow or at least a more
ancient Egyptian version of it her
counterpart tried to reason it looks
like here the figure was Far healthier
after consuming blood see how the aura
around them is repaired now but sadly
look at what they're standing on Kayla
whispered one of the final images in the
glyphs did display exactly what Seth had
described but beneath the feet of the
figure who now seemed replenished was a
mass of bodies a pile of human corpses
with one person standing at the very top
who'd want to live forever anyway Kayla
muttered almost inaudibly hey come and
have a look at these leaning over she
picked up one of the food bowls from the
floor brimming with offerings of dates
she handed it to Seth who marveled at
how well preserved the food was that's
incredible you remarked this bowl looks
like it's at least several thousand
years old and guess maybe 2500 BCE but
the dates he poked one out of the bowl
and sniffed it put it back and then did
the same with another making sure it
wasn't a fluke the conditions couldn't
possibly have kept them fresh so how is
it there are bowls of food all over this
room that still look edible she asked I
honestly have no he began to say but the
sound of heavy grinding stone
interrupted Seth's sentence both he and
Kayla looked in horror as they witnessed
the entrance of the Tomb being sealed
the heavy stone door dropping moments
away from sealing them in Seth we need
to run Kayla urged grabbing her bag if
we move now we can get out of here
before we get shut in but Seth protested
looking around the tomb the glyph walls
that had only just been discovered
nobody would know that he and Kayla had
found them if they ran now he looked
around the room pondering for a moment
his eyes starting from a bowl of bread
to the bowl of dates in his hands we
should at least take photos no time our
lives aren't worth proving what we found
better to make it out than be buried
alive Kayla shouted darting towards the
entrance ducking under the slowly
lowering stone door Seth come on she
called from the other side despite her
calls for him to move her fellow
Explorer didn't follow he just stood
there watching the door get lower and
the only way back to the surface get
narrower by the time it had completely
closed Kayla's voice sounded so much
further away that Seth could barely make
out what she was saying I'll get help
find some way to get you out Kayla
screamed at the wall now separating her
from the tomb if you can hear me Seth
ration the water in your bag take small
sips every few hours Seth already knew
that the human body could survive around
three weeks on just water and no food
and he trusted Kayla would have figured
out how to get him out by then he gave
another glance to the food bowls
scattered throughout the tomb the idea
of eating any of it knowing how old it
all potentially was did turn his stomach
a little but if it came down to having
to eat just a bite in order to survive a
little longer Seth was sure it looked
fresh enough to still be edible it
couldn't hurt to take a bite right over
the next few days Seth's Focus was spent
entirely on photographing and
transcribing being more of the
hieroglyphics occasionally stopping to
take swigs of water from his canteen if
anything it was more to combat how warm
and stuffy it was being locked inside
the stone chamber 20 meters underground
meanwhile unseen to Seth outside Kayla
was working tirelessly to try and figure
out a way to get the door open she had
been searching for days for any sign or
some kind of switch or lever that would
unseal the chamber entrance there had to
be some mechanism that had caused the
stone door to shut itself in the first
place but there was nothing around that
looked like it fit that description as
much as she urged Seth to abandon his
archaeological Finders Keepers Pride
Kayla was hesitant to make the long
journey back across the desert to Cairo
to get help anyone she brought to the
dig site might claim the discovery as
their own and more to the point the more
time she spent traveling across the
desert for help the more time Seth would
spend trapped succumbing to gradual
dehydration and starvation little was
Kayla aware it was already too late Seth
hadn't been observing her warning about
managing the amounts of water he was
drinking and pretty soon his canteen was
empty he cursed himself annoyed for
being so involved in his discovery that
he'd now potentially put his own life at
risk but then he remembered the food
bowls kneeling down he picked up the
nearest one the same bowl with all the
dates in it shaking his head at the
thought he put them back down again the
longer he waited the more Seth began to
worry that maybe Kayla had abandoned him
and if she had and he was faced with the
inevitability that he would die down
here lost and forgotten in an ancient
tomb underground he couldn't help but
find something ironic about the whole
thing he was going to die in a tomb
whose walls told the tale of a dead
person being brought back to life maybe
in a few hundred years more
archaeologists would find this buried
room and think he was the one the tomb
had been constructed for even trying to
put an ironic spin on things wasn't
enough to give Seth much peace when
staring down the possibility he might
not see the Sun and walk above ground
again and getting closer to death is
what made him want to avoid it tempting
him towards the bowls of food every time
he tried to remind himself not to touch
any of it the pain in his stomach
swelled even greater reminding him of
his own hunger with no clear view of the
sky Seth had little clue just how many
days he'd been trapped in the Tomb
although he was sure it was approaching
the day four threshold he couldn't
survive much longer beyond that point
without eating as the days dragged on he
abandoned his research and note-taking
it was impossible to focus on
translating hieroglyphics when he was in
so much pain aching from the Heat and
having no food or water exhaustion
causing him to pass out his body trying
to conserve its already limited reserves
of energy eventually Seth started trying
to rationalize eating at least a date or
two the food hadn't decomposed or rotted
at all even introducing air from outside
when the tomb was first open hadn't
changed the state of any of it at all
not the dates nor the bread or the fish
it still looked fresh and edible and
after God knows how long without eating
it was beginning to look all the more
appealing to the starving archaeologist
who cares if it had been there for a
thousand years or longer if Seth didn't
eat he knew he wouldn't last much longer
the moment he chewed on the first date
feeling it passed down his esophagus
passing from his mouth to his stomach
Seth immediately regretted giving in to
his need to eat his mouth instantly went
dry far worse than it had been after
this long without water it was like the
tiny piece of fruit had pulled all the
saliva from his mouth Seth tried to
scream and panic only to release a horse
dry-throated grasp as he felt his tongue
shriveling up with his mouth and throat
until it felt like the skin of a drum
but it didn't stop there it only got
worse Seth stared in horror at his own
arms the blue veins that ran underneath
his skin rapidly draining away his
forearms and biceps shrunk muscle and
sinew shriveling like his body had been
left in a water evaporator all the while
the pain of having his entire physical
form being reshaped was pure Agony the
dehydration of his mouth meant Seth
still couldn't scream only dropped to
the ground as he felt the same thing
happening to his legs every drop of
moisture in his body every fluid from
water to blood saliva and even urine was
drying out leaving Seth as little more
than a Dusty desiccated husk before his
own eyes he could only watch as his skin
lost its pigment drawing into a thin
leathery texture drained of its original
color as his blood stopped flowing
outside Kayla had been coming back to
the tomb sealed door every day and would
stay until the late hours of the evening
she tried digging down from the surface
to reach the chamber where Seth had been
trapped but it was too far underground
there was no sign of any way to move or
reopen the stone door that is until she
heard the heavy grinding of it opening
on its own Kayla raced down the steps
towards the tomb it had been five whole
days since she and Seth got separated
and he'd need food and medical attention
sprinting into the dark tunnel she
arrived just in time to see the entrance
reopening expecting to see Seth standing
on the other side as the stone door
lifted which he saw instead was a
nightmare it looked like a corpse an
ancient and decomposing dead body Kayla
had seen plenty entombed in sarcophagi
on her many travels exploring ancient
runes around the world but she had never
seen one standing up it was still
breathing a wheezing raspy sound
escaping its mouth its skin looked
almost brittle as if it was stretched
too thin almost see-through enough to
show off the bones underneath the
upright Corpse's face was all wrong too
sunken cheeks and eye sockets deeper
than they should have been it looked so
different that it wasn't until Kayla
shown her flashlight on its drained face
that she recognized who it was Seth he
lunged at her immediately racing towards
her snarling with his dried mouth Kayla
turned and ran as he came after her bony
fingers swiping at her clothes her
flashlight gripped in her hand was all
but useless as she sprinted back the way
she'd come swinging back and forth in
her arm barely Illuminating much of the
cavern that led to the tomb the whole
while she was running from it she could
hear the wheezing behind of Seth behind
her terrified of whatever he had become
and why he was chasing her then she saw
it the stairs her one shot at getting
out and getting away if she could make
it to the surface she could put some
more distance between herself and the
drained dehydrated corpse all she had to
do was make it up the last step she just
made it when she felt the shriveling
hand grip her ankle tripping her over
falling face first in the sand Kayla
scrabbled at the loose grains trying to
pull herself away as her body was
dragged back down onto the stone stairs
she felt a searing pain and screamed
into the empty desert as The Corpse's
fingers dug into her neck its leathery
dry skin against hers eventually
screaming stopped replaced with a dry
horse gasping and then silence as Seth
drained her body of her blood along with
the rest pulling Kayla's Body by her
ankle Seth dragged whatever was left of
her back down towards the tomb
scp-3359 to feed on what was left
anomalous creatures in the SCP
foundation's Universe are not a rarity
dealing with anomalous Sapient life
forms is the foundation's bread and
butter whether it's talkative sea slugs
or a body stealing swarm of ants for
those of you who haven't read their
Ethics Committee guidebooks Sapient
anomalies are defined as creatures who
have a keen sense of self-awareness and
can communicate from the zaniness of Dr
bright and his amulet to the neck
cracking SCP-173 these Sapient anomalous
entities come in all shapes and sizes
but when does a creature become so
sepient they can be considered anomalous
take the humble octopus for example who
also just so happens to be the subject
of today's video the octopus is a
boneless eight-legged creature capable
of Shifting the color and texture of its
skin and Will Blast Predators with a
black substance to Blind them if I read
that in an SCP Foundation file I might
think those researchers found an alien
creature but no octopi or octopodes are
as you know real living breathing
creatures you can see at any aquarium
another interesting Quirk of octopods is
their intelligence these creatures are
smart extremely smart hell they'll even
use Fallen coconuts as a sort of armor
against enemies if tool use isn't
intelligence I don't know what is you
may be wondering how can you make an
octopus more anomalous than what I've
already described well today on SCP
explained we'll be taking a look at
scp-2967 the Sapient cephalopods to
answer that exact question we've all
probably been to aquariums dark ambient
room where the only light comes from
behind the massive tanks filled to the
brim with colorful fish and Crustaceans
they can be fun to explore but when
you've seen a bunch of exotic fish once
it's not like you're clamoring to get
back in soon this was the problem faced
by the Galaxy aquarium in May of 2010
attendance was low and profit was lower
the owner of the aquarium was a man by
the name of Mark Hemphill he was young
and extremely ambitious Mark had an
interest in marine life since he was a
child and dedicated his life to studying
the creatures of the sea when he opened
the aquarium he had just gotten out of
college he hoped his passion and his
aquarium would Inspire even just one
child to pursue the study of marine life
as he did Mark's ambitious personality
was not going to let him watch his
life's work go to waste at a nearby
Auction House the anomalous group of
Interest Marshall Carter and dark were
organizing a showing for their new batch
of anomalous creatures available for
bidding seasoned viewers of scpc have
likely run into anomalies that Marshall
Carter and dark have had a hand in for
those not in the loop Marshall Carter
and dark are dealers of anomalous goods
and services selling anomalies to the
highest bidder no matter who they are
from the average Joe to a tyrannical
dictator Marshall Carter and dark only
care about Cold Hard Cash and getting as
much of it as they can Mark hearing
whispers of a massive auction coming up
decided to attend he entered the auction
house an old dilapidated Warehouse on
the sketchy side of town not exactly
inspiring confidence but Mark thought
maybe just maybe there would be
something for him to add to his aquarium
to get more attendees marked walked
through the heavy metal doors to an
Immaculate auction space the building
was loaded with well-dressed individuals
who gazed over the items they had for
sale wooden tables lined the walls of
the warehouse and on top of each table
were tanks and cages of creatures Mark
never thought could exist from dogs that
smelled like candles two purple frogs
that telepathically communicated with
the people around them Mark was
convinced that there was something here
he could use a staff member approached
Mark almost immediately it was as if the
staff could smell the willingness to
spend money on him she was an older
woman dressed in a fine purple huge suit
she spoke with a comforting Candor to
Mark asking him about his day and what
brought him to the auction house she
introduced herself as Jay and said that
the auction house had just the thing for
Mark before he could even get the words
out they walked to the opposite side of
the building where a purple curtain was
erected walking through it was as if
Mark had returned back to his aquarium
what were the odds that this place would
have a marine life section oddly for
such a well-designed room there was only
one small tank placed in it within it
was six octopodes a pale yellow in color
Mark immediately recognized the species
as the common octopus the Galaxy
aquarium already had a pod section with
much more rare species than the common
octopus dejected Mark almost gave up
hope before Jay approached the tank and
kneeled Jay seemed concerned and called
out the name Levi from under the table
on which the tank stood a massive
octopus slithered into sight startling
mark it was at least five feet in height
and length that's impossible Mark
thought there's no way that an octopus
of this species could get to be this
large the octopus's size was not the
only Oddity it held though Jay began to
scold Levi for leaving its tank and
asked what it had to say for itself she
threw a Sharpie marker to the ground for
Levi who uncapped it and began to write
out the word sorry on the concrete floor
this couldn't be Mark thought there was
absolutely no way that an octopus can
learn to understand English let alone
ride it Jay turned to Mark encouraging
him to talk to Levi uh what's your name
Mark as sheepishly he couldn't believe
he was trying to to talk to an octopus
as soon as the words left his mouth the
octopus spelled out
l-e-v-i with its marker mark couldn't
believe it this had to be some trick
right some sort of marketing gimmick to
get him to buy an overgrown piece of
calamari there is no way that an octopus
could have self-awareness Mark knew they
were smart of course he had studied
these things for years but knowing its
name that's not possible what are you
Mark questioned hoping to figure out if
it was an animatronic instead of a
living breathing animal Levi began to
ride on the floor again not a word this
time but a symbol the octopus first drew
a large oval then eight lines coming
from the bottom a crude drawing of an
octopus behind Levi the other six
octopodes were watching him as
Spectators seeming to clap when Levi
finished the drawing Jay with a smug
grin on her face asked Mark if he was
impressed the look on Mark's face
already told the story so Jay began to
go over the pricing of the creatures
Levi and the other six octopodes were a
package deal with a starting bid for all
seven placed at three thousand dollars
Mark without a second thought asked if
he could outright purchase Levi and his
compatriots for ten thousand dollars Jay
smile grew wider and she shook Mark's
hand without another word said Levi and
the six other octopodes were delivered
to the Galaxy aquarium the next day
within that time Mark had already
prepared an unused section for the
arrival of his new attraction the
cephalopods were placed in their tanks
without much difficulty and settled into
their new home advertising began for the
Galaxy aquarium's newest attraction the
talking octopus Mark even splurged on a
billboard on the nearby Highway this
investment was meant to save the
aquarium and for the next few months
attendance skyrocketed now we know why
the SCP Foundation keeps a heavy watch
over anomalous entities in the public
because all it takes is one ambitious
person before the entire world knows
that anomalies exist with the popularity
of Levi it was a matter of time before
the SCP Foundation heard of it it was
time for an investigation site-12 was a
site dedicated to marine life and as
such many of the Personnel station there
had the appropriate expertise to deal
with the anomaly agent Hooper
volunteered for the investigation He was
ordered to pose as an animal behavior
specialist from the sea coral Pacific
Federation real creative there SCP
Foundation it just so happened that at
the same time agent Hooper was getting
involved Levi was beginning to give Mark
a hard time at his aquarium it was a
late night in January 2011. the aquarium
had since closed after another day of
almost full attendance Levi was not
sleeping however he was hungry and by
coincidence the section of the Galaxy
aquarium next to Levi's tank was a
potential all-you-can-eat buffet should
his plan come to fruition the next day
aquarium staff awoke to the filtration
system of the crab enclosure being
blocked by one of Levi's friends it was
quickly removed and placed back into its
proper tank it wasn't out of the
ordinary for octopodes to escape their
tanks as I explained there are smart
creatures aquarium staff began the
process of moving the crabs to a
temporary tank while repairs and
cleaning on the original tank were
taking place as their attention was
drawn to the damaged filter and
contaminated crab tank Levi managed to
escape and enter the unguarded temporary
tank of crabs broken shells and water
splattered the floor of the temporary
tank room as the feast began it was a
massacre Levi ate 20 of the 40 crabs and
another 10 were dropped off into the
octopus's Tang for Levi's comrades
satisfied with its meal Levi returned to
his tank as if nothing had happened an
hour passed before the leftovers of
Levi's dinner were discovered and it
didn't take much guessing on the part of
aquarium staff to deduce who was behind
this agent Hooper arrived the next day
and asked to meet with Mark Hooper
explained that he was from the sea coral
Pacific Federation and his place of
employment had heard of Levi and wanted
to study him Mark like a moth to a flame
eagerly took the opportunity to describe
the remarkable events of the previous
day Hooper nodded along with the story
and promised to figure out why Levi was
acting this way agent Hooper was
escorted to the talking octopus section
of the aquarium and asked for some
privacy which he was granted Levi was
sitting on a large mound of sand while
the smaller octopods sat in front of it
as if they were intently listening Levi
was apparently lecturing the group using
a sharp Rock to carve words and pictures
on the Plexiglas walls of the tank agent
Hooper knocked on the glass startling
the group in Anger Levi swam to the
front of the tank and stared at agent
Hooper with a tentacle it knocked hard
on the glass and then endeavored to
return to its lecture agent Hooper
didn't catch the hint that he was
unwelcome and stayed uncomfortably close
to the glass until Levi couldn't ignore
the agent any longer the octopus held up
five tentacles and made a shoeing motion
towards Hooper who was incredibly
surprised Hoover recognized the motion
as the phrase go away in Sign Language
Hooper responded asking Levi sign
language in sign language in response
Levi once again held up five tentacles
and created what appeared to be a fist
then bobbed it back and forth like a
head nodding an octopus that knows sign
language not the most dangerous or
extraordinary anomaly that the
foundation has ever discovered but still
this anomaly could not remain out of
containment Hooper quickly contacted the
research head at site 12 and explained
the situation he needed a containment
van for an aquatic anomaly a containment
force and Class A amnestics immediately
this request was granted Foundation
mobile task force Lambda 12 Pest Control
stormed the building and wrangled the
aquarium staff into a closet so they
couldn't interfere the agents were
dressed in their tactical armor and held
large rifles but this was only to show
that they were meant to be taken
seriously and not to be used for force a
white unmarked containment fan arrived
soon after Foundation researchers ran
into the building and transported Levi
and his students into the temporary
tanks of the containment van and made
sure they were securely closed and
mocked multiple times when each octopus
was secured an Airborne version of
A-Class amnestics was distributed
throughout the aquarium by the mobile
task force agents leading to all
knowledge of Levi being forgotten by the
aquarium staff and Mark for further
containment the SCP Foundation
distributed liquid amnestics into the
city's water supply so that anyone who
saw one of Levi's performances would
forget that it ever happened the SCP
Foundation classified Levi as
scp-2967 and discovered the full extent
of its anomalous attributes
scp-2967 of course has the ability to
communicate through written language is
able to recognize and identify colors
symbols and individual figures of other
species and holds an abnormally High
intellect almost comparable to an
average human's intelligence this six
comrades of
scp-2967 were designated as
scp-2967-1 as they do not seem to be at
the same level of intellect as
scp-2967 through behavioral analysis and
research it was found that
scp-2967 will refer to
scp-2967-1 as its students friends or
Army Dr Reynard the head researcher on
the scp-2967 anomaly began hosting
intelligence checkups on
scp-2967 every two weeks these consisted
of Levi talking to Dr Reynard through
the use of a waterproof magnetic slate
while the doctor asked Levi questions on
one such occasion the foundation
discovered that there may be more
creatures similar to
scp-2967 and its students Dr Renard
began by drawing a crab an octopus and
scp-2967's toy he labeled them crab
friend and toy on its slate SCP
2967 wrote like and then a sketch of a
heart Dr Raynard drew a check mark on
his clipboard before rewarding
scp-2967 with a prawn following up Dr
Reynard asked if there was anything Levi
didn't like to display this concept Dr
Reynard Drew an X over a heart symbol
Levi paused for a moment seeming to
think then Drew what appeared to be a
bird with outstretched wings and an
angular beak Upon finishing the drawing
the octopus's skin changed to a deep red
color Levi wrote don't know word on his
slate then returned to its normal
colorization Renard displayed a photo of
a pigeon to Levi who marked an x on his
slate signifying that there was
something wrong before shifting its skin
black in response Dr Raynard returned to
a picture of a crow to Levi who
scrambled to write on its slate that
word it wrote hastily Renard responded
Crow with his Newfound knowledge Levi
drew a heart with an X through through
it on its slate then spelled out don't
like Crow Dr Renard was confused how did
two species of creatures who live in
completely different habitats have a
disdain for each other
scp-2967 began to explain Levi sketched
an octopus a crow in what appeared to be
a human over the head of the human Levi
drone arrow pointing at the human before
drawing a check mark over the sketch of
the octopus and the crow Levi connected
the check marks to the arrow above the
human with two lines it seemed that the
crows and the octopodes disdain come
from their common ability to connect and
grow fond of humans the intelligence
check included after Levi explained this
to Dr Renard as the octopus claimed it
was tired and wanted to return to its
containment chamber the next day however
it seemed that
scp-2967 had correctly predicted what
would happen at site 12. on April 3rd
2011 research staff at site 12 reported
a high concentration of American crow
surrounding the building many were
perched in trees or on the roof of the
site but some were simply hovering near
the entrances seeming to hope that the
door would open while the crows weren't
aggressive to humans who would fly to a
window connected to the containment
chamber of
scp-2967 and peck on it this continued
for hours and it seems that the crows
were threatening Levi and his friends
the foundation deployed mobile task
force Lambda 4 bird watchers to site 12.
this team was not armed in your standard
tactical gear and heavy Weaponry they
wore camouflage clothing with shoes that
muffled their Footsteps in grassy
environments they had jackets of thick
leather to prevent injuries from Talons
or beaks and they had specialized pellet
guns they used to incapacitate anomalous
Birds they began by shooting the birds
away and capturing a few using meds for
further study as they concluded all but
one of the crows dispersed this Crow was
similar to Levi much larger compared to
non-anomalous members of its species the
large Crow flew 10 feet from the
entrance of the site and spat the
decaying remains of one common octopus
out onto the asphalt parking lot before
retreating the bird watchers attempted
to follow the group of crows but the
flock was impossible to track what was
found however was an area in a nearby
Forest that contained an abnormally
large number of feathers belonging to
the American crow species as well as
numerous small makeshift Huts made of
sticks and dying leaves and a collection
of various litter fashioned into basic
tools such as hammers made of bolts and
toothbrushes the most surprising item
retrieved during this exploration was
the torn remnants of a copy of the
documentation for
scp-2967 capped in the largest Hut as is
standard the SCP Foundation enacted
surveillance procedures on this location
placing hidden cameras and microphones
as well as traps the large Crow has been
classified as scp-2967-b
so it seems that the animal kingdom is
at War for the favor of the human race
while the foundation Only Knows for sure
that octopodes and crows are at Battle
there may be many more species out there
who look to Curry our favor who do you
think will be the victors should battle
commends call them what you will be it
myths urban legends ghost stories or
just full Yarns the fact is we've all
heard at least one traditionally stories
like that were just shared around a
campfire but nowadays they have ended up
spreading far and wide across internet
message boards and creepy threads
everything ranging from unsolved missing
persons cases actually being the result
of alien abductions to haunted videos
carrying an unforgiving curse or some
missing unaired episode of popular TV
shows that had somehow been Unearthed by
an online sleuth we're always quick to
share these ideas these stories but deep
down a part of us knows that there's no
truth to them Urban myths are
speculation that someone has turned into
A Tale of Terror for nothing more than
to give some quick scares to whoever
they tell it to but then that person
passes that tail on to someone else and
suddenly the story had become a
widespread Legend with no discernible
point of origin sure they might still be
fictional but through sharing these
stories we as humans bring them to life
not literally of course that would be
outlandish after all when was the last
time you heard of a fictional story
becoming reality growing up with
exposure and unfiltered access to the
internet in the late 2000s Paul Jacobs
and his friends had been fascinated with
and admittedly pretty terrified by the
notorious legend of the Slenderman it
began as whisperings in an online Forum
a story that was intentionally designed
to be a modern day Urban myth and just
like so many others before it the myth
spread what had started as a forum post
became became unnerving photoshopped
images of a tall faceless figure in a
suit lurking in the woods next an indie
video game and even a real world tragedy
given how young he was at the time still
being in high school Paul and a few
others had bought into the Slenderman
myth wholesale he believed it to be real
this towering expressionless Boogeyman
the more he learned about this
malevolent creature every story blog
post or creepy YouTube video made about
Slenderman only added more and more to
his Legend and kept young Paul awake at
night afraid that every noise outside
his bedroom window was the faceless
horror of course if you take away that
belief the possibility an urban legend
might be true then it simply loses its
power it's that potential that maybe
Towing the line between fantasy and
reality that can allow these stories to
go on and incite fear forever but that
wasn't the case for the Slenderman story
and The Craze for it quickly died down
after it was debunked numerous times
over casting it permanently back into
the realm of fiction but the profound
effect the legend had on Paul at a young
age ended up informing his future as he
Grew Older his past fear of certain
stories became a keen interest in how
these Tales could influence people could
any story have that same impact or only
those that walked the line between
fictional and maybe being true did these
urban legends become more real to people
because of their subject matter or did
human beings give them that power to
transcend the constraints of fiction
just by believing in them as Paul got
older he began to study the truth behind
certain urban legends attempting to
trace them back to their Origins some
were often inspired by real events but
with specific details that had gradually
been altered from the original story the
more and more people passed it around
ghost stories seemed to be the most
changeable but with some roots in the
real world a person might have died a
hundred years ago and the story of them
haunting their old home or final resting
place would start to circulate then
shortly after another similar story
might emerge and the two would overlap
whoever was telling each story might
have added or omitted certain details or
combined elements of more than one tale
until what was left being passed around
was neither the first story nor the
second but a hybrid of different
versions from different storytellers
there was one legend that Paul felt
drawn to more than others and it was a
rather obscure one to say the least
during his self-conducted research into
stories of this nature he learned about
a tale that told of an ancient sect
called the davites according to Legends
some that dated so far back that they
preceded almost all of recorded history
these daveites were a callous and cruel
civilization they had emerged from a
book so the story went and sought only
to wage war on other cultures and
enslave their enemies but Paul also
uncovered one detail of the story that
intrigued him more than any other it
referred to something known as the
Eternal text and was regarded as some
kind of deity or figure of worship by
the devites The Legend stated that this
text had helped create the book that
they had emerged from of course this all
sounded like highly fictitious nonsense
to Paul Jacobs he knew that things of
such nature didn't exist in the real
world they were only part of stories but
he had noticed that this particular
story seemed to have passed its way
through the ages searching further Paul
had uncovered The Works of an obscure
author from the United States who had
only a few works that were known about
during the 1940s and 50s even then most
of his stories weren't widely published
only a few shorter pieces making it into
a magazine that had long since stopped
being printed this writer had died in
1957 having never seen his career in
fiction come to fruition but despite his
short-lived career and being considered
a somewhat subpar author at the time the
writer's work had garnered its own
little cult following online mostly
comprised of amateur authors it was
through them that Paul managed to obtain
some scanned copies of the anonymous
writers stories particularly some that
he felt wore a striking similarity to
the David Legends of the Eternal text
one story in particular written in a
style lifted directly from H.P Lovecraft
was based on a supposed encounter the
writer claimed to have had with
something that closely resembled the
Eternal text Paul also studied the
writer's own personal journals that he
had managed to recover scans of the
entries from it seem to imply that the
author came across what he called the
written God and that this compelled him
to write a fictitional version of those
events it was only after writing about
this new encounter that what he had
depicted in his story seemed to come
true exactly as he'd written them this
led to a recursor process of the writer
creating these encounters only for them
to occur thus causing him to write about
it and then make it happen the entire
Prospect not only confused and
bewildered Paul but intrigued him
further as well although he had no way
of confirming what this writer had
claimed was true Paul believed that on a
smaller scale the author had achieved
the same effect that occurs during the
passing down of urban legends but the
difference here was that it had all been
done through himself via a singular
person telling variations on the same
story allowing it to continue and
perpetrate recursively of course Paul
didn't actually believe in this written
God or Eternal text those were all just
part of the fiction but he wanted to
experiment further and see if he could
achieve the same process for himself
taking an empty notebook Paul started to
write the first things that came to mind
basing a short story off of the
anonymous author's own tale he intend
intentionally changed a few key details
noting down things that weren't in the
original the written God appeared behind
me he wrote adding on a whim the line it
had no face the whole intention of
Paul's experiment was to pass his new
version of the story onto someone else
and then try to get them to write it
from memory he wanted to observe if
their mind would change certain details
subconsciously or if they would
misremember elements when they retold
their new version if enough people could
spread the story around each time
altering or adding new parts to it what
effect could it have as he finished his
Rewritten version of the author's tale
attaching it to an email to send to one
of his fellow writers Paul was
blissfully unaware of just what he'd
done a heavy knocking rang out
somebody's fist pounding at the front
door loud enough to wake him bleary-eyed
Paul checked the alarm clock next to his
bed it was the middle of the night
stumbling out of bed he staggered his
way towards the repetitive noise unsure
who or what would be calling the Slate
Paul froze for a second casting his mind
back to the story he had written earlier
surely not it couldn't be right it was
just a story after all but the author he
had described how the things he'd
written had come true there it was that
possibility that maybe what if it was
behind the door right now suddenly
something much heavier than a hand
bashed against the wooden surface of the
front door causing it to fly open the
catch of the lock being ripped out of
the wall by the force of the impact a
group of black-clad figures rushed in
one of them tackling Paul to the ground
before he could even process what was
happening the weight of another person
pinned him down and kept him from moving
despite his attempts at struggling free
then the feeling of something sharped
poked at the Exposed Skin of Paul's neck
a needle filled with he wasn't sure all
he really knew right now was how dizzy
he was unable to stop himself from
slipping away the a sedative quickly put
Paul back to sleep as the agents filed
into his home the floor he woke up on
was freezing cold blinking his heavy
eyelids until they opened again Paul did
his best to stand his head was still
spinning making it hard to keep his feet
still and to make matters worse the room
around him was hardly lit only a few low
fluorescents dimly illuminated the tiny
Space Mr Jacobs a voice boomed over a
crackly intercom the pitch lowered to
distort it further we need you to answer
a few questions for us what corresponded
in confusion what did you first learn
about scp-582
The Voice questioned barely giving Paul
a moment to think about what what's an
SCP he asked back he wrote a story
earlier today correct boomed the Unseen
speaker meekly Paul nodded his head
for any mentions of scp-582 or anything
using any of its known aliases you mean
that written God Eternal text thing Paul
replied catching on to what the voice
had been referring to I read about it in
some stories by this old author he died
ages ago most of his work is pretty
Niche it's actually hard to track down
enough The Voice interjected bluntly
when did you specify scp-582 would
manifest manifest he raised an eyebrow
confused again it was just a story
that's what I was doing I was examining
stories and how they change when they
get passed on Mr Jacobs it sounded as
though the voice had shifted still
distorted but now calmer more collected
somebody else was speaking it is
important to answer our questions your
life could be very well
do you remember when you wrote that
scp-582 when it
came to appear what do you mean in
danger Paul retorted in a panic what the
heck even are you people calm down Mr
he looked down to see his hands were
trembling suddenly aware of the sweat
coating his forehead Paul took a series
of deep breaths trying to collect
himself I I don't remember he sighed his
voice now shaking as much as the rest of
him was
The Voice pressed him can you tell us
where it's going up here I didn't write
a location either Paul answered I I just
said it appeared the words he had
written earlier quickly Came Crashing
back into his head almost like an urgent
warning behind me as he spoke Paul could
sense someone standing near him that
same sensation you get when you know
another person is in the room even when
you haven't looked directly at them yet
Paul tried to keep his head forward only
tilting it slightly to the side seeing
something dark looming just behind his
shoulder he couldn't rationalize any of
what was happening he was too scared to
turn all the way around doing that would
admitted all of this was real and not
just some horrific nightmare not just a
story
for the first time the voice over the
intercom sounded uneasy what do you
think you need to turn around
telling himself he'd wake up any second
Paul rotated with his eyes screwed shut
snapping them open once he was facing
nothing a blank space lacking any
expression and all the normal features
was looming over him with an empty
eyeless stare it had no face just like
in Paul's story he opened his mouth to
let out a scream only for it to be
interrupted by the crunching sounds of
neck bones twisting the wrong way as
Paul's lifeless body dropped back down
to the cold floor
scp-582 vanished just as quickly as it
had arrived the thing about some
anomalies is you have to be very careful
about how you talk about them not just
because they could be listening in and
might hear you but because what you say
about them might just have a nasty habit
of coming true that is the case with
scp-582 otherwise known as its rather
apt nickname a bundle of stories what's
so fitting about that title is its
accuracy that's all As
u582 really is stories but therein lies
it's true power this entity has a way of
propagating and perpetrating itself
continuously adapting and spreading like
a mutating virus except it doesn't pass
from person to person as an illness
there are no symptoms it transmits via
stories
scp-582 is a subject to a process of
passive reality manipulation it doesn't
necessarily directly change the world
around it but can itself be changed by
certain factors what this means is
anything said or written about this
entity even if pulled out of thin air a
fictional account of its Deeds all
becomes real let's say for example you
told a story about scp-582 sneaking up
behind a foundation researcher when his
back was turned telling that story would
cause those exact events to be carried
out in the real world when scp-582
manifests it will do so in accordance
with any details given in a fictional
account about it the same time the same
place on Earth it would appear in the
exact form that the tale specified if
any of those details were omitted or
purposely left vague then the entity
would still be able to manifest and
would do so in a way that fits the rest
of the narrative appearing wherever and
whenever it has an opportunity to as far
as the researchers at the SCP Foundation
can tell the actual abilities of scp-582
are usually left vague when people write
about it one of the few consistencies is
that the entity can disappear and
reappear and will to any place or time
another is that no method of harming or
even killing scp-582 has ever worked
even if written down as fiction in order
to be made fact and the other details or
abilities that someone assigns to the
creature will however become a permanent
addition to its growing myth meaning it
is able to perpetually increase its
power the more people write about it on
the rare occasion multiple different
writers accounts of scp-582 contradict
each other or don't fit into the
entity's own Canon it can easily adapt
to these contradictions this usually
results in conflicting information
having no effect on the bundle of
stories or having so little impact that
it is almost like they didn't happen at
all in short if one author's story
doesn't quite match up with another's
then the effect these additions have to
scp-582 and its ongoing story are
lessened so that they can all either
logically occur or be negated completely
it is because of this adaptability and
that it has been described by multiple
sources that portrayals of scp-582 tend
to be generalized this even extends down
to its appearance it's currently unknown
what the entity's true form is or if it
even has one However the fact that it is
usually depicted as a deity or God means
that this bundle of stories has been
known to manifest as one of several
avatars the most common of these
appearances is that of a humanoid being
standing well over six feet tall when
manifesting as this particular form
scp-582 is dressed in thickly layered
robes made from burlap or Hessian
complete with a hood however no face is
visible underneath the creature's hood
and when presenting as this Avatar it is
often described as carrying sacks of
unknown contents sometimes even
appearing to bleed heavily there have
been a number of other incarnations of
scp-582 including a six-legged form that
is made out of pure molten tar and will
attack any nearby human beings on site
this Avatar would normally appear as
being fused with the first in other
instances it has appeared as a plant
capable of producing both light and
enough radiation to kill anyone in its
radius within a few hours of exposure
other times it has been a vaguely
human-shaped Shadow and even has one
form that exists within more than three
dimensions due to this form existing on
higher Dimensions this made it
impossible to properly perceive it with
the naked eye and resulted in the depths
of anyone who even looked partially at
it who knows maybe at some point it has
even been described as a tall slender
figure in a dark suit with pale skin and
a face with its eyes ears nose and mouth
all missing actually it's probably best
that nobody writes it down we don't want
it becoming real now do we the question
is how can you hope to contain or even
fight something that can be anything
anywhere and have any strength that
someone claims it has well just to be on
the safe side the foundation uses its
own fictional narrative to keep the
entity contained it is their hope that
by describing it as powerless it will
turn the creature's own reality altering
properties against it and actually cause
scp-582 to lose its ability
what thoughts if any that flow through
that alien mine are not mine to know it
remains silent and still within its
chamber entrenched in the Persistence of
its own memory it remains but only as a
shade of what it was its power spent
where at least come to rest so remember
scp-582 possesses no actual
Consciousness or free will anything it
has ever said or done is because someone
wrote that it would and yes we're only
saying that because we don't want to
write that it's broken free from
containment and is currently standing
behind you if we did that it might just
come true who doesn't love a party right
a lot of us jump at the chance to leave
all of our troubles behind and get
together with friends and family for a
good time celebrating a special occasion
while unencumbered by the weighty
responsibilities of everyday life
parties give us an excuse to kick back
to meet new people as well as catch up
withhold acquaintances and Mark a
holiday or someone's birthday in the
most memorable way possible or at least
they can be when you're one of the
guests invited to a party but when you
happen to be one of the poor souls
tasked with organizing one they can
change from an exciting and much
anticipated social Gathering to a
dreaded time sink of organizational and
logistical chaos can you tell I needed
to organize 05-1's 141st birthday party
recently I'm still recovering from the
stress but I'm not the only one
suffering from this particular kind of
anxiety for a young man named Alex
planning an upcoming shindig was turning
out to be that particular kind of
absolute nightmare that anyone who has
ever tried to organize a party will be
all too familiar with it had seemed like
such a long time away when Alex had
first drawn that short and oh so unlucky
straw two months on paper sounds like
forever plenty of time to get everything
ready but the list of jobs that needed
doing before the dreaded party date only
seemed to get longer and more
complicated with each day that passed
you see normally Alex thrived at keeping
himself organized every part of his life
usually running like clockwork the trick
as he found was to pay attention to what
he could control naturally in life the
unexpected usually tends to happen but
Alex had learned that by regimenting his
daily routine having specific times for
certain tasks and scheduling the week's
events on his calendar he could keep
himself pretty on top of everything it
was that organizational mindset that
meant that Alex's friends decided to
nominate him as the sole planner for an
upcoming surprise birthday party of
course being organized and in control of
one's own life goes completely out the
window when trying to coordinate all the
various moving parts needed for a party
it had been left up to to Alex to sort
out when this celebration was going to
be held along with who would be
attending the entertainment food and
drink setting up group chats to update
everyone along with a whole calvicade of
other important party factors each one
fraught with its own potential problems
from the beginning it was an uphill
battle the first venue Alex had booked
had to cancel the whole building needed
to be fumigated because of a rat problem
guests were rsvp'ing at a sporadic rate
some would confirmed their attendance
only to back out days later with the
party day drawing closer and closer the
planning had become a perfect storm of
problems that were all out of Alex's
hands in an effort to regain some
control he raced out only a week before
the party stocking up on finger foods
and beverages that were all extremely
overpriced but by now the party was only
a few days away and Alex was acting in a
blind panic you see it was in that Panic
that he reached for something throwing
it into his shopping cart without fully
thinking about it it was a pinata a
hollow paper mache animal designed to be
filled with candy and hit with sticks
until the contents burst out sure it was
a childish party game and in the back of
his mind Alex wasn't sure why he'd
picked it up maybe part of him thought
everyone would find it amusing a bit of
quaint nostalgic entertainment he barely
noticed how it didn't even seem to
resemble any known animal and was
instead shaped like a strange cross
between a unicorn and a llama Alex was
too lost in everything else he still had
to do to think about the pinata for too
long his biggest mistake was deciding
not to put it back in the corner of the
Party Store where he'd found it
arranging for the surprise to take place
at one of his friends houses Alex's
party seemed to be coming together at
long last but still he was in a state of
panic with only a rough estimate of how
many people were going to be there and
no clue who might show up or not
gradually the guests filled in and the
more of them that did arrive only caused
Alex further worry that he hadn't bought
enough food and drink much to his
frustration a few who had canceled
managed to change their other plans last
minute and made it despite saying they
wouldn't be able to despite everything
coming together the whole event still
felt like an unmitigated disaster even
after the guests of honor arrived the
surprise was sprung and the evening was
in full swing Alex's brain was still in
organization mode if a drink got spilled
he dashed in and mopped it up to avoid
any lasting mess the same happened if
food was dropped or chairs were knocked
over truth be told it was actually
stopping Alex from being able to enjoy
the party he'd spend so much time
organizing that's your problem man Milo
one of his friends told him this is a
party stop trying to control everything
stop worrying you never know you might
just have some fun tonight
I suppose you're right Alex said a reply
no way you got a pinata
Milo spotted the brightly colored animal
covered in what looked like tissue paper
instantly Alex felt embarrassed that
he'd picked it up fully expecting to be
a laughing stock for bringing it to a
party surely everyone here had outgrown
a party game like that and yet to Alex's
complete surprise minutes later his
friends were taking turns being
blindfolded and swiping at the pinata
with a bat trying to break it open so
it's candy content would come spilling
out as he watched Milo take a huge swing
and miss the pinata by a mile Alex
couldn't help but laugh not even
noticing himself relaxing and enjoying
the night celebrations soon enough it
was Alex's turn to be blindfolded eyes
covered spun around unable to see
anything but total darkness he took a
wide swing at the pinata Miss pulling
back the bat spurred on by the chorus of
his friends laughing around him he gave
it another go this time he felt the hit
the vibrations traveling down the bat
and into his hands told him that it
connected in aiming blindly for that
same spot Alex gave another swing this
time with much more power behind it
certain he'd break open the candy filled
cardboard creature the bat connected
again hard enough to knock the pinata
off the string keeping it in the air
hearing his friends cheer and whoop Alex
lifted the blindfold to see the pinata
lying on the ground a few meters away
then turned to the group around him one
more to break it open the ass met with
laughs and nods of approval lifting the
bat again Alex brought it swiping down
towards the pinata with he was sure
enough Force to break it open but as he
struck it something strange happened or
rather what was strange was that nothing
happened the pinata still didn't break
it shouldn't have been possible after
all Alex was sure it had only been made
of flimsy cardboard and paper mache the
whole thing should have come apart by
now and yet the bat had lazily glanced
off the pinata the inanimate animal
seeming to resist the oncoming bat as if
it were nothing by now the other guests
at the party were looking somewhat
bemused at Alex They too had been
expecting the pinata to break and a
shower of candy within to come spilling
out not wanting to lose face Alex made
the instinctive decision to take one
final swing at it only to find he
couldn't his arm wasn't moving it had
less than 30 seconds ago he'd been able
to lift his arm but now it was rigid
locked in place Alex's lower body was in
much the same state unable to move as if
his feet had been stuck to the ground
legs too stiff to take a step the only
part of his body Alex could still move
were his eyes which now darted
frantically over the faces of the party
guests their looks of bemusement or
excited smiles were all rapidly washing
away into stairs of confusion and
concern some of his friends started
asking what was wrong but he couldn't
reply when Alex tried to speak his jaw
stayed clenched shut teeth pushed
together so hard they might shatter
tongue and tonsils Frozen still
some of the guests Drew closer waving
hands and clicking fingers in front of
Alex's face trying to elicit some kind
of movement from him a few thought it
was a joke waiting for him to suddenly
move and shout and frighten them for a
cheap laugh all the while Alex was
trapped in his own skin locked in a body
that had somehow become a prison the
moment he'd step closer to the pinata
his eyes caught sight of Milo dashing
into another room and returning with a
phone in hand he punched in three
numbers to call the emergency services
although it did little to calm the
rampant internal Panic Alex was feeling
the paramedics arrived at a record speed
by the time the ambulance pulled up at
the house most of the other party guests
had either stepped back from Alex still
standing frozen in place or had left the
party altogether as the EMTs rushed in
and started asking if he could hear them
or say anything Alex tried with every
ounce of strength to get his mouth to
move yes he wanted to say to scream just
to let all the mounting Panic out I
can't are you I'm awake I'm in here I
just can't move despite their best
efforts the paramedics couldn't get Alex
to move instead trying to lay his rigid
body down to begin CPR one of them
gripped his hands together about to
start chest compressions while everyone
still at the party watched in Silence
the paramedics gently pushed down on
Alex's chest when just like the pinata
it burst open for a microsecond Alex's
eyes widen in pain and shock before
rolling back his chest split as if it
were made of paper mache instead of skin
and bone inside where his lungs should
have been was a pile of candy the party
didn't end with a bang that night but
with a horrified scream later that night
after the rest of the party's guests
either fled home or were urged to leave
by the confused paramedics the police
were called to the scene roping off the
room where the apparent accident had
happened although curiously it seemed
that the pinata had somehow vanished
maybe someone removed it after all it's
not like it just got up and walked away
right meanwhile Alex's remains were
taken to the local Mortuary and handed
over to the Pathologists for an autopsy
they noticed despite only having died
recently the body seemed to be severely
dehydrated to the point where the limbs
the outer skin and various internal
organs were brittle the Pathologists had
examined the body made another startling
and confusing Discovery when they opened
up what was left of Alex more candy was
growing out of his organs there were
over a thousand sugary pieces each one
individually wrapped in unmarked foil
without any logos or branding needless
to say the Pathologists examining Alex's
corpse were understandably left baffled
they had never seen anything like this
in any cadaver barely able to come up
with a cause of death how had his body
gone rigid and left him completely
unable to move how had candy been able
to start growing from his internal
organs and most importantly who or what
had done this to Alex well here's what
happened something that Alex had
presumed to be nothing more than a
harmless party favor filled with
delicious treats was far from just an
ordinary pinata you see it was actually
an instance of
scp-956 although we can hardly hold Alex
entirely at fault for assuming there was
nothing different about this particular
pinata on the outside as cp956 does
appear to be an unassuming cardboard
creature made of paper mache or at least
that's what it feels like it's made of
but the surface of scp-956 is actually
constructed of unidentifiable fur glue
sugar and most unnervingly human tissue
scp-956 is an entity that normally
remains in an inactive and docile State
displaying no intelligence or active
hostility at first glance you wouldn't
even know that it can move unlike any
ordinary pinata you might buy at a local
party store which are designed to break
upon impact
scp-956 manages to maintain its
structural Integrity against most forms
of external damage whether bludgeoning
it with a bat or applying crushing force
with fists or kicks the pinata will show
virtually no change in its state the
only effective way to leave any lasting
damage is through the use of flames or
gunfire and you might have a hard time
finding any of those at your average
Pinata Party however when an unwitting
human victim comes within a five meter
range of scp-956 and for a long enough
time the entities further anomalous
qualities will activate the pinata will
render its victim totally paralyzed from
head to toe diminishing their motor
functions and leaving them unable to
move any part of their body save for
their eyes this doesn't kill the victim
however just immobilizes them they
retain full awareness just like Alex did
but can only helplessly look around
while being unable to flee and why would
they need to flee well because once it's
has frozen a victim that's when scp-956
begins its approach the pinata will
switch from being an inanimate object to
a creature capable of movement and
proceeds to physically attack its
immobile vulnerable human target it
doesn't stop continuously bludgeoning at
the victim until eventually their chest
ruptures and a pile of candy comes
tumbling out like an avalanche as for
yscp-956 didn't try to attack Alex this
way maybe someone else had a party
knocked it aside without noticing or
perhaps the paramedics managed to make
it to the scene before the pinata had
its chance whatever the case the candy
produced by a victim of scp-956 seems to
be formed using their internal organs
and bodily tissues it is unclear how
quickly this candy begins growing after
a person is exposed to the pinata
however it appears that the amount of
candy produced is dependent on how much
time the victim spends in close
proximity to scp-956 the longer they're
close to it the more pieces of candy
come spilling out when they're opened up
as for the candy itself commonly
referred to as cp956-1 as you might
expect it's far from anything you'd buy
in an ordinary store and its negative
effects aren't just limited to toothache
or Sugar Rush the pathologist that
performed Alex's post-mortem were lucky
none of them made the grave mistake of
actually eating any of this cursed candy
if they had they could have experienced
violent seizures upon consuming the
sugary confectionary within three
minutes the candy that had come bursting
out of Alex's insides would have made a
person drop to the ground unstoppably
convulsing with a chance that they would
also experience a potentially fatal
Cardiac Arrest animals will usually also
suffer these effects upon eating
instances of
scp-956-1 in humans however the effects
of the scp-956-1 candy seem to vary in
most cases those who consume it will
experience the aforementioned seizures
with with an additional five percent
risk of heart attacks but other
instances have shown an entirely
different side effect that somehow
manages to sound even less appealing the
second of the candy side effects begin
with a process very similar to the
immobilization caused by exposure to
scp-956 a person after having consumed
the Kennedy will lose control of their
body's motor functions becoming unable
to move however the first key difference
is if they remain in a standing position
with their arms resting in front of
their body the next is the rapid and
grotesque sequence of bodily changes
that follow firstly their hair rapidly
begins to fall out shedding in clumps
until it is replaced with paper mache
that grows over every inch of skin next
their bones and muscles are forcibly
rearranged crunching and contorting
unnaturally until the affected person
can no longer stand the same way they
used to in fact by that point they
aren't a person anymore within nine
minutes of eating the scp-9 26-1 candy
they will have been transformed from a
human being into a pinata from that
moment onwards they are another instance
of
scp-956 as you may have already guessed
the foundation has done us all a service
by rounding up existing instances of
scp-956 and all the candy produced by
the pernicious pinata and that is a
lucky thing too for any of you would be
party planners out there after all
nothing is harsher than coming to A
celebratory atmosphere than a pinata
that fills people with human candy that
comes bursting out of them just ask
everyone at Alex's party although maybe
it'd be a good idea to avoid buying a
pinata for your next get together just
to be on the safe side being on SCP-173
detail isn't easy these duties of strict
observation fall on a bi-weekly basis
when scp-173's enclosure needs to be
cleaned the reddish brown substance on
the floor is a natural out put of
SCP-173 a combination of feces and blood
while the foundation has put up with a
lot of depraved behavior from its scps
it draws the line at poor hygiene they
routinely send in a crew of three
d-class personnel to clean up the mess
but the bigger chore isn't the scrubbing
and mopping at all but rather keeping
SCP-173 docile to do so the line of
sight must not be broken at any time
with SCP-173 Personnel assigned to enter
the container are instructed to alert
one another before blinking if this
protocol is not followed
SCP-173 attacks by snapping the neck at
the base of the skull it is at its core
a high-stakes staring contest the crew
is intelligently divided into their
tasks only one of them actually has
janitorial duties and even then the
moppers most relevant skill isn't even
related to cleaning at all his greatest
strength must be his ability to trust
other people as he takes his mop to the
floor he hands over his life to his crew
who protect him with their focus and
attention on SCP-173 it is without a
doubt one of the cruelest and most
stressful jobs anyone could ever have
but not every horror story is found in
the trenches of Terror those with mops
on the front lines have their work cut
out for them but even the researchers
with their warm lab coats and boring
bureaucratic obligations aren't safe
from danger this is the story of Jake
skull a researcher who for reasons we
will tactfully tease you with until the
videos witty end has been reassigned to
SCP-173 director Fordham brought the bad
news like a bag of coal you're being
reassigned he said with a slight smirk
on his face continuing to be preoccupied
with his paperwork as if this news was
secondary to what he was doing right
there and then but it wasn't secondary
to Jack skull it was the center of their
life no not even just the center it was
the center peripheral and outer bounds
of their life their assignments were
everything and everything was about to
change a pregnant silence followed the
announcement Jake's skull couldn't find
a response and they weren't even sure
there was one to be found no matter how
deep they dug what came out wasn't as
much of a retort as a reaction that
involuntary bodily response to events
that weren't expected that awkward and
Afraid muttering of fear and confusion
ah I
what I am I'm being where aha
I I'm to be reassigned is that what
you're saying researchers gold blinked a
few times confused their feet sunk into
the deep forest green shag on the floor
a spectrum of thoughts cascaded through
their mind as they searched harder and
harder for a reason digging deeper and
deeper only to find another Treasure
Chest full of nothing is my work not
sufficient on SCP director Fordham
looked up and gave them the fixed
pointed stair they'd grown to dread over
the past six months of course not Jake I
recognize what you've done and we want
to put you somewhere I feel you deserve
and serve the foundation of course we're
putting you on a very important and
special object again Fordham gave that
smirk that damn smirk sure his words and
tone presented themselves as the truth
but his face said otherwise the devious
positioning of his lip suggested that
there was a layer of sinister her
subtext to his speech but Jake schole
couldn't pick up on the cues there's no
room to read someone else's poker face
when all of your attention is on the
crappy hand you've just been dealt Jake
skull's eyes fell to the desk reassigned
the word weighing like church bells why
God their work with scp-3872 as a
Consulting chemist was going slowly to
be truthful but they didn't think it was
to the point that they needed
reassignment ah all right which project
am I assigned to the time between the
question and the answer was the longest
of Jake's life the uncertainty felt like
an eternity Fordham tapped a few symbols
accessing skull's profile and added an
entry in their security clearance he
hastily swiped away all the other files
listed and turned back to face skull you
have access to it now please get on the
first plane to site 19. your dormitory
contents are already packed up Jake
reached into their pocket to check the
notification on their cell phone
scp-3872 file removed
scp-2593 file removed
SCP-173 file added they turned around
and walked slowly through the corridors
towards the Transportation Hub on the
outskirts of the site they open the file
on their phone and quickly scanned the
oddly phrased report attempting to make
sense of what they were reading skull's
eyebrows raised to the heavens as they
noticed the time stamp on containment
SCP-173 was one of the first one of the
few objects that the foundation came to
possess through some organization or
another without losing its information
they tried their best to remain
optimistic in their interpretation of
these new life events and for a moment
they thought this might be a good thing
for me swiping down they came to the
section about assigned researchers the
people whose steps they would be
following in and where were those steps
leading them the list was impressive
from Dr to Dr bright these people were
all legends in their own right and so if
they could just follow their footsteps
they reason they would end their journey
in a good place they imagine their new
career path straight to the top of this
mountain of success maybe they would
become the face of the foundation maybe
they would accomplish so much that
they'd had a statue erected in their
honor that people travel far and wide to
visit and take pictures with maybe this
would be a good thing they wanted to
think I need the first plane to site 19.
they said with confidence I've been
reassigned and so Jake skull took to the
air and clung to the stream as long as
they could but no matter how heavy a
sleeper reality shakes everyone awake
eventually six years later Jake skull
could hear the years pass but not only
could they hear it they could feel it
their body was decaying in a way
inconsistent with our biological
understanding of age
SCP-173 the legendary object the first
the original the statue it was chipping
away at the soul of Jake's skull it was
carving a statue of its own hacking at
Stone until it was nothing and that's
what Jake's skull felt like nothing it
was torture when they arrived they
quickly reviewed the research materials
every word had become burned into their
memory all 233 words of them the
additional research materials turned out
to be a few scribbled Pages by board
researchers a few had made hypotheses
that it all turned out to be nonsense
there was a locked filing cabinet but
every time skull requested it be opened
maintenance told them that the control
room was designated low priority and
they would get to it eventually over the
past six years Jake's skull had made 18
separate transfer requests they wanted
out but all of them had been denied it
was as if they were in high school again
asking dates to prom and getting it with
no thank yous feeling none of the
politeness backed into their syntax
understanding only the brutal reality of
the phrase no they were stuck here
technically a level 3 staff now but
without any rights to view or work on
any other objects they were given a
promotion but it withheld all the perks
and benefits that come with it they were
stuck in a loop of pats on the back
people extended them their hand but it
was always with an empty Palm giving
them nothing to hold on to but a gesture
they were assigned a staff of four three
d-class all of which were older men and
a lazy level 2 security officer who
slouched in his office chair meeting the
bare minimum requirements to be
considered a living human being the
d-class were all quite docile they came
in once a week mopped the floor mumbled
clear to each other and left they lived
within this exact structure no new days
became an unspoken motto the these
recurring 24 hours pass slowly if there
were no clocks to prove the passing of
time they would have every reason to
believe it had frozen over but
occasionally ever so occasionally the
day would deviate just slightly they'd
hear something a scrape and the sounds
of movement Jake would flip open the
observation ports on the double concrete
lock and examine SCP-173 but Jake could
take offense to such language examining
might be the wrong word more accurately
they would just look at it because there
was nothing to examine there was nothing
to observe
SCP-173 was already understood Michael
Jordan doesn't take a microscope to the
ball every time he plans to dribble he
knows every detail of it by heart his
fingertips know the grooves his hand-eye
coordination knows how to control it his
right arms built in apt for physics
knows exactly how much force to put into
each shot and at what trajectory to aim
we are told to learn something new every
day but the truth is there comes a day
when the learning stops when we know all
that we will ever know and this felt
true to Jake they understood
SCP-173 there was nothing more for them
to see it was just concrete Reebok and
some spray paint that was it and that
was all that it would ever be there was
nothing to find nothing to determine
nothing for the researcher to research
their job was done but they kept having
to work it their identity no longer fit
but they kept having to put it on each
and every morning when Jake first got
there they collected samples of the
concrete some of the rebars some spray
paint they were determined to find
something worthy of research after four
weeks they'd gotten sick of getting no
replies from admin and they cracked the
locks on the filing cabinet finding the
research notes of all the previous
researchers all the legendary doctors
notes turned out to be Doodles and
random to-do lists which had nothing to
do with the object after six weeks they
gave up on taking samples after eight
weeks they brought a cane boy after 10
they started bringing in anything they
could to pass the time a yo-yo a
collection of short stories a packet of
hot sauce they felt bad throwing away a
piece of string to cut off circulation
to their index finger for no other
reason than to make sure they were still
a human relying on blood oh yes Jake's
skull was bored so very bored they
thought if anyone could bring the phrase
bored to death to fruition it would be
them these days they shuffled in and
waved at the guard and sat down at their
little control room where there was a
terminal which by the way didn't have an
internet connection and tried to stay
sane fast forward a few years and Jake
barely fit into his chair to clarify no
they did not purchase a new tiny chair
out of Fordham they got fat out of
boredom their life brought them no joy
and so what they couldn't get from
living they searched for in eating but
there was no fulfillment to be found at
the center of the Tootsie Pop Jake stood
with a grunt as the light came on and
the 3D class were escorted to the
control room with the mops and buckets
in tow thanks Jimmy was the only
conversation they had with the new
security staff the Old Guard had retired
some time in the eighth year honestly
Jay couldn't even remember the d-class
had gotten older too most of them now
gray-haired but still assigned to the
project the security guard walked over
and thumbed towards the break room Hey
Jake I'm gonna get coffee if anything
happens seal the door you know the drill
just keep an eye on the DS Jake buzzed
the doors open and stood inside the door
frame keeping their eyes on the Statue
most of the time but but wandering over
the containment chamber a long time ago
they might have been concerned but the
d-classes they worked with weren't very
violent frankly they had worked with
these men long enough that they extended
a small measure of trust all did their
jobs without complaining and never had
made a mistake in 10 years while the
years of repetition wore them out the
job itself didn't even feel like labor
they had perfected the art of the
staring contest they were confident and
they had reason to be as the years went
on although they collected no new data
on SCP-173 they did collect evidence
evidence that they were capable of
containing it while they learned nothing
new of importance about SCP-173 they
learned about themselves they learned
that they were a good crew and it was
because of this confidence even if
rightfully earned that success crumbled
when in a room with SCP-173 you have to
assume everything will go wrong because
anything can go wrong and eventually it
will and when that time comes you have
to be prepared procedure said Jake had
to have someone armed in the room with
any d-class Jake looked down at their
head double checked the pistol there
they knew how to use it but figured he
never would have to draw it the routine
cleaning began Claire Claire Claire it
was the same old same old until suddenly
it wasn't clear oh no I think I'm having
a snap what hey hey Nick are you snap oh
God no I don't wanna snap Jake's eyes
shot up as the statue stood inches away
its green eyes stared directly into
their soul in their periphery Jay could
see the 3D class with their head turned
at odd angles Jake desperately reached
out for the Emergency containment button
on the wall they hadn't ever had to use
it and it was supposed to be easy to
find but of course it wasn't they were
called the manual saying move your hand
anywhere along the right hand wall the
button takes up most of the wall it will
seal off the containment chamber and
SCP-173 from breaching containment they
moved their hand exactly how their
memory of the manual instructor
but it wasn't there there was nothing to
press there was nothing to save them
Jake's hands grew desperate and their
eyes began to water just as they started
to close a last thought crossed their
mind move your hand anywhere along the
left hand wall the button takes up most
of the wall it will seal off the
containment chamber and SCP-173 from
breaching containment of course a
classic mix-up 50 50 chances never
favored the flustered their
fight-or-flight instincts were
contradicting each other was reaching
for button fighting or was it fighting
they were in their head deep in trenches
of overthinking finally they regained
their composure their hand darted out to
the left and they started to push down
on the button the red of the emergency
button filled their Vision as the green
eyes of SCP-173 slipped just barely out
of snap director Kinsley stood outside
of the meeting room a few minutes before
the weekly briefing in the site 2117
administrative Wing Fordham do you
remember Jake's skull oh yeah I sure do
just got a report from 19. looks like
there was a breach and they bit it
Fordham waved off a few colleagues who
were about to enter the meeting room his
conversation with director Kinsley
wasn't over he went on to tell him that
he was just about to approve Jake
scholes transfer after all these years
Jake had been sending requests to leave
SCP-173 their wish was about to be
granted but instead they were reassigned
to the Grave what a cruel twist isn't it
that is of course if it were actually
true Fordham gave his patented smirk
just kidding the only researchers to
ever get out of that post needed friends
in very high places scroll to his
detriment did not so what exactly did
skull do to deserve this it is known
that those who are sent to a cp-173 have
made mistakes if you disrespect your
boss you might be reassigned to SCP-173
if you don't follow Foundation policy
you might
into SCP-173 if you leak information to
the public you might be reassigned to
SCP-173 if you are Jake scroll however
it doesn't take quite as much so I will
pose the question once more what
horrible thing could Jake have done
could they have been plotting to help an
array of scps Escape could they have
been smuggling dangerous equipment from
the lab and selling it on the black
market could they have somehow been
responsible for every casualty and
Foundation history or could it have been
something much much smaller like
occasionally parking in their boss's
favorite spot on site 217 a lot you must
understand which doesn't have a signed
parking the tiny carnivorous snowmen are
Relentless sharp fangs dripping with
blood as they crawl on mass towards the
mobile task force opening fire on them
with their assault rifles who would have
guessed that a mere hour or two earlier
a young boy was joyfully playing around
in the snow here how had things gone
from Frosty to freaky so fast let's
rewind the clock there was a chill in
the air that lingering biting coal that
would gnaw in your Exposed Skin if you
dare to step outside in anything less
than a thick warm coat for protection
the ground was still coated in a heavy
snowfall a holdover from Christmas just
passed whether that had refused to let
up well into the early days of the New
Year everyone reaches an age where the
cynicism of Life the weight of
expectations that keep you anchored in
the real world they all coalesce to rob
you of the childlike wonder of the snow
as you get older the snow loses its
novelty it becomes a source of
inconvenience something that you need to
shovel off the driveway to take your car
out whereas turn the clock back to Youth
and it's like a tiny Miracle It Coats
your whole world in a clean blanket of
freezing Frost turning the ordinary into
a 1 land Robert and Michaela Anderson
were glad that their son Michael was
still at an age where he could enjoy the
snow after all Michaela getting to take
her son out in a sled or seeing him
hurling snowballs at Robert was able to
provide them with a little bit of warmth
during the freezing cold snowier months
in Missouri optimism was never enough to
melt the snow however then maybe that's
what drew in those creatures the snowmen
it was early 2019 not even a full two
weeks into the Year by now Michael had
gotten used to the fact that after
Christmas and New Year's Day a
begrudging return to school would soon
follow as much as it clearly brought
down his mood nothing lifted his spirits
like still getting to be out in the snow
and after a long day of helping his mom
take down the tinsel and pack up the
lights while his dad disposed of the
tree Michael was itching to go outside
please Mom he begged as a box of
decorations was placed back in the attic
his hands clasped together in a pleading
gesture please please please just five
minutes I I won't go further than the
front yard Michaela sighed partly from
exhaustion but a smile crept onto her
face it was hard not to find her son's
love for the snow endearing all right
but only for five minutes she insisted
firmly and I want to see gloves hat and
a scarf not just a coat Mister with the
speed and excitement that she and her
husband had long since lost she watched
Michael race off to gather his warmest
winter coat remember when we were like
that Robert heave decides he appeared
from chopping up that dried out
dehydrated remains of the Christmas tree
no do you Michaela replied with a light
chuckle before long Michael had donned
his gloves and coat almost a size too
big his scarf was almost wrapping up his
entire head save for the little
bobblehead that poked out at the top
Robert opened up the front door and his
son stepped out into a world that had
been whitewashed with clear cold snow
give even that the Andersons lived on a
small Street in Grain Valley there
weren't many other people around
especially not with another flurry of
snowfall moving closer in the clouds up
above but it wasn't the next snowfall
that the residents of Grain Valley
Missouri should have been worrying about
it was the previous one the one that had
already fallen and what was now hiding
among the snow in the Anderson family's
front yard having few other kids his own
age to play with and not being allowed
to venture too far from the front porch
Michael was content to spend his
precious time Outdoors making snow
angels or practicing throwing snowballs
he had long been trying to get one to
clear the roof of the small house he and
his parents shared leaving a few
scattered patches of snow embedded on
the roof shingles a few meters from the
front door stood a snowman granted that
was hardly a rare sight at this time of
year especially in the cold weather but
what was so unusual about it was that
Michael hadn't remembered making a
Snowman recently his parents hadn't let
him out in the snow on his own since the
start of the New Year given how badly
the downfall and icy winds had been for
the first week of January sure somebody
else could have made it taking a pause
as they passed by the Anderson's front
yard although not Michael Nor either of
his parents had spotted anyone doing
that the Snowman itself was featureless
the white of its ice cold body smeared
with mud and Dead Leaves debris that had
been packed in with the snow used in its
crude construction it was featureless
too whoever had made it hadn't gone to
the effort of giving it a phase nor
draped an old scarf over it or given it
a hat it just stood there but not like
any other snowman there was nothing
welcoming about it in fact it was
fittingly cold given how far away it
stood it was almost as if it was
watching the house curiously Michael
began to approach the Snowman being only
nine years old his imagination was
immediately running with the possibility
that this snow and mulch construct could
be alive much akin to the likes of
Frosty the Snowman little did young
Michael Anderson know that he wasn't far
away from the truth although this
particular snowman wasn't quite the
happy Jolly soul from the much covered
holiday song he hadn't got that much
closer to the Snowman when he heard
something move nearer to where he stood
there was the rustle of leaves and the
Snapping of small Twigs coming up from a
bush next to him Michael couldn't see
what it was but it was far too low to
the ground and too close to the house
for it to be a bird maybe a possum or
raccoon had gotten trapped in the thin
branches and was now scrambling to try
and free itself diverting from
approaching the Snowman he walked closer
to the plant as he did the rustling got
louder more frantic almost hungry there
wasn't just one creature lurking out of
sight beneath the leaves but lots of
some things Robert and Michaela had been
sitting indoors watching the TV when
they heard a spine chilling scream
coming from outside instantly they were
both up on their feet racing toward the
front door Robert threw it open and
Michael dashed inside in floods of
fearful tears what happened sweetie
Michaela asked concerned brushing
snowflakes from her son's coat are you
okay did you slip through crying and
sniffling shaking uncontrollably with
how afraid he was Michael couldn't find
the words to answer instead he pointed
through the still open door directly at
the Snowman still standing at the edge
of the front yard how long has that been
there Robert wondered aloud taking a
single step outside don't dad Michael
screamed but it was already too late
something small and Speedy had leaped
out of the snow in the front yard and
latched onto Robert's leg he howled as
he felt searing pain bitten by rows of
tiny pointed teeth as sharp as needles
and as bitterly cold as ice stumbling
back Robert Anderson fell over and
landed on the floor in the front hallway
inadvertently carrying whatever had
attacked him into his home both Michaela
and Michael screamed in fear as the tiny
creature clawed its way up Robert's leg
while he swatted at it frantically
trying to brush it away before it could
get closer with a blind swipe of his
hand he knocked the creature to the
floor and clambered to his feet arms
outstretched keeping his wife and son
behind him while staring into disbelief
at what had bitten him it was barely
more than half a meter tall a tiny white
snowman bulbous bloodied eyes bulged
from its head much like those of an
insect directly between the eyes was a
hole a mouth not unlike a lamprey lined
with rows of sharp teeth that all
pointed inwards it reared up and lunged
toward the Anderson family in a display
of aggression that caused all three of
them to jump rarely backing away from
the snow creature it was then that
Robert and Michaela noticed what had
frightened their son so much out of the
corner of their eye they both
simultaneously caught the sight of the
open front door and the yard Beyond
wriggling through the snow shifting as
they moved or even more of the creatures
slithering towards the house like
piranhas catching the scent of blood in
the water and standing ominously just
beyond the driveway was the Snowman as
if it was the General commanding its
troops to storm the house the Andersons
raced upstairs as the swarm of snow
creatures came spilling into the house
crawling from the yard onto the floor
and piling on top of each other like
ants to climb the stairs naturally
Michaela's first instinct as well as
protecting her son was to call the
police while Robert Held the door to the
bedroom shut Michaela held Michael close
and pleaded with the local grain Valley
Police Department to come and help them
although they only seemed to take the
call seriously when Michael started
screaming again one of the snow
creatures had pushed its way under the
door frame and was sneaking its way
towards Robert to attack him leaving a
trail of water behind it stepping back
and Thinking Fast Robert grabbed a hair
dryer and switched to Dawn full blast
the Sudden Rush of electrically heated
air caused the toothy snow creature to
retreat into a corner refusing to let up
Robert closer and kept the hairdryer
trained on it eventually causing the
creature to melt until little more was
left than a damp puddle but the victory
was momentary there were still more of
them crawling up the stairs after the
Andersons with their sharp teeth they
were gnawing at the wood of the bedroom
door trying to force their way inside
fortunately for Robert Michaela and
their son Michael they wouldn't be able
to recall the horrific events of January
12 2019 for much longer by the time the
local police arrived it had become clear
to the officers responding that they
were well out of their depth especially
when one of them was injured suffering a
bite from a snow creature that was what
led the SCP Foundation being called in
and within 15 minutes they had
dispatched mobile task force operatives
to secure the anomaly being some of the
foundation's most highly trained agents
it didn't take long for the MTF to
neutralize the carnivorous snow
creatures however they quickly realized
that the mysterious snowmen that had
seemingly spawned the Swarm could not be
melted by any conventional mean
nor would it deteriorate naturally on
its own a cover story was issued that
Michael had suffered an accident and
fallen down an open pothole that had
become obscured by heavy snowfall as a
result police officers were dispatched
to help him although the injury
sustained by one officer due to a bite
from a snow creature was never explained
following this the Anderson family was
administered amnestics meaning they
quickly forgot about the whole
terrifying ordeal maybe it was for the
best however young Michael seemed
irreparably changed he never went out to
enjoy the snow again repeatedly
suffering from nightmares about the cold
meanwhile the anomalous snowman was
recovered and thus designated as
scp-4230 immediately the SCP Foundation
did as their organization does best and
commenced testing with a human subject
no less they quickly discovered that
scp-4230 seemed to generate a sort of
field around itself that could trigger a
distinctive physiological change in any
human being or animal that came within
six meters of the Snowman this process
became known under the designation of
scp-4230-1 it appeared that Michael
Anderson had managed to unknowingly
escape this fate purely by not getting
too close to scp-4230 staying just far
enough away so as not to trigger
scp-4230-1 the foundation placed
d-19375 a member of their d-class
personnel within this six meter radius
of the Snowman and observed the gradual
changes he underwent over the following
week for simplicity's sake we'll refer
to d-19375 as frost a rather fitting
moniker and you'll soon see why within a
day of exposure to the Snowman Frost
complained to a senior researcher that
he felt a lot colder than usual although
he exhibited no other observable
symptoms beyond the coughing and
sniffling of a common cold by the
following day Frost was far worse for
wear appearing to have lost significant
body mass to the point where he'd
appeared to have been nourished his
cold-like symptoms had continued
accompanied by disorienting dizziness
and as if all that wasn't bad enough his
skin tone had seemingly lost its natural
pigment reduced to an unnaturally pale
shade as white as snow day three saw
Frost's body continue to change rapidly
at an alarming rate he was internally
producing an unknown chemical that
looked to be responsible for enacting
certain alterations namely the
dissolving of his femur and fibula the
cold and dizziness were also now made
all the worse by the addition of pain to
the man's lower body Frost even reported
to Foundation researchers studying him
that every movement he was able to make
caused him to suffer extreme levels of
physical pain but yet rather than
attempt to cure his condition the
foundation apathetically observed noting
down the process of
scp-4230-1 within five days of exposure
to scp-4230 naturally occurring
substances within Frost's body had
traveled downwards and solidified died
this was followed by the most shocking
stage of the scp-4230-1 process so far
and one that made the foundation realize
that these weren't just changes it was a
transformation when day five saw Frost's
skeleton physically reshaping itself his
head becoming a sphere and his arms
extending outwards like brittle Twigs it
soon became clear what was happening to
him he was turning into a snowman
rendered immobile and blind a week after
scp-4230-1 began to take effect Frost
had started to secrete an unknown
substance this liquid lowered his body
temperature freezing almost instantly
and turning his skin into an icy white
Mass worryingly similar to snow sure
enough on the Eighth Day the extent of
the scp-4230-1 process was made evident
Frost had already perished his body now
looking identical to a plain featureless
Snowman no eyes or face just a blank
cold slate but underneath the outer
layer of snow Frost's bones and the rest
of his organs were still contained
inside from the outside though he wasn't
even human anymore just an instance of
what became known as
scp-4230-a however being turned into
another Snowman by close proximity to
scp-4230 wasn't even the worst part by
now you might be wondering what were
those snow creatures that attacked the
Andersons you'd be forgiven for thinking
that perhaps these were rodents or other
wild animals affected by scp-4230-1
after all testing has shown that the
process doesn't just alter human
physiology but these carnivorous needle
tooth creatures are known as
scp-4230-bs and they are nasty little
critters to say the least when a person
or animal is turned into a snowman
during
scp-4230-1 becoming one of these
instances is far from the full extent of
the transformation the test the
foundation conducted on Frost and
presumably on numerous other d-class
personnel as well led to them
discovering the further alterations made
when someone becomes an
scp-4230-a instance their freezing snow
in case bodies become hosts for white
spherical eggs after a subject like
frost becomes an
scp-4230-a snowman these eggs will hatch
within 72 hours producing up to 19
instances of
scp-4230-b creatures the foundation was
quick to examine these bizarre snow
spawn Gathering up as many as they could
for testing they found that instances of
scp-4230-b matured to adulthood
remarkably quickly reaching adulthood in
15 seconds destroying the eggs
containing these creatures seemed to be
an effective way of preventing swarms of
scp-4230-bs from getting loose although
the Snowman each egg came from would
also have to be destroyed to achieve
this result also the lifespans of the
smaller snow no creatures only lasted
for a total of 24 hours and they would
melt away after a full day of life
regardless of the surrounding
temperature
scp-4230-b seem uninterested in food
that was presented to them specifically
one test involved giving a snow creature
a head of lettuce and a watermelon the
creature regarded the fruit and
vegetables with little interest even
refusing to eat either despite prompts
from the researchers this painted the
scp-4230-bs as exclusive carnivores
which explained why they attacked the
Anderson family they were trying to eat
them hunting the Andersons as a pack
further testing into
scp-4230-bs revealed they had a weakness
to heat above a temperature of 40
degrees Fahrenheit during another test a
d-class was sent into a cell with 10 of
the carnivorous snow creatures armed
only with a simple lighter an emergency
flare and one gallon of gasoline
immediately all 10 of the
scp-4230-bs crawled toward the man
hungry and determined him to be a new
source of food that is until they
noticed the lighter he was carrying the
d-class frantically clicked the spark
wheel until the flame danced from the
lighter causing seven of the creatures
to back away from the heat Source
cautiously the d-class was able to kill
the remaining three instances in
self-defense causing them to melt with
little effort he was Far luckier than
the subject of the next test would be
another d-class was placed in a holding
cell with three of the snow creatures
and much like before they instantly
acknowledged his presence and began
approaching him however the foundation
had sent this member of d-class in
completely unarmed without even so much
as a match to defend himself the
carnivorous beasts made short work of
their helpless victim feeding on what
was left the foundation was able to
dispatch instances of
scp-4230-b with relative ease even
without waiting for them to Simply melt
after a day the use of flamethrowers or
drawing them into warmer areas seemed
effective enough at destroying the small
snowman that hatched out of SCP 4230-a
bodies however some bright spark at the
foundation decided to test what would
happen if the opposite element was used
against
scp-4230-b creatures were they
vulnerable to the snow despite being
made from a snow-like substance
themselves another test was conducted to
answer this which involved a small
snowball being thrown at one of the
scp-4230-bs the result of that incident
has been entirely expunged from the
foundation's archives but it's a safe
guess to ask why evidently when attacked
using snow or ice
scp-4230-bs are seemingly able to adapt
in some way that is determined to their
attacker do they add snow to their mass
or become even more aggressive it's hard
to say given the redactions but the
result of that final test were deemed so
catastrophic that the foundation banned
any further testing that involved
scp-4230-bs as for where
scp-4231st came from the foundation is
still baffled the first reported
incident involving the Killer Snowman
and the carnivorous creatures It
produced came when the Andersons found
themselves Under Siege by hungry
scp-4230-bs maybe the Snowman is just a
freak of nature or the result of an
unknown pathogen or microorganism
carried in a snowstorm one fateful night
or perhaps
scp-4230 is something far far more
vicious whatever the case we would
recommend waiting for the sun to come
back out and the snow to melt just to be
safe it's hard to believe it's been over
three whole months since those monsters
came to town if only I had known back
then what they were really doing here
maybe I could have stopped it I don't
know so much of this is beyond me what
could I have done even if I had known
about it could I have stopped what
happened to all those people sickness
sarcasm the SCP Foundation it's all such
a blur but for a while I can still
remember how I spent 100 days in full
trading a circuit cult it All Began on a
pretty ordinary day I live in a small
Lumber Town most of the areas cut off
from major cities connected only by
Miles and Miles of Winding Road through
the forest it's a quiet rural place and
the low-tech way of life our main
business has been Timber generations of
tree cutters even in the Modern Age we
keep that going although my home has
always been off the Beaten Track we
often had our fair share of visitors
hikers and Wanderers who would sometimes
stumble upon the town quite by accident
yet be so enthralled by open Natural
Beauty on offer but they just have to
spend a night at the only hotel in town
the woodsman's lodge run by my friend
Andreas that's what we thought they were
at first just visitors that's why we
welcome them when they arrived because
not one of us had any idea who these
people really were what they really were
we could have never known that they had
chosen Our Town specifically and come
here on purpose many of the wearier
among Our Town thought these newcomers
were strange they were a group of five
very obviously full of cash but less
obvious was the reasons for coming here
when friendly townsfolk try to drum up
conversation with any of them they all
seem to report the same thing that these
strangers were aloof and each one gave a
dramatically different answer as to why
they had come to our quite little
logging Community one said their group
was just sightseeing another said they
had gotten lost someone else from their
group told a local man that they were
here on a mission from someone called
karcissist varus and was rumored to have
been quickly silenced by another in the
visitor's party but the one thing they
all seemingly agreed on was that they
wouldn't be any trouble they insisted on
that in fact and said that the five of
them were just looking for somewhere to
sleep bed and bored in exchange for cash
and so someone pointed them in the
direction of andreas's Hotel I was often
there myself not as a guest but helping
my friend maintain the place he'd
inherited the hotel from his family but
it was always in need of repair luckily
my background was in carpentry and I was
more than happy to help Andreas
it wasn't one of your fancy furnished
hotels you know the kind you'd find in
the big city all slick and sleek and
owned by a big chain it was homely a
more bed and breakfast type of place it
was anyway whenever I was working over
at the woodsmans I'd observed the
strange group of visitors from a
distance they didn't seem to me like
average tourists or sightseers to me
they looked wealthy very wealthy it
wasn't hard to picture any one of them
as a politician or a businessman the way
they dressed and carried themselves made
it pretty clear they were people of
influence of course that begged the
question what on Earth were people like
that doing in a town like this I first
got to speak with one of them after a
few days the five newcomers were down a
man and didn't seem at all happy about
that the remaining four were grumpy
looking anchored and agitated I wondered
if maybe their fifth compatriot had left
in the night but when I asked around
town apparently nobody had seen him
unless he's crazy and decided to hike
through the woods on his own in the
middle of the night one of my friend
scoffed after telling me that no one had
even heard any cars leaving the night
before I decided to ask one of the
visitors when he passed me in the
hallway of the woodsman's lodge trying
to broach the topic as tactically as I
could sorry to see you're down a man I
told him he stopped in this tracks like
I just caught him doing something he
shouldn't be yes yes he replied not
turning around to face me it is a
terrible shame and a terrible shame
indeed but he had to leave us it was for
his own good he knew that well following
that odd encounter things got all the
stranger the following day I arrived at
the woodsman's again expecting to start
another day of work I'd gotten a call
from Andreas earlier that morning he was
complaining about some kind of
squelching noise coming from the
basement under the hotel that had only
started last night I told him I wasn't a
plumber but that I'd take a look so
imagine my surprise when I saw Andreas
loading most of his worldly possessions
up into a truck outside of the front of
the hotel he excitedly explained to me
that he'd been bought out with the
remaining four newcomers had offered to
buy the wood on the spot but that's your
family's Hotel Andreas I reminded him as
if it was already too late I was never
gonna keep it afloat forever he Shrugged
when they told me how much they were
willing to pay I couldn't refuse would
have done the same ingvar I've never
been offered so much money this all made
it very clear these guests were here to
stay it had taken less than a week for
me to grow suspicious of these people it
wasn't in my nature to pry but so much
about them just didn't make any sense
they were clearly Rich enough to buy
andreas's Hotel like it was nothing just
like an ordinary everyday purchase like
buying a loaf of bread but they were far
too insular to seemingly want to run a
hotel for our friendly logging Town it
left me scratching my head over the
whole thing making the question of what
they were really up to stick out like an
unignorable Splinter were these just
careless Rich folk with more money than
sense had they somehow grown
disillusioned with their wealthy
affluent Lifestyles we're now using this
hotel to learn how to connect with
people on a more fulfilling personal
level or did they have a different
agenda something else that they were
trying to hide it turns out they did I
decided to formally introduce myself to
the new owners of the woodsmans after
all I knew this place well it always
needed something repaired plus if I
could keep my little side job of working
there as a handyman going then maybe I
could find out exactly what they were
doing I was greeted by the man I'd
spoken briefly to the other day looking
at me with the skull as I stood in the
doorway hello sir I greeted warmly met
with silence uh we uh we met the other
day what do you want oh well um I
continued disarmed by the bluntness I
understand your group just bought this
place I had a gentleman's agreement with
the last owner I'd help him out fix
things that need fixing I just thought I
should offer the same service to you if
you'd be interested might help get this
hotel up and running nice and quick for
you so you can start making a return on
your investment with that the door was
unceremoniously slammed in my face at
first it certainly seemed like my
options for uncovering more about this
strange group were all but depleted or
at least doing so through any legitimate
means but just as I was reaching a
desperate point where I was considering
donning a balaclava and breaking into
the hotel in the dead of night
opportunity re-emerged from behind that
closed door we were sorry to turn you
away yesterday one of the other visitors
apologized somewhat insincerely but we
would be delighted to take you up on
your offer provided you accept a few
conditions conditions I echoed what
would those be we would need you to
start on repairs immediately we want to
open up the hotel's doors to guests in
the next few days as a matter of urgency
he explained but you will need to be
discreet privacy is very important to us
so we hope to maintain that for our
guests it all seemed like a lot of Hoops
to jump through certainly more than
Andreas had ever given me when he used
to run the woodsmans but it felt like
the right call if at least it got me
closer to answers in hindsight I should
have turned them down over the course of
the next week things seemed to run
relatively normally I'd be given a
checklist of things to fix around the
hotel and for the most part just focus
purely on the tasks at hand but whenever
the strange new owners were near I'd try
to subtly listen in on their
conversations they seem to mostly talk
about running the hotel though like they
knew I was around a few tourists started
showing up in fact it seemed to get much
busier than usual pretty quickly I asked
one of the odd owners about it and he
just brushed it off as the result of
their group's marketing the woodsman's
lodge more widely on the internet I
didn't see much of the hotel's guests
staying out of their way as I'd been
instructed to but it did strike me as
odd how few of them seem to leave some I
spotted around town usually those
traveling as a couple or in a larger
group any that were staying alone though
they didn't seem to venture beyond the
woodsmans none of them checked out
either but their rooms would be empty
and often needing repairs mainly scratch
marks on the wooden floorboards two and
a half weeks after that weird group had
arrived and bought up my friend's Hotel
I got a call from someone I knew who
lived next door to the woodsmans the
hotel some one was screaming she said
frantically over the line get her quick
they might need you I checked the time
it was the dead of night so late that it
was almost the start of the next day
racing quickly over to the hotel I was
greeted by one of the owners he'd rushed
to the door wide awake like he hadn't
even been sleeping when I told him there
were reports of blood curdling screams
he reprimanded me you were told our
guests privacy must be maintained he
scolded if you must know one of the
hikers staying with us tripped over and
had a nasty fall he landed downstairs in
the basement and he's in a lot of pain
not to be moved we've already called for
an ambulance I wanted to take what he
said at face value but the fact he
wouldn't let me see the injured man felt
suspicious I spent the night with the
person who lived next door to the hotel
watching the woodsman's launch for any
sign of ambulance it never arrived that
was when I remembered he had said the
guest fell into the basement the same
basement Andreas had heard a strange
squelching coming from and not once had
these new owners asked me to take a look
down there already I was even further
suspicious of the new owners now I had
no idea what they were up to the wild
theories in my head range from them
being a group of sadistic serial killers
using the hotel to lure victims or a
shadowy government Black Ops team up to
something nefarious enough was enough I
needed answers I couldn't wait for an
opportunity I had to create one while as
few people were in the hotel as possible
I snuck into the main office not to
steal anything or even Peak just yet or
break the legs off a desk if they asked
me to fix it then I'd be able to spend
longer in the office with no supervision
sure enough they soon asked me if I'd be
able to fix the desk and that was my way
in I started rummaging through the
filing cabinets rifling through whatever
I could find old expense reports legal
documents left behind by Andreas but
there was nothing that could give me any
inkling as to what was actually going on
until there was you see as much as it
came as a surprise to no one more than
me I wasn't the only one looking into
this new strange group one of the guests
entered the office and quickly realized
what he was doing at first he seemed to
imply that I was somehow in a league
with the new owners but I was able to
talk him around telling him I was just
trying to get to the bottom of what they
were up to that was when he revealed to
me who he was agent clerkson he
introduced himself I'm here on behalf of
the SCP Foundation after he brought me
up to speed on what the hell all that
meant we arranged to reconvene somewhere
they wouldn't overhear us meeting up at
the lumber mill he explained that these
four strangers were a cult a subsect of
a strange religion I had never heard of
called sarcasism but after agent
clericsen described their practices I
wouldn't soon forget ritualistic
sacrifices cannibalism and even far far
worse than that it made me feel sick
just hearing about it over the next few
days clericson agreed to let me help in
his investigation offering me the chance
to help the foundation and make it so
that nobody in my remote little logging
town would ever have to suffer the
memory what the sarcic cult were up to
little did I realize he also meant me I
did my best to spy on the death and
disease worshiping cultists without
drawing too much suspicion and reported
my findings back to the foundation agent
but it quickly became clear that he was
unimpressed with my current method of
just eavesdropping so instead he
suggested a more direct approach
clericsson gave me a book on the sarkic
religion telling me to memorize as much
as I could and then approach the
cultists as if I shared in their Twisted
beliefs even reading the techniques of
grand karcissist ion was enough to make
my stomach turn all the grotesque things
that the founder of this cult's beliefs
preached in order to achieve something
akin to godhood it was horrific what was
much more horrific though was that our
plan went awry I asked to speak alone
with one of the cultists and instantly
started explaining that I have observed
them for a time and I come to realize
that we were one and the same in a state
of panic I regurgitated anything I could
still remember from reading about
sarcasism their goal to achieve
apotheosis through will the consumption
of gods and sacrifice but I must have
said something wrong one of them stuck
up behind me and knocked me unconscious
I'm woke up in a daze the splitting
headache running through my skull I was
in a cage and a part of the hotel I
hadn't seen before it was dark absent of
natural light there are others too I
recognized one or two of the hotel's
single guests also trapped in cages
agent Clarkson was nowhere to be found
the sarkic cultists spent the next day
asking me how I had found them I told
them the truth and answered their
questions the only way I knew how but I
couldn't make them believe me liar one
spat you did your homework I'll admit
but the foundation is known for working
in Broad Strokes missing out on the
finer details we're neosakites another
explained you were spouting the
teachings of the proto-sarkic religion
we believe the only way of becoming a
god achieving the apotheosis is through
sheer will and in terms of sacrifice one
of the other cultists chimed in will
sacrifice many in service of us few but
you'll soon come to witness more of that
they kept me in the cage for days
without food and barely any water I felt
so drained of energy before long and I
soon realized why no one had heard the
captive guests calling out for help they
were so weak that they could barely
gather enough strength to shout and
those that did their voices were too
weak to reach anyone above the basement
the cultists came and went all
throughout the day alternating between
running the woodsman's lodge and coming
down into the dark cramped and
disgusting room below the stench was
foul yet not one of the sarcic cultists
seemed to mine they would just talk
endlessly about the new age of Flesh
before dragging their next victim out of
their cage at night and taking them into
a back room by this point all the
remaining Hotel guests that had been
caged up with me were gone I could never
fully see what went on in the other room
but I certainly heard a lot there were
muffled screens followed by chanting in
a language I didn't understand then came
the noise of something slithering all
the while the cultists who had gathered
in the room with their captive victim
kept reciting their incantations I had
no idea what was going on in there but
the hotel guests never re-emerged just
the sarkites I'd read enough about their
rituals to get a pretty good idea I'd
lost track of how long I'd been prisoner
when aging Clarkson appeared in the
basement The cultists Backs have been
turned just long enough for him to slip
downstairs undetected for a moment I
thought I was saved only for my heart to
sink when he told me he couldn't get me
out I pleaded with him but he insisted
that he needed to know exactly what was
going on down here as he left me on my
own I cursed him under my breath before
much long the cultists decided it was my
turn they dragged me out of my cage and
into the back room strapping me to a
chair I had no strength to fight back
but I had plenty of fear there were more
cages back here it was an old store room
that they were now keeping nightmares in
the things in the cages were disgusting
Abominations masses of bloody gooey
flesh flesh that had one human I
realized these were the hotel guests the
ones who traveled alone who never
checked out whose fingernails had left
scratches on the floorboards as they
were dragged out of the rooms by the
cultists using a cattle prod one of the
sarkites started directing a creature
towards me the horrible mutant was
getting closer an appendage resembling
an arm reaching out at me it was going
to turn me into one of them and I
couldn't stop it scared for my life I
mustered the little energy I had left to
try and pull away from the sickening
creature but just as it was about to
make contact someone kicked down the
door agent clericsson had returned with
reinforcements members of a mobile task
force that promptly arrested the sarkic
cultists and sealed the room containing
the monsters for the time being he sat
down next to me and explained what had
gone on but I was barely awake enough to
keep up with all the details something
about
scp-610 instances and rare to see them
this far out of Siberia but he promised
that the SCP Foundation would be
ordering the creatures to be incinerated
soon the woodsman's lodge would have to
be burned down as part of the cover
story as for me I just want to forget
the whole ordeal the sarkic cult all the
people they turned into monsters the
horrifying things they do the scp-610s
all of it I want it all gone luckily
agent Clarkson has given me something he
says will help with that he called it an
amnestic won an anomaly of your own
check out scpswag.com for high quality
SCP merch now go check out what does
this secret SCP religion believe in and
I survived 100 days hiding from the SCP
Foundation here's what happened for more
mysterious SCP offerings